WE WERE GOING TO START A
ONE O'CLOCK BUT THAT DIDN'T WORK
OUT SO WE'RE GONNA START AT ONE
TWENTY SOMETHING SO- COUPLE OF
NOTES BEFORE WE START HEARING
TODAY- BEFORE I BEGIN I'D LIKE
TO MAKE A STATEMENT PROVIDING
EVERY PROVIDING ABOUT PROVIDING
TESTIMONY AT THIS HEARING. WE
SEEK TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
ALL WHO PARTICIPATE THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SO WE CAN
HAVE EFFECTIVE DELIBERATION ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE GOAL OF THIS
HEARING WE WILL NOT PERMIT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OTHERWISE IMPORT IMPEDES THE
ORDERLY PROGRESS. OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. WE WILL
NOT ACCEPT BEHAVIOR THAT INCITES
THREATENS VIOLENCE OR EVEN. EVEN
VEILED THREATS. AS WE PROCEED
WITH THE WITNESSES AND PUBLIC
COMMENT I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THE
ASSEMBLY HAS RULES TO ENSURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER. AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT AND FAIR HEARING. WE
APPLY THESE RULES TO EVERYONE
WHO PARTICIPATES IN OUR
PROCEEDINGS. ALL WITNESSES WILL
BE TESTIFIED IN PERSON TODAY. TO
ALLOW TO ME WITNESSES FOR A
MAXIMUM OF THREE MINUTES EACH. A
DISTRICT OFFICIAL TESTIMONY WILL
BE IN EITHER IMPORT WILL BE IN
PERSON AND WILL BE COMBINED NOT
GROUP BY POSITION. LIMITED TO
NAME POSITION. AND ORGANIZATION
IF YOU REPRESENT ONE. THIS NO
TESTIMONY FOR AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WILL BE LIMITED TO
FORTY FIVE MINUTES. ALL PUBLIC
COMMENTS NEED TO FOCUS ON THE
BILL AT HAND. COMMENTS ON OTHER
ISSUES WILL BE RULED OUT OF
ORDER AND YOUR TIME WILL EXPIRE
IMMEDIATELY. PLEASE BE AWARE
THAT VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES
MAY SUBJECT YOU TO REMOVAL OR
OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COOPERATION AND
WE HOPE AUTHORS LISTICLES ARE
RESPECTFUL OF THIS PROCESS. DUE
TO THE COVERED PANDEMIC WE HAVE
LIMITED SPACE FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE SO WE CAN ENSURE
EVERYONE MAINTAIN SIX WE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCE. BUT ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE AND WILL REMIND YOU
OF THAT. AS WE GO FORWARD TODAY.
WHEN YOU COMPLETE YOUR TESTIMONY
MAKES EXIT THE HEARING ROOM OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT IF SPACE
PERMITS- WE'RE DOING THINGS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY TODAY
BECAUSE OF THE TECHNICAL ISSUES
WE HAVE LAST WEEK. WE HAVE A
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS WHICH
IS THE FIRST TEN BILLS WE WILL
HEAR TODAY- THREE OF THOSE BILLS
ARE BEING RE HEARD BECAUSE OF
THE TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES WE
RAN INTO. A AND SO MY APOLOGIES
TO THE AUTHORS BUT WHEN TO
ENSURE THAT- EVERYTHING IS SO
PERFECT FOR YOUR REPRESENTATIONS
AND THE AND THE RECORD OF THAT-
V. S. C. DUE TO THE- YEAH. I
ALREADY DID THAT- THERE WAS WE
DID A COMPUTER AGENDA AND SIX
BILLS THAT. ARE DOUBLE REFERRED
WERE NOT HEARD SO WE WERE TRYING
OUR BEST TO MAKE SURE EVERYTHING
WORKS OUT. OF THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR FOR TODAY THE PROPOSED-
BILLS ARE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
I THINK I PROPOSED A LOT NOW-
ANYWAY I REMEMBER SIX AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY ONE. BY MISTER SALAS
AND INNER FOURTEEN AB NINETEEN
NINETY NINE BY DOCTOR REGULAR.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN BY AB TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED BY DOCTOR REGULAR
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN. AND INNER TWENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES. I'VE
NEVER TWENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON. A NUMBER THIRTY AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. I'VE
NEVER THIRTY FOUR AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY. I AND NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE BY
MR MEDINA. AT NUMBER THIRTY SIX
EIGHTY TWENTY NINETY SIX BY MR
MULLIN. ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX BY MISS
REYES. SOME OF REYES. I NUMBER
FORTY. EIGHT TWENTY X. EIGHTY SO
BY SO MEMBERS. I'VE NEVER FIVE
AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE BY SOME A
MEMBER OF THE VALLAPUDUA. AT
NUMBER FORTY SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY. OUR OUR VICE
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON A
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTEEN BY ALSO BEAR VICE
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON.
SO WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A
SUBSTITUTE TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA WILL REPLACE THE
DEMOCRATIC BASE VACANCY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. REMOVE FROM THE
CALENDAR TODAY AB TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN. BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AND AB
TWENTY FIVE OH FOR A MISTER
KALRA HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM THE
AGENDA TODAY. ARTS WITH THAT WE
WILL GO TO OUR FIRST- BILL-
MISTER GRAY. FOR OUR FIRST SHOT
AT GROUNDHOG DAY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING THE CREATION OF
THE NATION'S FIRST PUBLIC HEALTH
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM I HAVE
DENIS CUEVAS ROMERO CMA HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IPHONE.
VERY MUCH PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEN
AS WELL AS TOMORROW IS HERE TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION JUST HERE
TO EXPRESS MY THANK YOU MR ARE
THERE AND WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
WHAT REGISTERED WITNESSES
OPPOSITION THERE ANYONE IN THE
PUBLIC WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE.
SEEING NO ONE WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF MR GRAY. WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT WE DO HAVE
A QUORUM NOW. WITH REQUEST ONE
TWO THREE. FOUR FIVE SIX. MR
MCCARTY IS THERE MCCARTY'S HE'S
HERE MCCARTY. WHAT WE WANT TO
PROTECT WE PROTECT WE CAN'T
PRETEND IT'S A QUORUM AREN'T.
WHAT BUT WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER
MISTER CHAIR OF THANK YOU MISTER
GRAY THANK YOU WE OF COURSE
WE'RE GONNA STOP DOWN TAKE ROLE. WHAT HERE WALDRON AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA BIGELOW. REAL. FOR
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO. GARCIA. WE HAVE A
QUORUM- BUT AND WE'RE HAPPY. THE
MOTION BY MISTAKE YOU'RE CURIOUS
EGGMAN MISS WALDRON WHICH LIKE
TO CLOSE MISTER. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE MOTION IS U. S. TO
HIGHER EDUCATION AND SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AYE YOUR CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
CARILLO. LAURA LAURA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN THE VERY AND I
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO GARCIA. NINE ZERO GIVE NINE VOTES OF
BILLS OUT THIS COULD BE A RECORD
FOR THE HEALTH COMMITTEE IN THE
SEVEN YEARS THAT I HAVE BEEN. TO
THANK YOU FOR IN THE BILL OUT IN
SECONDS THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK
YOU SO MUCH HAPPY TO COME BACK
ANY TIME- IT. WHATEVER IT TAKES
. MISS PETRI NORRIS PLEASE COME
ON A. GOOD AFTERNOON I CHAIR AND
MEMBERS HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM IS UNDER ASSAULT ALL
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY AND OUR WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A LEADER IN
PROTECTING REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
I. MANY CALIFORNIANS CONTINUE TO
LACK ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE IN FACT 40% OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE
A SINGLE ABORTION PROVIDER THIS
BILL WILL CREATE A REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICE COURT IN
CALIFORNIA THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION INSPIRED BY THE
NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE CORPS
THIS PROPOSAL WILL GREATLY
STRENGTHEN OUR HEALTH CARE
EDUCATION PIPELINE BY RECRUITING
TRAINING AND RETAINING. A
DIVERSE WORK FORCE OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS ARE PROUD TO BE
WORKING WITH THE TRAFFIC
COALITION OF PARTNERS ON THIS
BELL AND- I WOULD NOW LIKE TO
INTRODUCE FLOOR HUNTED TEACH AND
AS DALY CARRASCO AND ARE IN
STUDENT NURSE MIDWIFE AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO. MOTION THE MOTION AND
REFERRING. SECOND BY MR IS IT
WOULD KNOWS THIS BILL NEEDS TO
GET OUT HERE REALLY QUICKLY TO
GET OVER TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
THIS IS. YOUR WITNESSES SO AND
BEATEN. THE MOTION BY
MISSISSAUGA CURRY SECOND BY
MISTER NAZARIAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON- WOULD MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS FOR
HUNT I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF TEACHER TRAINING IN EARLY
ABORTION FOR COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE. I AM A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL- TEACHERS
AN ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
ABORTION TRAINING AND
MENTORSHIP- TO ENSURE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE NEXT
GENERATION OF REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CHAMPIONS I AM VERY
EXCITED TO BE WORKING ON THIS
BILL WITH ASSEMBLYWOMAN CONNIE
PETRIE-NORRIS THAT WOULD CREATE.
THE CALIFORNIA REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICE CORPS. AYE SHE'S
MENTIONED THIS BILL IS MODELED
AFTER THE NATIONAL HEALTH
SERVICE CORPS WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED FIFTY YEARS AGO AND
AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN WILL DO FOR
ABORTION CARE ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHAT THE NHS CEDAR
FOR PRIMARY CARE ACCESS IN
UNDERSERVED AND RURAL AREAS.
THERE'S COLLAR SHIPS AND
STIPENDS FOR ALL MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTHCARE TEAM AB NINETEEN
CREATES ACTION EDUCATIONAL
PATHWAYS. THAT MEET THE REAL
NEEDS OF DIVERSE EXPIRING HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS. WE CANNOT
GET SERIOUS ABOUT DIVERSIFYING
OUR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
WORKFORCE WITHOUT INVESTING UP
FRONT IN THEIR EDUCATION THEIR
MENTORSHIP AND THEIR
DEVELOPMENT. THIS UP FRONT
INVESTMENT WILL ENSURE OUR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS BETTER
REFLECT THE DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE. VERY CLOSE TO MY
HEART THIS BILL ALSO ADDRESSES
THE SHORTAGE OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ABORTION TRAINING. ROGER
IT'S OF THE TEACH PROGRAM ARE
AMONG THE LUCKY FEW PARTY OF
ONLY 6% OF FAMILY MEDICINE
RESIDENTS GUARANTEED ABORTION
TRAINING BY THE RESIDENCY. AND
FOR ADVANCED PRACTICE NURSES
ABORTION TRAINING IS EVEN LESS
ACCESSIBLE. I URGE YOU TO VOTE
EIGHT ON AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN SO
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS THE
STRONGEST BEST TRAINED
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH WORK FORCE
IN THE COUNTRY CAPABLE OF CARING
FOR EVERY PERSON SEEKING CARE IN
OUR GREAT STATE THANK YOU. AND
THANK YOU MISS HUNT AND I THINK
AND WE'LL HAVE OUR SECOND
WITNESS JUST BE AVAILABLE TO
TAKE QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SHOULD ADD. THEY HAVE
THEM. THANK YOU. BUT THERE IS A. THERE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. PLEASE COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN JONES I'M LAST WEEK
THERE WAS TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES
AND ONE OF MY ASSOCIATES WAS
HERE TO TESTIFY SHE WASN'T ABLE
TO COME TODAY SO I'D LIKE TO
GIVE HER TESTIMONY HER NAME IS
SONIA BATES AND SHE'S A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE SAMBAR DINO
PREGNANCY AND FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER SHE'S LED ABORTION
RECOVERY FOR FIFTEEN YEARS TO
HELP WOMEN HEAL FROM THE TRAUMA
OF ABORTION. SHOUTS CLARITY
ABOUT ABORTION IT'S NOT AN
ABSTRACT WORD. THAT SIMPLY. YOU
HEAR ON THE NEWS SHE CHOSE TO
ABORT TWO OF HER OWN CHILDREN.
AND THROUGH OUR WORK SHE'S MET
DOZENS OF WOMEN'S WHO DID
LIKEWISE SOME EARLY IN THE
PREGNANCY AND OTHER SUPPORTING
LATE TERM. SOME HAD ONE ABORTION
REMEMBER. SHE IS LED GROUPS THAT
ARE DIVERSE IN AGE ETHNICITY
INCOME AND EDUCATION BUT ALL
HAVE HAD ONE OR MORE ABORTIONS
EVERYONE IS CRIPPLED EMOTIONALLY
FROM THIS EXPERIENCE MANY CAN
EVEN SAY THE WORD ABORTION MUCH
LESS SHOUTED. SOME HAVE VIVID
MEMORIES THAT HAUNT THEM WHILE
OTHERS LIKE SONIA WORKED HARD TO
SUPPRESS IT DETAILS THE TRAUMA
COMES FROM THE FACT THAT WE ALL
KNOW IT'S ALWAYS WRONG TO KILL
AN INNOCENT HUMAN BEING WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT ABORTION DOES. BUT
WE RATIONALIZE WHICH IS A LOT OF
WORK SO WE FIND PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT US IN OUR SELF DECEPTION
WHICH IS THE ABORTION INDUSTRY
IS PLEASED TO DO. THAT'S WHAT AB
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN SCHOLARSHIPS
WILL FIND MORE TRAINING TO
DECEIVE WOMEN THAT ABORTION AND
ITS SIDE EFFECTS. SO YET ABORTED
HER FIRST CHILD AT THE AGE OF
NINETEEN AND AFTER THE FAMILY
DOCTOR WROTE THE WORDS
THERAPEUTIC ABORTION ON A
PRESCRIPTION PAD. SHE RECALLS
VERY LITTLE ABOUT THE ACTUAL
ABORTION BECAUSE SHE
INTENTIONALLY SUPPRESSING MEMORY
BUT CLEARLY REMEMBERS THE WORDS
ON THE PAINT PAD THERAPEUTIC.
RELATING TO HEALING OF THE
DISEASE IT WASN'T SEIZE IT WITH
THE PREGNANCY. AND CERTAINLY SHE
WASN'T HEALED FROM THAT
ABORTION. ABORTION HAS AN
ENORMOUSLY NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
EMOTIONAL HEALTH. AND THE WAY WE
BEHAVE. THROUGH PREGNANCY AFTER
A FEW YEARS SHE ONCE AGAIN CHOSE
A FORTUNE BUT THIS TIME WAS
DETERMINED TO BE UTTERLY
DETACHED EVEN OFFERING TO PAY
HALF OF THE ABORTION BECAUSE IT
TOO TO GET PREGNANT. SHE DOESN'T
REMEMBER MUCH ABOUT THE ABORTION
HERSELF. THAT REMEMBERS THE
CALLOUSNESS RESPONSE MUCH LATER
THROUGH THE ABORTION RECOVERY
PROGRAM HAS RECEIVED HEALING
FROM THE SO CALLED THERAPEUTIC
ABORTION. TODAY I HELP HEAL
OTHER WOMEN FROM THE PAIN THAT
WAS SUFFERED THROUGH ABORTION DO
NOT FUND THE SCHOLARSHIP FOR
ABORTION PROVIDERS THEY DON'T
NEED HELP WOMEN NEED HEALING
FROM ABORTION NOT MORE DECEPTION
AND TRAUMA MY ASK IS THAT YOU
VOTE NO ON A. B. NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS THERESA
BRENNAN I'M A CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY AND A THIRD GENERATION
PRO LIFE ACTIVIST AND PRESIDENT
OF THE RIGHT TO LIFE LEAGUE
AMERICA'S FIRST PRO LIFE
ORGANIZATION. REPRESENTING FIFTY
TWO MEMBER PREGNANCY HELP
CLINICS CENTERS AND MATERNITY
HOMES IN EVERY ONE OF YOUR
DISTRICTS AND TENS AND THOUSANDS
OF PRO LIFE VOTERS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ABORTION IS
A MEDICAL PROCEDURE THAT CARRIES
WITH IT GREAT RISK FOR INJURY
AND COMPLICATIONS INCLUDING
BLEEDING TISSUE RETENTION AND
INFECTION UTERINE DAMAGES SUCH
AS UTERINE PERFORATION AND TOTAL
LOSS OF FERTILITY FOLLOWING
ABORTIONS. THE STATED INTENT OF
AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN IS TO TRAIN
AN ARMY OF ABORTIONISTS WHO WILL
TARGET THE CHILDREN OF POOR
UNDERSERVED AND MINORITY
COMMUNITIES. THE BILL SETS UP AS
STATE FUNDED SCHOLARSHIP TO
TRAIN DOCTORS MIDWIVES NURSES
AND PHYSICIANS ASSISTANTS. TO
PRACTICE IN ONE NARROW ASPECT OF
HEALTHCARE ABORTIONS NOT
DENTISTRY ARE ONCOLOGY OR
CARDIOLOGY NOT INFERTILITY AND
CERTAINLY NOT OBSTETRICS. AFTER
MENTIONING REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE THE BILL USES THE WORD
ABORTION AND ABORTION CARE NO
FEWER THAN EIGHTEEN TIMES. WHO
WILL ADMINISTER THESE ABORTIONS
IS THE EMPHASIS ON SKILLED
PHYSICIANS GIVING PROFESSIONAL
AND COMPASSIONATE CARE NO. THE
ONLY STUDENTS TO GET GRANTS MUST
AGREE TO PERFORM ABORTIONS. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN SPECIFIES THAT
SCHOLARSHIPS ARE NOT BASED ON
MERIT STUDENTS MUST SPEND AT
LEAST TWO CRITERIA FROM A LIST
OF ALL OBSCURE CHARACTERISTICS
INCLUDING UNDERSERVED AREAS
HOMELESSNESS MENTAL IMPAIRMENT.
HOW DO THESE QUALITIES BARE ON
LEARNING OR PROVIDING ABORTIONS
THEY DON'T. BY DIRECTING THESE
LESSER TRAINED ABORTIONISTS TO
RURAL UNDER SERVED AREAS AB
NINETEEN IT WILL REDUCE THE
STANDARD OF CARE FOR TARGETED
WOMEN OF COLOR WHO LIVE THERE.
WE SHOULD BE WORKING TOWARD
IMPROVING CCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
HEALTH CARE FOR WOMEN AND
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THEY NEED
TO GIVE THEM A REAL CHOICE NOT
JUST INCREASE ACCESS TO SUB
STANDARD ABORTIONS. THANK YOU AT
THIS POINT WE'LL GO TO OTHERS IN
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
PLEASE COME FOR TO THE
MICROPHONE JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ANY
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROXANNE GOLDEN BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAHLER OF
SOME OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RACHEL GATES
OPPOSE THANK YOU. KATHY
MUSBURGER CENTER ACCESS HEALTH
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. KIMBERLY
ROBINSON WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS AND BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS ACTION PROJECT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON GENESIS GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LENNY
COULD UNLOCK IT'S IN SUPPORT OF
. LINDA HUDSON WITH BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS AND SUPPORT YOUR-
IS IT ALL OUR CREDIT WITH NARAL
PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY HILLARY
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. RESIDENTS
ARE BEHALF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYN THIS DISTRICT NINE IN
SUPPORT YOUR- GREG BIRD FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BRANDON CAMPBELL PASTOR THE
FAITH BAPTIST CHURCH WHEATLAND
AND- NORTHERN CALIBRATORS
CALIFORNIA CAPITOL CONNECTION
REPRESENTING BAPTIST CHURCHES UP
AND DOWN THE COAST IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. AND I'M
JUST A GRANDMOTHER A GREAT
GRANDMOTHER THAT LOVES CHILDREN
AND AYE OPPOSED NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. MASALAH
GRANDMOTHER I OPPOSE AB NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH RING GELEMSO IN
SPINSTER AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL
IF. I NOTICED. TRONIC CAN COME
SEVEN TWO SHORT. YOU'RE JUST
RIGHT IN FRONT OF GOVERNOR OF
THE COUNTY AND I OPPOSE NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU SOMETIMES
YOU'RE THE MICROTUS TWO HIGH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
. YOU KNOW WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. AND
WE DID HAVE A MOTION BY A
SECULAR KOREA SECOND BY MISTER
NAZARIAN. OF THE BILL DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION IT'S DO
PASSED TO HIGHER EDUCATION WE
CHECK THE CLOSENESS BETWEEN OURS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE FIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE AND WALDRON
WALDRON NOW AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA RAMBLE
I BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO. CARILLO
LAURA LAURA NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MAYES NOT
VOTING MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN HIS
AREA NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA GARCIA HI.
NINE ZERO I'M SORRY NINETY THREE
NINETY THREE YOUR BILL IS OUT IT
WILL BE TRANSMITTED- VIRTUALLY
IMMEDIATELY TO HIGHER EDUCATION
THANK YOU AND WHAT IS YOUR
CHAIRED MEMBERS WHEN I GO BACK
AND OPEN THE ROLE- FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON TO MR GRAY'S BILLS SO-
SO THE ACT BILL CAN BE
TRANSMITTED WITH THE WITH WITH
THE COMPLETE OF ACCOUNTS WE'RE
GOING TO GET TODAY SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I'D CARILLO.
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE. GARCIA
GARCIA I. THIRTEEN SO HAS
THIRTEEN VOTES THAT BILL WILL BE
TRANSMITTED TO HIGHER EDUCATION
AS WELL SO- MR SANTIAGO ARE YOU
READY TO PRESENT. I KNOW YOU
WILL NEED FOR TRANSMITTAL PERSON
PURPOSES SO. YEAH OTHERS PRESENT
MY BILL.
AB TWO ZERO EIGHT ZERO BERMAN
WHAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THIS COMMITTEE HAS
INVESTED A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
TIME OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
HEALTHCARE THE CONSUMERS RECEIVE
AND REDUCE ITS COST WE HAVE HELD
MANY HEARINGS ON COST
CONTAINMENT. ACCESS
CONSOLIDATION AND MORE. IT
WASN'T THAT LONG AGO THAT
SOMEONE INFAMOUSLY SAID. WHO
KNEW HOW HEALTHCARE COULD BE SO
COMPLICATED. HELLO WAS IT NOT
MOST OF US HAVE KNOWN THIS FOR A
VERY LONG TIME. YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD FROM OPPONENTS WHO SAY
THIS BILL IS TOO COMPLICATED BUT
I SAY IT'S SIMPLE. CONSOLIDATION
CONTINUES AND HEALTH CARE AND
THE HEALTH CARE MARKET PLACE AND
PRICES ARE NOT GOING DOWN. AS A
MATTER OF FACT THEY'RE GOING UP.
AND WE NEED TO PROVIDE MORE
OVERSIGHT IN GENERAL. AND MORE
OVERSIGHT AND AUTHORITY IN
CONSOLIDATIONS. OR INTO THE
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID SERVICES. HEALTHCARE
SPENDING INCREASED BY NINE POINT
7% FROM TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TO
TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY. AND
ALTHOUGH THAT GROWTH WAS DUE IN
PART TO THE COBIT PANDEMIC
NATIONAL HEALTHCARE SPENDING IS
PROJECTED TO GROW AT AN ANNUAL
RATE OF FIVE POINT 4%
420-192-2020 EIGHT. MUCH FASTER
THAN THE ANNUAL GROWTH OF FOUR
POINT 2% FROM TWO THOUSAND TEN
TO TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
HEALTHCARE IS GROWING AT TWICE
THE RATE OF INFLATION. THAT'S
SIMPLY NOT SUSTAINABLE. THE BILL
PROHIBITS SIX TYPES OF ANTI
COMPETITIVE CONTRACT PROVISIONS
AS AGREED TO IN THE SETTLEMENT
BETWEEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
SUTTER HEALTH. IT BUYS
PROHIBITIONS NOT ONLY TO
HOSPITALS BUT ALSO THE HEALTH
PLANS INSURERS AND HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. THIS WILL LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD AS THESE GROUPS
NEGOTIATE AMONG THEMSELVES ON
PAYMENT RATES. FOR EXAMPLE ONE
OF THE PROHIBITED TYPES OF
CONTRACT CLAUSES IS ALL IS AN
ALL OR NOTHING CLAUSE. SOME
HOSPITALS REFUSED TO ALLOW A
PLAN TO NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT
WITHOUT ALL OF THE HOSPITALS IN
THE PLANT EVEN AS SOME HOSPITALS
ARE FAR OUTSIDE THE AREA THE
PLAN OPERATES IN. THIS ALL OR
NOTHING REQUIREMENT INCREASES
THE PLANS COSTS AND THEREFORE
INCREASES COST TO CONSUMERS. THE
SECOND COMPONENT OF THIS BILL
EXTENDS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
EXISTING AUTHORITY TO REVIEW
NONPROFIT HOSPITAL SALES AND
MERGERS TO FOR PROFIT HOSPITALS.
INCLUDE HEALTH PLANS AND MEDICAL
PRACTICES. YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
FROM OPPONENTS OF THIS PROVISION
HOW ONEROUS AND UNFAIR IDEAS I
SAY IS LONG OVERDUE. OKAY NOR
CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY HEAVILY
CONSOLIDATED. AS NOTED IN THE
ANALYSIS RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
CONSOLIDATION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT AN AVERAGE
IMPATIENT PERSON CONSERVE
INPATIENT PROCEDURES. TO BE
NEARLY TWICE THAT IN NORTH AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THE THIRD
COMPONENT OF THIS BILL MAKES
CLEAR THAT TRANSACTIONS BY
HEALTH PLANS ARE ALSO SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATE APPROPRIATE REVIEW
AND OVERSIGHT. BECAUSE HEALTH
EXPENDITURES ARE PROJECTED TO
GROW ONE POINT ONE FOR SEPARATE
SENT FASTER- POINTS FASTER ON
AVERAGE 420-192-2820 EIGHT. OKAY
COSTS ARE PROJECTED TO INCREASE
FROM FOUR POINT ONE TRILLION
DOLLARS INTO ANY TWENTY. TWO SIX
POINT TWO TRILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. THESE ARE
STAGGERING NUMBERS AND CERTAINLY
UNSUSTAINABLE FINALLY THE
INDUSTRY ARGUES A CONSOLIDATION
IMPROVES QUALITY BUT THERE'S NO
LITERATURE. OTHER THAN INDUSTRY
SPONSORED STUDIES THE SUPPORT
THAT ASSERTION IT'S SIMPLY NOT
TRUE. I'D LIKE TO HAVE YOU HERE
FOR MY WITNESSES BETH CAPELL
WITH HEALTH ACCESS AND JERRY
BURRELL. WITH PURCHASERS
BUSINESS GROUP ON HEALTH. GOOD
AFTERNOON A GERMAN WORD AND
COMMITTEE- AND THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THIS AFTERNOON- I'M
JERRY BURRELL. WITH PGH- BUT
PRIOR TO JOINING PGH I MANAGE
HEALTH BENEFITS AND PURCHASED
HEALTH CARE FOR MCKESSON
STANFORD AND SAFE WAY FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS. HE J. H. IS A NON
FOR PROFIT NOT FOR PROFIT
COALITION OF EMPLOYERS AND
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE
HEALTH BENEFITS TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND FAMILIES WITH THE
MISSION OF IMPROVING QUALITY AND
AFFORDABILITY AND HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. AS YOU KNOW THE COST OF
HEALTH THE COST FOR CALIFORNIANS
COVERED BY PRIVATE HEALTH THE
HEALTH PLANS ARE MUCH TOO HIGH
AND CONTINUE TO INCREASE AT AN
UNSUSTAINABLE RATE. WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE HIGH COSTS ARE DUE
PRIMARILY TO HIGH PRICES. NOT
INCREASED USE OF SERVICES OR THE
AGING OF THE POPULATION. HIGH
PRICES ARE DUE LARGELY TO THE
MARKET POWER OF LARGE HOSPITALS
HEALTH SYSTEMS AND PROVIDER
GROUPS. THE GAME THIS MARKET
POWER BY CONSOLIDATING AND FOR
SOME OF THEM ENGAGING IN ANTI
COMPETITIVE PRACTICES. WITH NO
FOCUS ON QUALITY. AB TWENTY
EIGHTY APPLY THE PRO CONSUMER
PROVISIONS OF THE LANDMARK
SUTTER SETTLEMENT INDUSTRY WIDE
IN OTHER WORDS LEVELING THE
PLAYING FIELD BY APPLYING THE
SAME RULES ALL HOSPITALS
PROVIDER GROUPS. AND HEALTH
PLANS BY PROHIBITING THE
SPECIFIC ANTI COMPETITIVE
BEHAVIORS IN THE SETTLEMENT. THE
BILL ALSO EXTENDS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S EXISTING OVERSIGHT
AUTHORITY OVER NONPROFIT
HOSPITAL MERGERS TO ALL HEALTH
SYSTEM TRANSACTIONS IN ORDER TO
REVIEW THE IMPACT ON QUALITY
COSTS AND ACCESS TO NEEDED
SERVICES BOTH OF THESE ELEMENTS.
OF THE BILL ARE ESSENTIAL TO
GETTING COSTS UNDER CONTROL. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT HIGH PRICES
FOR HEALTH CARE SERVICES GIVEN
BY INDUSTRY CON CONSOLIDATION
AND ANTI COMPETITIVE PRACTICES
HAVE DRAMATICALLY INCREASED
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS FOR
EMPLOYERS WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THIS HAS RESULTED IN
LOWER WAGES FOR WORKERS AND
SLOWER JOB GROWTH. IN OTHER
WORDS THIS IS NOT JUST A HEALTH
CARE BILL IT'S A WAGES AND WAGES
AND JOB GROWTH BILL THE HEALTH
CARE INDUSTRY IS CROWDING OUT
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND WE CANNOT LET THIS CONTINUE.
WE NEED LEGISLATION THAT WILL
MAKE HEALTH CARE MARKETS WORK
THE WAY THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO
RESULT IN LOWER PRICES A
STRONGER ECONOMY AND MORE
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. YES
HELLO ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE CONSUMER ADVOCACY
COALITION. WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY
EIGHTY BECAUSE AS WE KNOW FROM
AN AMPLE ACADEMIC LITERATURE IN
THIS DOCTOR WOULD JUST SAID.
CONSOLIDATION DRIVES UP COSTS
WITHOUT IMPROVING QUALITY AND
THEY'RE EVEN STUDIES INDICATING
THAT IT WILL WORSEN MORTALITY OR
DEATH RATES REALLY THE WRONG
DIRECTION. THE ONLY STUDIES THAT
INDICATE DIFFERENTLY WERE FUNDED
BY THE HOSPITAL INDUSTRY ITSELF.
WE KNOW FROM THIRTY YEARS OF
WORKING WITH ATTORNEYS GENERAL
OF BOTH PARTIES. ON NONPROFIT
HOSPITAL MERGERS THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS USED THEIR
AUTHORITY TO KEEP HOSPITALS OPEN
TO PROTECT EMERGENCY ROOMS LABOR
AND DELIVERY CARDIOLOGY
REPRODUCTIVE SERVICES LGBT CUES.
SERVICES ATTORNEYS GENERAL HAVE
ALSO IMPOSED CONDITIONS TO
PREVENT ANTI COMPETITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTO MODERATE POST
CONSOLIDATION PRICE INCREASES.
YOU WILL HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL REVIEW MAKES BUSINESS
DECISIONS MORE EXPENSIVE AND
TIME CONSUMING THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAS NINETY DAYS WITH ONE
FORTY FIVE DAY EXTENSION THAT'S
PRETTY MODEST WHEN YOU CONSIDER
WHAT'S INVOLVED IN THESE
TRANSACTIONS THESE ARE ALL
TRANSACTIONS THAT INVOLVE MORE
THAN FIVE BUSINESSES WITH MORE
THAN FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. IN
THE LAST THIRTY YEARS DOZENS
INDEED HUNDREDS OF TRANSACTIONS
HAVE PRECEDED ALL MOST OF THEM
WITHOUT CONTROVERSY AND MOST
WITH CONDITIONS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND THE HEALTH OF THE
COMMUNITY. THE IMPORTANT THING
THAT AB TWENTY EIGHTY DOES IS TO
ASSURE THAT THERE ENFORCEABLE
CONDITIONS TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
AND TO PROTECT THE HEALTH CARE
THAT'S BEING DELIVERED. IN THE
COMMUNITY YOU WILL ALSO HEAR
THAT SOMEHOW AB TWENTY EIGHTY
UNWINDS MANAGED CARE ON DOES
INTEGRATED DELIVERY SYSTEMS.
AGAIN NOTHING COULD BE FURTHER
FROM THE TRUTH AN INTEGRATED
DELIVERY SYSTEM INVOLVES A
HEALTH PLAN THAT'S TRUE WHETHER
TO KAISER OR SUTTER OR SHARP. IT
IS THESE HEALTH PLANS. THAT ARE
SUBJECT TO ALL OF THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT HEALTH ACCESS
IS FOUGHT FOR DECADES TIMELY
ACCESS NETWORK ADEQUACY RATE
REVIEW FINANCIAL SOLVENCY. THOSE
PROTECTIONS ARE THE ONES THAT WE
HOLD DEAR AND THINK IMPORTANT
AND WE SUBMIT TO YOU THAT IN
PART WE HAVE HOSPITAL SYSTEMS
TRYING TO GET OUT FROM UNDER
THEM BY SAYING THEY DON'T NEED A
MANAGED CARE PLAN AS PART OF THE
DEAL. FOR THESE REASONS WERE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU- I'LL
CALL UP ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO WITNESSES- THREE
MINUTES EACH.
THANK YOU I'M THE MARC ALMOND
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT ELIMINATES
THE VALUE OF MANAGED CARE
NETWORKS. AND ALSO ELIMINATES
THE BENEFITS OF COORDINATED CARE
AND TAKING CARE OF PATIENTS. I
WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW AN
INTEGRATED HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
HOSPITAL SYSTEM CAN TAKE CARE OF
PATIENTS AND REACT TO-
UNPRECEDENTED EVENTS. FIRST
EXAMPLE IS- WHAT HAPPENED DURING
THE PANDEMIC WE SAW THAT
HOSPITAL SYSTEMS HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS. WERE ABLE TO REACT
QUICKLY TO- THE SURGE THAT WAS-
EBBING AND FLOWING IN VARIOUS
COMMUNITIES. I HAD MORE
RESOURCES TO MOVE P. P. YEAR
ROUND TO MOVE EQUIPMENT AROUND
TO MOVE STAFF AROUND TO ADDRESS
A WHAT WAS HAPPENING IN
COMMUNITIES. ANOTHER VALUE OF
INTEGRATED SYSTEMS IS THE
ABILITY TO PROVIDE A SPECIALTY
CARE. IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO HAVE
THAT SPECIALTY CARE. A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES- MATERNAL HEALTH CARE A
MOTHER OF COURSE- HAVING A
NORMAL PREGNANCY- IT'S BEST TO
DELIVER- IN THE COMMUNITY AT THE
AT THE LOCAL HOSPITAL OR OTHER-
LOCATION NEARBY. BUT IF THERE
ARE COMPLICATIONS IF IT'S A HIGH
RISK PREGNANCY. THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT VALUE IN HAVING
ARRANGEMENTS PREDETERMINED KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE TO GO- FOR
SPECIALTY CARE AT TO A HOSPITAL
WITH HIGHER LEVEL OF SERVICES-
WE KNOW THAT- ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
SPECIALTY CARE WE KNOW THAT THE
MORE A RARE OR VERY COMPLICATED
PROCEDURE IS DONE IN ONE PLACE
AT THE SAME HOSPITAL. BY THE
SAME PHYSICIANS SURGEONS AND
CARE TEAM THAT THE OUTCOMES ARE
MUCH BETTER- FOR EXAMPLE CENTERS
OF EXCELLENCE WHERE PATIENTS ARE
DIRECTED- THEY RECEIVE
INCENTIVES TO GO THERE IN THE
FORM OF LOWER COPAYS- THEY GET
CARE FROM SURGEONS WHO DO THAT
SORT OF TRANSPLANT ROUTINELY IN
THE OUTCOMES ARE BETTER. FINALLY
ON THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
PROVISIONS- EXTENDING THIS TO
ALL THE SECTORS IN THE
HEALTHCARE COMMUNITY BEYOND- THE
WORDS APPLIED NOW WE THINK.
THERE SHOULD BE SOME DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS PUT IN PLACE- THE
RULES OF EVIDENCE DON'T APPLY
THE RULES OF CIVIL PROCEDURE
DON'T APPLY AND WE KNOW THAT-
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION TO IMPOSE
CONDITIONS ON THESE TERMS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- WILL OPEN IT UP
TO THE TESTIMONY FROM FOLKS IN
THE ROOM SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
LIMITED TO NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL.
CERAKOTE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OFFICE WITH THE
PRESIDENT IN OPPOSITION. ISABEL
ARE QUITE ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM IN OPPOSITION.
DIVISION'S AWESOME HALF OF
AMERICA'S VISION GROUPS- I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSITION. THE SET
SHORT ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE
OF CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE PEACH
THE COMMUNITY SAFETY NET
HOSPITALS ADVENTIST HEALTH IN
LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY HEALTH IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU PRESTON
YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE HERE IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. ERIN GILBERT FOR
SCRIPT HEALTH IN OPPOSITION.
KATHLEEN SORIANO ON BEHALF OF
THE CUT MEDICINE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THAT'S NOT
AS GOOD AS A STATE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. I LANDED ON REPRESENT
NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS IN OPPOSITION
AND- ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WITH AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU. HI RUN PARTICULAR C. H. A.
BUT ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. MISTER MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
BRANDON MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ORTHOPEDIC
ASSOCIATION IN AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON A
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS SIDE
JENNIFER MALEY LOOK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RIGHT SPENCER
THE CALVARY PRETTY ACTIVE
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSED
ESTIMATED. ALISON RAINY ON
BEHALF OF KAISER PERMANENTE A
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION. AMY
BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND SEEING NO OTHER
WITNESSES I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS MOTION. MISTER MASON
THANK YOU- ADAM VICE CHAIR- STE
WE'VE HAD A LITTLE CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS- AND- AS THE FORMER
VICE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
ALL THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE IN
REGARDS TO COST CONTAINMENT TRY
TO DRIVE DOWN THE PRICES OF
HEALTH CARE WHICH ARE STILL
CONTINUE TO SKYROCKET- I'M- YOU
KNOW I'M I'M SINCERE IN MY
SUPPORTER OF THE EFFORTS THAT WE
DON AND THE EFFORTS WE'VE
CONTINUED. TO DO- TAKING A LOOK
AT THIS BILL IS A COUPLE
CONCERNS- THAT I THAT I HAVE-
ONE OF THEM ALL JUST TALK ABOUT
LOCALLY- BACK IN MY DISTRICT AND
I KNOW THAT THE- THE CHAIR THE
AUTHOR KNOWS. MY DISTRICT PRETTY
WELL- BUT- WE HAVE- FOR
HOSPITALS IN MY DISTRICT BUT
THREE OF THEM WITH ONE JUST
OUTSIDE IN INDIO. A WE HAVE- JFK
A DESERT REGIONAL I AND ALSO
HIGH DESERT- HI I HAD AS A
MEMORIAL HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
WHICH IS HIGH DESERT A HOSPITAL.
THAT HAS CONTRACTED WITH TENET
AND THEY'VE CREATED THE DESERT
CARE NETWORK THE THREE OF THEM-
I KNOW THAT I HEARD THAT-
CONSOLIDATION IS TO IS- THERE'S
NO DATA TO SUPPORT THAT IT ISN'T
GOOD BUT I CAN TELL YOU- THAT-
AT LEAST ANECDOTALLY. FROM THE
FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT THAT- IT
HAS BEEN BETTER. FOR THEM THAT
OUGHT TO ALSO BE FIT THERE'S
SOME COMPETITION A BECAUSE-
RIGHT NEAR THEM WE'VE ALSO THAT
EISENHOWER SO WE'VE GOT SOME
AREAS OF THE STATE WHERE THERE
ISN'T ANY ANY COMPETITION WITH
HAVING. IT'S ALL CONSOLIDATED
INTO ONE AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE NO
COMPETITION PRICES. ON THE
PRICES RISE BUT WHAT WHAT IMPACT
WOULD THIS HAVE ON THAT. ON THAT
TYPE OF AN ARRANGEMENT WHERE YOU
HAVE ON TO HOSPITALS THAT OUR
PUBLIC HOSPITALS THAT HAVE
CONTRACTED- WITH A PRIVATE MY
ENTITY YOU. AT LIKE TEN TO
CREATE A AND IN. SYSTEM I WOULD
CALL AN INTEGRATED SYSTEM. A
WHAT IMPACT WOULD THAT WOULD
THIS HAVE ON ON THAT. I DON'T
KNOW IF THE OPPOSITION OR FOR
THE AUTHOR WANTS TO. I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE A STAB AT IT IN ON THE
NIGHT I THINK BETH WILL AS WELL-
LOOK I THINK THERE ARE ALL SORTS
OF ARRANGEMENTS THAT HAPPEN OUT
THERE AND I'LL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE IN MY OWN DISTRICT- WE
ALMOST LOST A HOSPITAL COAST
HOSPITAL. IN FORT BRAGG AND WERE
IT NOT FOR ADVENTIST HEALTH
STEPPING IN. YOU DO A MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENT FOR THAT HOSPITAL WE
WOULDN'T HAVE THAT HOSPITAL
TODAY. I WOULD SAY THAT'S A GOOD
ARRANGEMENT NO. EVIDENCE DOESN'T
OWN THE HOSPITAL BUT IT IS AN
OPERATING. AND YES. PROBABLY
CALL THAT CONSOLIDATION. BY THE
AS A CONSOLIDATION AND FOR THE
BENEFIT. OF THE COMMUNITY THERE.
I DO NOT UNDERGRADUATES. THAT
NONE OF THIS BILL UNWINDS ANY
EXISTING AGREEMENTS- BUT WE WANT
TO BE ABLE TO LOOK. MORE
CLOSELY. WHY SHOULD A HOUSE
WHITE WHY SHOULD A HOSPITAL
SYSTEM HAS HOSPITALS IN.
MULTIPLE PARTS OF THE STATE THAT
MIGHT NOT BE CLOSE TOGETHER. ALL
CONTRACT YOU GATHER FOR THE SAME
EXACT RATE. THAT DOESN'T
REFLECT. THOSE INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES THAT DOESN'T REFLECT
THE COST OF NECESSARILY DOING
BUSINESS THERE. WHAT IT DOES DO.
IS MAKE SURE. THAT THOSE PRICES
STAY HIGH AND I BELIEVE THAT'S
ARTIFICIALLYHIGH. AND SO THIS
WE'RE JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
REVIEW PROCESS. LUBIS SCRUTINY
AROUND THIS. SAY THIS COULD BE
FAIR FOR CONSUMERS ARE NOT. AND
THE- I DON'T KNOW IF THE IF THE
OPPOSITION WANTS TO ADDRESS THAT
ARE OFF YOU'VE GOT ANY THOUGHTS
ON ON THAT- THE ADVANTAGE OF-
HOSPITALS IN A LARGER SSTEM
MEAN IF THEY'RE NOT
GEOGRAPHICALLY NEXT TO EACH
OTHER IS THAT THEY DO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO ALL THE HOSPITALS
IN THAT SYSTEM CLINICAL
EXPERTISE I OFTENTIMES ITS
FINANCIAL RESOURCES A HOSPITAL
THAT- WOULDN'T MAKE IT ON. ITS
OWN CAN BE PART OF A LARGER
SYSTEM AND CONTRACTING AND
NETWORKING TOGETHER- IN A STATE
THAT HAS HIGHLY LEVERAGED-
PAYMENT PLANS AS WELL IS JUST A
WAY TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY.
IS ABLE TO- GET A FAIR RATE FOR
PROVIDING CARE IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITY BUT IF I IF I MIGHT
AND AGAIN YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH
MY AREA BUT- THE COMMUNITIES OF
PALM SPRINGS- ARE VASTLY. IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF JOSHUA TREE- AND
TO THE RESPONDING- THEY ARE
DIFFERENT AND SO IF YOU'RE IF
YOU'RE NEGOTIATING A RICK- IT'S
THE SAME RATE SAYING IT'S GONNA
ALL NOTHING. OUT AND I AND BY
JOSH SHOULD BE A IS A MUCH PLACE
EVEN THOUGH IT'S JUST FORTY
MINUTES UP THE ROAD- WHY WOULD-
BE A- FOR THE- COME UP THE BILL
. SAY THAT THOSE ARE. OVERSEE
THE BILL- THE PROHIBITS WERE ALL
HA. COULD BE AND ALL OF TO BE IN
THE NAY AND DOESN'T THAT THE
RATES HAVE TO BE THE SAME. SO
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE PARTIES
COULD AGREE TO SAY YOU HAVE TO
BE IN THE IN THE NETWORK YOU
HAVE TO CONTRACT WITH US. BUT
THEN THERE IS A SEPARATE
NEGOTIATION ON WHAT THE SPECIFIC
RATE IS THE BILL PROHIBITS- THE
ABILITY TO KEEP ALL OF THE
AFFILIATES TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE
IT'S AN INTEGRATED COORDINATED
NETWORK. SO THE ECONOMICS I
GUESS THE QUESTION WOULD BE WHAT
THE DID THE ECONOMICS BECOME
PROBLEMATIC THEN FOR LIKE A
HOSPITAL LIKE JOSHUA TREE- WHERE
IS A SMALL RURAL AREA WOULD BE-
MAYBE IT WOULD WORK OUT MAYBE
TEN IT WOULD DECIDE HEY IF IT'S
NOT ALL OR NOTHING THEN WE WOULD
HAVE DONE. THAN BUSINESS THERE
THEY WOULD DECIDE TO BE ABLE TO-
TO DROP THAT CONTRACT RIGHT IN
AND WHAT WE SEE SOME GAMES WITH
THESE HOSPITALS TO IS- THE PAIR
THE HEALTH PLAN. THE INSURER
CHOOSES A DIFFERENT HOSPITAL
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY GOT A BETTER
RATE. THAT MEANS ALL THE-
PATIENTS IN THAT COMMUNITY ARE
DRIVING PAST THEIR LOCAL
HOSPITAL. GOING TO ANOTHER
HOSPITAL THAT'S FARTHER AWAY
THAT'S ONE OF THE DISADVANTAGES
. AND THEN THE OTHER CONCERNED-
THAT I- THAT I HAVE- AND I'M
LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS I TRIED
ACTUALLY FIND THIS IN THE
LANGUAGE. OF THE BILL AND I'M
SURE THAT IT'S THAT IT'S THERE
BUT THIS IS ON PAGE THREE. AND
ITS THE- THE BULLET OF THIRTEEN-
TALKING ABOUT THE ATTORNEYTHE
DISCRETION IT'S GIVEN TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IT SEEMS TO BE.
A LOT LIKE SOME- THAT YOU'RE
GIVING IT OFF A LOT OF POWER TO
ONE INDIVIDUAL A TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THESE AND YOU KNOW I'M I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT GIVING. THAT
KIND OF POWER TO ONE OF ONE
PERSON AND THE IN JUST THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S THERE- WAS
SAYING WHETHER OR NOT. WHETHER
OR NOT WHETHER OR NOT WHETHER OR
NOT- THAT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S THE
IT AG DOESN'T HAVE ANY- ROAD
BLOCKS IF YOU WILL- TO BE ABLE
TO DECIDE- IS JUST YOUR
COMPLETE. I'M AUTHORITY TO BE
ABLE TO GO IN AND YOU DO THAT OF
COURSE OF CORRUPTION AND OTHER
THINGS CAN END UP HAPPENING. IS
IS THERE ANY CONCERN ABOUT THAT-
AT ALL TO TIGHTEN. UP BORDER TO
MAKE SURE THAT. WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WE WILL BE
WORKING WITH JUDICIARY ON THIS
AS WELL- I THINK YOU MIGHT BE
MESSY ATTORNEY GENERAL THEY
MIGHT THINK THE LANGUAGE IS
WEAKER THAN THEY WOULD LIKE
QUITE FRANKLY- BUT- BUT- I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT. THAT THAT WILL BE
AN ISSUE I WANT TO TAKE YOU BACK
TO WHY WE'RE HERE. WE'RE HERE
BECAUSE OF A SUTTER SETTLEMENTS.
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ANTI
COMPETITIVE PRACTICES. THAT'S
SIGNIFICANT THAT IS SIGNIFICANT
AND WHAT THAT DID. WAS THAT YOU
HEALTHCARE COSTS BEING 50%
HIGHER NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. I
DON'T THINK THAT'S GOOD FOR
CONSUMERS AND THE CARE
NECESSARILY ISN'T BETTER THAN IT
IS IN YOUR AREA BUT IT IS WAY
MORE EXPENSIVE. AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS HERE AND
I'D LIKE TO HAVE MIGHT WITNESS
SHE CAN ANSWER A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR YEAH OF BETH BELL
AS A GIRL FROM RIVERSIDE I DO
KNOW PALM SPRINGS AND- PART OF
YOUR DISTRICTS ARE. OF UP I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S DISCRETION IS ALWAYS
BOUNDED BY THE COURTS AND IN
FACT. IN A RECENT TRANSACTION
INVOLVING HUNTINGTON AND CEDAR
SIDE I THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION LITIGATED THEY THERE
WERE THERE WAS A SETTLEMENT IT
IT CAME TO A HAPPY PLACE BUT WE
HAVE THIRTY YEARS. OF ATTORNEYS
GENERAL GOING BACK TO DAN
LUNDGREN A REPUBLICAN IS WE MAY
RECALL- USING THIS AUTHORITY IN
A WHAT I WOULD SAY WAS A
RESPONSIBLE WAY ALWAYS SUBJECT
TO REVIEW B THE COURTS AND SO
THERE'S ALWAYS THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR- A CORE DUMP IN AND SAY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS OVERSTEPPED
THEIR BOUNDS AND- IN MY DEALINGS
WITH ATTORNEYS GENERAL. OVER
THESE DECADES THEY'RE VERY
MINDFUL THAT THEY HAVE TO BE
WITHIN THE PARAMETERS OF THE LAW
. AND THEN- FINALLY THE- THE
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR A NUMBER WHY
WAS THAT WHY WAS FIVE MILLION-
THRESHOLD THAT WAS CHOSEN WHY
NOT TWENTY MILLION OR THIRTY
MILLION OR TWO MILLION FOR THAT
MATTER WHY FIVE FLIES FIVE
MILLION THE- I THINK SOME PEOPLE
ARGUED FOR LESS SO QUITE
FRANKLY- I DO. THAT IS YOU KNOW
IF THERE ARE KEY IS COMPELLING
EVIDENCE THAT THAT IS THE
INAPPROPRIATE NUMBER I'M OPEN TO
THAT- IF YOU'RE A IS CERTAINLY
RID SENSITIVE TO THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW PEOPLE MIGHT BE THERE
MIGHT BE INDIVIDUAL
PRACTITIONERS LOOKING AT. VERGE
YOU KNOW. DOCTORS MERGING
PRACTICES THOSE ARE LIKE NOT
LIKELY TO BE HIT THAT THRESHOLD.
WE'RE TRYING TO BE SENSITIVE TO
PROVIDERS. BUT THESE ARE IN OF
THESE THESE LARGE MERGERS ARE
GONNA. THE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
HIGHER THAN THAN FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND DOT IF THERE'S A
PROGRAM MORE PROBING NUMBER OF
PEOPLE CAN MAKE A CASE FOR THAT
WE ARE OPEN TO THAT I. I THINK
PEOPLE KNOW MY DOORS OPEN WE
WILL WE WILL ALWAYS TALK WITH
THE OPPOSITION. BUT I DON'T LIKE
IS WHEN PEOPLE TO SAY NO WE
DON'T OFFER OFFER A REASON WHY
OR- OR SOMETHING FOR US TO
CONSIDER. OKAY WHAT MANAGER
THAT'S THE ALL MY QUESTIONS I
JUST TO MAKE ONE STATEMENT I'M
GONNA SUPPORT THIS- TODAY- ONE
OUT OF MY AFFECTION FOR OF THE
AUTHOR- I'VE GOT SOME DEEP
CONCERNS ABOUT- THIS- THIS BILL
AND IF IT WOULD BE OKAY AS THIS
MOVE AS THIS BILL MOVES ON
THROUGH THE PROCESS- IF WE CAN
CONTINUE TO KEEP ENGAGING
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO HOW
IT AFFECTS- A HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY- IN IN IN REGIONS LIKE
MINE ABSOLUTELY MY PLEASURE
THANK YOU. MYTHAGO OCCURRED. I
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I TO
HAVE SOME RESERVATIONS ON THIS
BECAUSE OF MY RURAL COMMUNITIES-
BUT I WANT TO STATE IS THAT IT'S
SO IMPORTANT THAT HOW MANY TIMES
YOU GO OUT TO VISIT WITH YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND HEALTH CARE IS
THE NUMBER ONE QUESTION THE
NUMBER ONE CONCERN THAT WE'VE
BEEN ASKED ARE YOU GONNA GET THE
RATES DOWN OR HOW ARE YOU GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
SPECIALIZED MEDICINE THAT WE
NEED THOSE ARE ALL THE QUESTIONS
THAT MANY OF US GET WITHIN THE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AS PART OF THE
NUMBER ONE. OF A TOPIC THAT
COMES UP SO I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY FAIR PLACE TO START I
KNOW THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU AND I PLAN ON
WORKING WITH YOU I MEAN WHO CAN
SAY THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE%
THERE'S NOT UNFAIR PROVIDE
CONTRACTING HELLO AS WELL AS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
OVERSIGHT FOR HEALTH PLANS AND
WE CAN GO BACK TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND SAY YOU'RE
RIGHT THIS IS WRONG OR WAS GREAT
AT WORKED ALL ALONG. BUT AGAIN I
WILL CONTINUE TO I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND- AS-
SOME GOVERNMENT SAID LET'S KEEP
WORKING ON IT THE ARTIST DESERVE
IT AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GIVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO PASS TO JUDICIARY I'LL
GIVE GERMAN WOULD A MOMENT TO
CLOSE IF YOU'D LIKE THANK YOU
AND IT'S WHAT THE MEMBERS FOR
THE QUESTIONS AND WE TAKE THIS
SERIOUSLY AND WE WILL ABSOLUTELY
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION THERE'S
REASONABLE REASONABLE THINGS.
THAT DON'T. LATELY UNDER THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WE'RE ALWAYS
OPEN TO THAT- BUT WE'RE ALSO
WATCHING CLOSELY FOR POISON
PILLS WE KNOW WE KNOW THAT GAME
TOO- SO I WENT THANK YOU- JUST
LET ME FINISH BY SAYING. THAT
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT KEEPING
HEALTH CARE COSTS DOWN. IS ABOUT
KEEPING WAGES AND JOB GROWTH UP
. IT'S IF EMPLOYERS ARE PAYING
TOO MUCH FOR THEIR INSURANCE
PREMIUMS THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO
GIVE RAISES. RED JOBS. THIS IS
IMPORTANT ON MANY LEVELS I
CONTINUES ALWAYS TO MEET WITH
AND WORK WITH OPPONENTS OF
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE MOVE THROUGH
THE PROCESS I'M WORKING ON
AUTHORS AMENDS WITH THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TRYING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AROUND. THE AGE APPROVAL
PROCESS- AND YES WE STILL HAVE
WORK TO DO BUT IT'S IMPORTANT WE
GET THIS DONE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THE MOTION TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY. I WOULD I WOULD I
WALDRON NO WATER NO FIGURE CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW BIGELOW NO CARILLO.
LAURA LAURA NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE GARCIA. RIGHT NOW IT'S FIVE
TWO THREE. WE WILL HAVE SOME
MORE FOLKS SAID IN LATER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU WILL PUT
THE BILL ON CALL.
MR SANTIAGO IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING ITEM THREE A. B. TWO
TWO FOUR TWO.
I THINK MISTER CHAIR HARPER- FOR
LONG AS THE PRESENT THIS OUT BUT
I ALSO WANNA THINK THIS
COMMITTEE- AND THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE- FOR WORKING WITH THIS
OVER A NUMBER OF YEARS- AB
TWENTY TO FORTY TWO WHICH WE
CALL THE MENTAL A MENTAL HEALTH
CARE COORDINATION ACT. WILL GO A
LONG WAY STILL TOWARDS HELPING
PEOPLE WERE ON HOUSE AT THE
CURRENT TIME NOW BACK LAST YEAR
YOU MIGHT RECALL THAT WE CARED A
BILL LIKE THIS- ALONG WITH MY
JOIN OTHERS LIKE MISTREATMENT
THE TALK ABOUT CONSERVATIVE-
WE'VE BEEN THROUGH THIS A NUMBER
OF YEARS NOW WE ENDED UP PULLING
BACK BECAUSE WE FELT THAT THE
AMENDMENT OF THE TIME WATER DOWN
THE BILL SO MUCH THAT. THE CHIP.
SUGGEST WE DO A HEARING ON IT.
IN IN THE HEARING- WE DISCOVER
THAT IT WAS BIGGER PROBLEMS IN
THE COORDINATION OF CARE FOR A
PERSON WHO IS HELD UNDER A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD. NOT THE
BIG ONE THE BIGGEST PLANS WE
FOUND THAT THERE WAS NO
COORDINATION- AND NO SERVICE
UNDER TOWARD THAT PERSON SO EVEN
IF. WE WENT DOWN THE PATH TO
CHANGING A CONSERVATIVE
DEFINITION THIS THERE WOULD BE A
BIG PROBLEM AND I WANT TO LAY
OUT WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO AND
KIND OF THE SIMPLEST TERMS.
NUMBER ONE IT WOULD IT WOULD
REQUIRE A COURT A CARE
COORDINATION. OF BOTH AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL AT DIFFERENT TIMES BUT
THEY CAN MOVE FORWARD ASSEMBLY
JAMES LEE. IT WOULD REPORT- WE
ARE A REAPING MECHANISM. A FRAME
WHICH WOULD REAP. THE DOLLARS
USE HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE HOW. WHO
HELPED AND BASED ON WHO HELPED.
AND IT WOULD ALSO BE. THE M. H.
S. A. DOT. WOULD BE. WELL TO PAY
FOR IN BY. AMBLE AND HOLES. NOW
IT. WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE AT THE GOES A
LONG WAYS. TOWARDS HELPING THOSE
PEOPLE WHO WE HAVE. OVER THE
YEARS. WHO FOR ONE REASON
ANOTHER CAN'T GET THE SERVICES
THEY NEED AND ARE PUTTING A
HOLD- IN WHAT IT WOULD DO. AT
THE END OF THE DAY YOU GOTTA ASK
YOURSELF WHAT IS DUE TO THAT
PERSON. THAT HAS TO BE A HEALTH
COORDINATION PLAN. TO THAT
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL BEFORE
THEY ARE RELEASED NOW WE'RE NOT
ASKING THAT THEY BE HELD UNTIL
THERE'S A PLAN WE'RE NOT ASKING
THAT ANY A LOT LAWS BE CHANGED.
FOR THE TO BE IN HELD ANY LONGER
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS THAT
THERE'S GOT TO BE ALL THESE
THINGS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT BUT
WHAT TOLD. IS A- ACCORDING TO
HEALTH PLAN MENTAL HEALTH CARE
PLAN FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL THAT
THAT IS ALL INCOMPLETE BECAUSE
OFTEN TIMES WHAT WE FIND OUT IS
A PEOPLE ARE RELEASED AND THAT
THERE'S NO PLAN I WANT TO GO
THROUGH A COUPLE NUMBERS JUST TO
SHOW YOU HOW IN IS. IN SOMETHING
KIND OF MIGHT. WE ALSO ASKED FOR
AN AUDIT OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND IN TWENTY TWENTY THOSE
ARE AUDIT RELEASED TO US THAT
THE US STATE HONOR HONOR DID AND
IT LOOKED AT- THE STATE IN A PIC
ON L. A. COUNTY THAT FROM FROM
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
FOURTEEN TO TWO THAT. NINETY GET
THE- PEOPLE. WHO ARE PLACED ON
SEVEN TWO HOUR. HAVE FIFTY PRIOR
HOLD HIMSELF. INTERVIEWED IN
WHAT WHAT WAS DONE ABOUT IT OUT
OF A HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX.
THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT WERE HELD
43% OF THOSE PEOPLE WERE HELD
MULTIPLE AMOUNT OF TIME. OUT OF
THAT ADULT PEOPLE THAT WERE HELD
TEN THOUSAND OF THOSE PEOPLE
WILL HOLD OVER TEN TIMES EACH
THAT MEANS THAT WE'VE INVESTED
ALL THIS MONEY. WE HAVE ALL
THESE. PROCEDURES OF ALL THESE
HEALTHCARE SERVICE EVERYTHING WE
PUT OUT THERE MENTAL HEALTH
RESEARCH BUT WHEN A PERSON IS
HELD. THERE'S NOT COORDINATION
PLAN FOR THEM. AND SO WHAT WE'RE
ARGUING HERE IS THAT THERE THAT
THERE HAS TO BE THOSE THREE
THINGS THAT WE MENTIONED. BUT
WHAT WE RESULTS IN IS A
COORDINATED PLAN FOR THIS
PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
BEING HELD SO THAT THEY HAVE
THOSE- SO THAT THEY HAVE THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED THAT COULD
TRANSLATE A BUT IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS. WE CAN CONTINUE
TO DISCUSS BUT MIGHT BE. A
RESPECT FOR THE COMMITTEES I
WOULD HANDLE. THE MISTREATMENT.
CHAMPION WITH OVER NUMBER VIEW.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I'M SURE LIKE THOSE OF
US IN LOS ANGELES THAT MANY OF
YOU. HEAR FROM CONSTITUENTS IN
YOUR AREA ALL THE TIME. ABOUT
THE FRUSTRATION OF SEEING PEOPLE
WHO CLEARLY. HAVE NO BUSINESS
BEING ON THE STREETS WHO ARE.
SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL OR IN THE
THROES OF SOME SORT OF CRISIS.
SEEING THEM SOMETIMES WE AFTER
WEEK YEAR AFTER YOU. SOMETIMES
SEEING THE SAME PEOPLE DIED
BECAUSE MANY OF THEM HAVE
UNDERLYING MEDICAL CONDITIONS
THAT THEY'RE UNABLE TO TREAT- OF
. WHO ARE. UP NOT OBSERVE WHERE
ANY COULD SAY THAT THERE ON THE
STREETS OUT OF CHOICE PEOPLE
SOMETIMES WHO ARE. CLEARLY
DELUSIONAL- SERIOUSLY MENTALLY
ILL AND WHY IN A NATION THAT HAS
THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT WE HAVE THAT WE CAN SEEM
TO. A WAY TO HELP THESE. AND
STAY. AND I AS WHO'S HAD TO IN.
IN MY CLOSE FAMILY. I'M BE THIS
WAS ALMOST GOOD TO ANYTHING
OTHER WAS A SEER BY PAUL
DISORDER. AS THEY ENTERED A IN
BATTLE OF AND SENT TO A DOUBLE.
THAT OUR FAMILIES A BILL. TO-
AND WORK WITH THEM THEY WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN STATE KNOW TWO
INTO TO THIS TIME A POST
GRADUATE COLLEGE BOTH WITH
ADVANCED DEGREES ARE LOOKING
VERY SUCCESSFUL LIVES BUT ONLY
BECAUSE WE WERE ABLE TO OFFER
THEM THAT KIND OF. CLOSE CONTACT
AND HELP AND THE PEOPLE THAT WE
SEE ON OUR STREETS DESERVE THAT
EVERY MUCH IT JUST AS MUCH.
THEY'RE ALL SOMEBODY'S CHILD
THEY'RE ALL SOMEBODY SIBLING AND
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO HELP THEM.
THE FAILING HERE I WOULD LIKE
INTO THIS THAT IT WHEN I WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER AND I LEFT
MY TREATMENT MY HOSPITAL AFTER
MY FIRST SURGERY I WAS GIVEN A
VERY COMPREHENSIVE PLAN FOLLOW A
PLAN THAT LASTED FOR YEARS. I
WASN'T JUST WAS SENT HOME AFTER
SURGERY AND SAID HEY GOOD LUCK
WITH THIS LET US KNOW IF
ANYTHING GOES WRONG. NO I WAS
OFFERED A CONTINUAL CARE
AFTERWARDS- THERE WAS A
REGULARITY TO IT THERE WAS A
COORDINATION BETWEEN CAREGIVERS
BETWEEN AN ONCOLOGIST IN A
PRIMARY POSITION A NUTRITIONAL
LIST AND OTHER. DOCTORS A
SURGEON AND EVERYTHING ELSE AND
YET WE DON'T DO THAT FOR MENTAL
ILLNESS BUT DON'T WE SAY THAT
MENTAL ILLNESS IS AN ILLNESS
JUST AS MUCH AS A PHYSICAL
ILLNESS. IF WE HAVE THAT
UNDERLYING PHILOSOPHY WE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO COORDINATE CARE AFTER
THAT FIRST CONTACT WITH THAT
MENTALLY ILL INDIVIDUAL THEY
SHOULDN'T BE HELD IN JUST SEND
HOME THE SAME WAY THAT SOMEONE
HAS HAD A HEART ATTACK WOULD
NEVER. JUST BE SENT HOME FROM
THE HOSPITAL WITHOUT A FOLLOW UP
PLAN SO IF YOU WANT TO THINK OF
IT IN SIMPLE TERMS THIS IS
REQUIRING THAT KIND OF FOLLOW UP
PLAN FOR SEVERELY MENTALLY ILL
INDIVIDUALS.WHAT WE'RE DOING
NOW AMOUNTS TO NEXT TO NOTHING
AND IT'S NOT WORKING AN
ARCHITECT YOU ANSWER FED UP WITH
IT AND IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE
TOOK A BIGGER AND BOLDER STAFF
AND I BELIEVE THAT SINCE THE
BEGINNING. OF THAT STEP THANK
YOU SO MUCH. VERY MUCH. WITNESS
SUPPORT. THERE REGISTERED. MR
SANTIAGO DO YOU HAVE PEOPLE
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT WITH YOU.
NO ACTUALLY WE CAME UP WITH THIS
- WE CAME UP WITH THIS IDEA. OR
OUT OF THE MANY YEARS THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS AS WELL AS
THE COMMITTEE HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE THAT WE DID SO IT
REALLY IS. A WAY OF SAYING THAT
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WORKS.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY WAY I
DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY
REGISTERED WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HERE SO WHAT WE'LL
DO AT THIS POINT. AS WILL TAKE
A- FURTHER A TESTIMONY THESE
WITH YOU YOUR NAME. ARE YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ANY
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE SO PLEASE COME ON UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. ADRIN HOW DO YOU
WITH A STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERE BROUGHT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ANDREA
WAGNER AT THE CAMPRO AT
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH PEER RUN ORGANIZATIONS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
PAUL SIMONS WIH THE DEPRESSION
AND BIPOLAR SUPPORT ALLIANCE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. AND A LITTLE BAR OF CAMPER
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PIRAN
ORGANIZATIONS DEFINITELY OPPOSE
THANK YOU. AVERY HELLO DESCENTE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND ORGANIZATIONS
ARE CAMPRO OPPOSE THANK YOU. THE
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
CONTINUED CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND COMMITTEE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HOWEVER
SHE'D WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO OPPOSED THANK
YOU. IF. YEAH I HAVE A QUESTION
ON ONE OF THE PEOPLE- HOW COME
THERE'S NO PHONE CALL GOING
RIGHT NOW WE CAN CALL IN ON
WE'RE SORRY AND WE DO NOT HAVE
KNOWN THATTHANK YOU FOR YOUR-
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
THAT'S A VIOLATION ON THE BILL
THE ACT RIGHT YOU KNOW PLEASE
YOU'RE OUT OF ORDER. YOU'RE OUT
FORMALITIES A QUESTION YOU GUYS
TO EXPLAINERS BY THE PEOPLE WE A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE HERE WE HAVE
AROUND TRYING TO GET ON. THERE
ARE NO FIRE THERE IS NO FROM
TODAY ALL TESTIMONIES ON PERSON
BECAUSE WE ARE BECAUSE WE IS
TRANSPARENCY ARE ALLOWED TO DO
THAT POLICY WE CHANGE OUR POLICY
BACK TO WHERE IT USED TO BE. A
WARY FOR COMMITTED YOU TELL ANY
DID YOU NOTICE IT WAS NOTICED IN
THE FILE IT WAS ACT HE WAS
LEGALLY NOTES IN THE FILE LAST
WEEK. NO YOU MAY NOT THINK. THIS
IS IN A MEETING THIS IS A NO
MEETING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
F. THEY ARE JUST A SECOND YOU
DON'T MIND. HI I'M I'M CHEN
CRYSTAL SANTA CLARA COUNTY FORTY
YEARS AUTHENTIC LIVED EXPERIENCE
OF MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSTIC
LABELING- I'M JUST CONCERNED
ABOUT YOU KNOW AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY TWO AND JUST IN GENERAL
YOU KNOW HOW POSITION OR SUPPORT
THAN OPPOSITION- I'M HERE FOR
CARE COURT TODAY. THAT THE BILL
ISN'T IT WE'RE NOT HEARING THAT
BILL TODAY. YEAH WELBECK THANK
YOU WE DON'T HAVE BRING ILLNESS
AND DEATHS WE DON'T IT'S THE
MEDICAL MODEL IS INACCURATE
THANK YOU. AFTER CHURCH MEMBERS
MATTHEW GALLAGHER CAL VOICES
OPPOSED TO US MANAGER THANK YOU
THANK YOU IF IT THAT. ANYONE
ELSE. BRING IT BACK GOT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THIS WATER. I'M
MENTAL HEALTH IS A HUGE ISSUE
FOR THE STATE OBVIOUSLY I'M- YOU
KNOW HAVING A PLAN I THINK IS A
GOOD THING AND HAVING PEOPLE AT
THE TABLE AND TRYING TO COME UP
WITH A PLAN. SEEMS TO ME TO BE.
I'M IN A THE PROBLEM IS IF WE
HAVE FOLKS FOR ON THESE HOLDS
AND THEN THEY'RE JUST RELEASED
BACK OUT THEN IT BECOMES LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S PROBLEM THEN IT
BECOMES A COMMUNITIES PROBLEM
AGAIN IT YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT.
LOOKING AT THE AMENITY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL AND YOU KNOW THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED THAT THEY MAY NOT
REALIZE THAT THEY- OF FAMILIES
THAT DON'T KNOW WHERE THEY ARE
THEIR LOVED ONES AND THINGS LIKE
THAT AND THOSE COSTS AND COST
THE COST THAT WE'RE PAYING. AND
IT SEEMS TO ME IF WE COULD COME
UP WITH A PLAN THAT'S WORKABLE
FOR EVERYBODY- AND ESPECIALLY
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL THEY WON'T BE
GOING THROUGH THE CYCLE AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN AND CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND EVERYTHING
ELSE SO- I'M INTERESTED TO SEE.
WHERE THIS BILL GOES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF ANY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. C. NINE-
I JUST WANT A COPY OF A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS PERSONAL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- AND- CREATE THAT THE
PEOPLE. OF PAID ATTENTION TO OUR
HEARING OF AND THE WORK THAT
WE'VE WE'VE DONE- I THINK WE'RE
ALL. OF STRUGGLING WITH THE
CHALLENGES RELATED TO THIS- I'M
IMPRESSED WITH THE DATA THAT YOU
PRESENTED- BECAUSE NOT EVERY
COUNTY EVERY CITY HAS THE DATA
AND THAT'S PART OF THE CHALLENGE
HERE- AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS I'M WORKING WITH THE
CENTER STONE ON A BILL TO
COLLECT SOME OF THE DATA. COULD
NOT AGREE MORE THE COORDINATION
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND SO- I
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS- THE
BILL DOES ENJOY A DO PASS- TO
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE- MADAM
SECRETARY WITH A AFTER AFTER THE
OF GIVEN OPTION CLOSE TO BE LIKE
. WE NEED A MOTION. GOT A OF YOU
THE LONG SPEED WITH THE
REALITIES YOU'VE GOT A LONG DAY
NOT AT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I WILL BUT THE BOTTOM LINE THIS
IS JUST A MODEST STEP I DON'T
DISAGREE THAT WE SHOULD BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE IN OUR APPROACH I
DON'T DISAGREE THAT THERE'S A
LOT MORE WORK TO DO. BUT BUT
IT'S MODEST IN GIVING A I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES BEST YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A PLAN AT LEAST THIS
INDIVIDUAL IN THERE ARE
MECHANISMS IN A CONTACT AN
INDIVIDUAL OR DOES IT NEED TO
IMPLEMENT THAT PLAN. I THINK
MISTER CHAIRS BUCKLEY HAS MY
BOOK THANK YOU IS THERE A
MOTION. THANK YOU. I CAN'T.
THANK YOU FOR A SECOND
INSTRUMENT A MOTION BY MISTER
NAZARIAN SECOND BY MR MAYES
MOTION IS DUE PASSED YOU
JUDICIARY AMENDED SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON WALDRON I AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BIGELOW CORREO. LARA OR NOT
VOTING. MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MAYES
AYE MCCARTY THIS AREA. NAZARIAN
I RIVAS RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA. IF SIX
VOTES- MISTER SUN HERE WOULD BE
THE BILL ON CALL AND I'M JUST
GOING TO GO BACK IN- AND
REITERATE SOMETHING THAT- THE
TESTIMONY TODAY IS ALL IN PERSON
THIS WAS NOTICED NOTE THIS WAS
NOTICED IN OUR DAILY FILE ON
THURSDAY OF LAST WEEK- THAT IS
THE WAY WE NOTICE THESE
HEARINGS- AND SO. WE WILL NOT BE
HAVING ANY TELEPHONE TESTIMONY
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU THAT
YOUR STUDENTS ARE OUT OF ORDER
YOU'RE OUT OF ORDER. YOU'RE OUT
OF ORDER IF YOU CHOOSE TO
CONTINUE WE WILL ASK YOU TO
LEAVE. I THINK IT'S TIME FOR YOU
TO LEAVE SIR. THANK YOU IT'S
TIME FOR YOU TO LEAVE. THANK YOU
WELL THAT THE SERGEANTS- AS THIS
GENTLEMAN TO LEAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER SALAS YOU HAVE- YOU BILLS
BEFORE US YOU HAVE WON A CONSENT
ASSUME YOU WANT TO BE THAT WHEN
THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY GOOD IDEA
ESPECIALLY OF PLEASE GO AHEAD
WITH AN AYE WE NEED THREE WITH
KNOWING THAT YOU HAVE A LONG
AGENDA- MEMBERS ARE PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
FORTY WHICH UPDATES A MODERNIZES
THE EXISTING SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTER. IT'S A GREAT PROGRAM TO
MEET CURRENT NEEDS OF STUDENT
HEALTH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ANYBODY TO HAVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU..
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINETEEN FORTY HI MY NAME'S LISA
EISENBERG I'M THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE WE
ARE REPRESENT TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY THREE ACTIVE SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND MANY MANY MORE-
PROVIDERS AND SCHOOLS THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN STARTING SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS I DON'T
THINK I NEED TO MAKE THE CASE
FOR WHY WE NEED SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH SERVICES OR THE BENEFIT
OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS I
KNOW THIS COMMITTEE IS VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT. IF YOU WANT
TO QUICKLY SHARE THAT THERE ARE
THREE QUICK ASPECTS THAT MAKE
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTER SO
EFFECTIVE. THEY DELIVER
COMPREHENSIVE INTEGRATED HEALTH
CARE THAT INCLUDES BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. FOR THEIR TEAM BASED
CARE APPROACH TO HEALTH CARE FOR
YOUNG PEOPLE. MANY EVEN PROVIDE
DENTAL CARE AND VISION SERVICES.
THE SECOND ONE IS THAT SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS ARE REALLY
WELL POSITIONED TO HELP STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITIES COME BACK TO
SCHOOLS FROM THE PANDEMIC SO
MANY ARE PROVIDED COVERT COVER
TESTING AND VACCINATIONS. AND
HELPING STUDENTS CATCH UP ON ON
MATT AND EXACERBATED HEALTH CARE
NEEDS. AND SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS OUR PROVEN STRATEGY TO
ADDRESS HEALTH AND EDUCATION
EQUITY THEY PREDOMINATELY ARE
LOCATED IN SCHOOLS WHERE A
MAJORITY OF STUDENTS ARE LOW
INCOME OR STUDENTS OF COLOR. SO
I'M EIGHTY FIVE NINETEEN FORTY
UPDATE OUR CURRENT PROGRAM IN
STATUTE DEFINES SCHOOL MAKES A
STRONG DEFINITION OF SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS AND REALLY
ADAPTS THE GRANT CATEGORIES TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE CURRENT
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTER
FIELD. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK OUT
. MUCH ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN JONES I'M
THE DIRECTOR FOR MOUNTAIN RIGHT
TO LIFE THE CALIFORNIA LICENSE
MEDICAL FACILITY. I COULD NOT BE
MORE IN FAVOR OF PROVIDING
HEALTH CARE FOR CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED AREAS. PROVIDING
SUCH HEALTH SUPPORT THROUGH
SCHOOLS MAKES GOOD SENSE AND
IT'S VITAL TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN MY JOB I SEE FIRSTHAND THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF
HOMELESSNESS AND POVERTY ON
WOMEN AND CHILDREN. IT'S OUR
DUTY TO CARE FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
LITTLE OR NO ACCESS TO RESOURCES
YOU AND I MUST STAND FOR THOSE
IN NEED OF ASSISTANCE BUT
ABORTION IS NOT ASSISTANCE AND A
SOMEONE WHO IS CRIED WITH WOMEN
WHO REGRET THEIR ABORTIONS
MOMENTS AND YEARS LATER I CAN
TELL YOU THAT PROVIDING SCHOOL
BASED. SCHOOL BASED HEALTH.
CENTER SUPPORT PROGRAM THAT
INCLUDES ABORTION IS NOT THE
KIND OF HEALTH CARE OUR CHILDREN
NEED. AMICALE ABORTIONS ACCOUNT
FOR THE MAJORITY OF ALL
ABORTIONS IN THE UNITED STATES
CURRENTLY INJURY FROM THESE
CHEMICAL ABORTIONS INCLUDE HEAVY
BLEEDING REQUIRING SURGERY AND
SECTION SEPSIS PUBLIC
INFLAMMATORY DISEASE
ENDOMETRIOSIS ANXIETY MENTAL
DEPRESSION UP TO DEATH. AB
NINETEEN FORTY WILL FACILITATE
GIVEN THE SAME CHEMICAL ABORTION
PILLS THE GRADE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL GIRLS THROUGH THE SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS. JUST LIKE
SB TWENTY FOUR MANDATES
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC COLLEGES. AND
WORKING IN CONCERT. WITH THE PRO
ABORTION LAWS ALREADY ON THE
BOOKS AND THOSE BILLS CURRENTLY
IN COMMITTEE AB NINETEEN FORTY
IF PASSED WILL ENSURE THAT EVEN
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS LOCATED AT
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS CAN
GIVE CHEMICAL PORTION. THE TWO
YEAR OLD. WITHOUT PARENTS
KNOWLEDGE AND WITHOUT A DOCTOR'S
DIRECT SUPERVISION. BUT WHAT IF
A GIRL TAKES THE CHEMICAL
WORSHAM TONE CHANGES HER MIND
AND SHE GO BACK TO THE SCHOOL
NURSE TO START A PROJECT FROM
TREATMENT TO OFFSET THE
MIFEPRISTONE. IS THAT INCLUDED
IN THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
. GOOGLE BANS ADVERTISING FOR
ABORTION PILL REVERSAL WHICH IS
THE PROGESTERONE TREATMENT EVEN
THOUGH IT'S A LIFESAVING
TREATMENT FOR THE BABY AND
POSSESSES NO RISK TO THE MOTHER
SO WHO DECIDES WHAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CARE. POLITICIANS OR THE PARENTS
FOR THESE REASONS I ASK YOU TO
OPPOSE AB NINETEEN FORTY UNLESS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE PHRASE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE BILL. HELLO MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH RANGEL AND THE
YOUNGEST OF TWELVE CHILDREN I'M
A UNITED STATES VETERAN I HAVE
SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
AIRFORCE RESERVES. AND WORKED AS
A LAW ENFORCEMENT CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS.
I'M A CURRENTLY A CHILDREN'S
PASTOR AND I OVERSEE A
CHILDREN'S MINISTRY AT MY
CHURCH. I'M A PROUD GRANDPARENT
OF TEN GRANDCHILDREN. WITH AB
NINETEEN FORTY CALIFORNIA'S
DOING SOMETHING IT HAS NEVER
DONE BEFORE. I PROVIDING DIRECT
STATE FUNDING FOR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS. YOU CAN HELP
SUPPORT GENERATIONS OF CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
WITH ACCESS TO A NURSE. AND A
LEVEL OF HEALTH CARE. AB
NINETEEN FORTY GOES BEYOND
HEALTH CARE TO ENABLE ABORTION
THROUGH THE SCHOOLS. BEHIND THE
BACKS OF PARENTS DESTROYING THE
CHILD AND PARENT BOND. ABORTION
LEAVES EMOTIONAL AND SOMETIMES
PHYSICAL SCARS IN THIS CHILD ON
CHILDREN I KNOW I HAVE THREE
LIVING CHILDREN AND I'VE HAD FOR
ABORTIONS. SO I'M READILY
FAMILIAR WITH THE PROCESS AND
THE DEVASTATING REGRET AND
SHAME. I HAVE SUFFERED FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS ABORTION
HURTS. I KNOW MANY MOTHERS HAVE
HAD ABORTIONS AND SOME WERE
NEVER ABLE TO HAVE CHILDREN.
SOME OF THEM WERE LED ON A
POWERFUL DRUG ADDICTIONS
ALCOHOLISM SUICIDE. AND REGRET
ISRAEL AND CAN LAST A LIFETIME.
AS A SIDEWALK COUNSELOR I HAVE
PERSONALLY WITNESSED SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS BRING IN YOUNG
GIRLS. AS YOUNG AS TWELVE YEARS
OLD FOR ABORTIONS AT THE PORTION
CLINICS. THEY'RE YOUNG AND THEY
ARE NAIVE AND SCARED TO TELL
THEIR PARENTS. I PERSONALLY WALK
SIDE BY SIDE WITH SOME OF THESE
YOUNG MOMS. THAT WERE AFRAID I
HAVE WATCHED THESE SCENARIOS
PLAY OUT. I HAVE PICTURES OF
THESE BABIES AND THEIR MOMS AND
THEY'RE ALL VERY THANKFUL.
SOMEONE WAS THERE TO GUIDE THEM
IN THE RIGHT PATH. IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A STRONG PRO
LIFE ADVOCATE. NOT SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES ABORTION TO THE ANSWER.
AS WOMEN WE ARE NOT PROMISE
CHILDREN. TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
NURSES SHOULDN'T BE ABORTION
ADVOCATES. BUT THAT'S WHAT AB
NINETEEN FORTY WILL DO. THE BILL
CHANGES THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE TO AUTHORIZE THESE NEW
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS TO
PROVIDE PRIMARY MEDICAL CARE.
THAT INCLUDES REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH SERVICES THROUGH MOBILE
HEALTH INTEL AND TELEHEALTH FOR
TELEHEALTH. REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES IS A CODE FOR ABORTION
THAT MEANS. AB NINETEEN FORTY
WILL DIRECT STATE FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS. TO
PROVIDE ABORTION SERVICES TO
CHILDREN ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES.
THROUGH THE STATE THE NEXT STEP
WILL BE TO PROVIDE ABORTION
PILLS TO GROUP TO GRADE SCHOOLS.
AND HIGH SCHOOL GIRLS ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES THROUGH THE SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS. BECAUSE
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WILL BE IN CHARGE OF
THE MINISTRY. THE NEW SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH PROGRAM UNDER AB
NINETEEN FORTY. THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN CHARGE OF EDUCATING OUR
CHILDREN WILL ALSO BE IN CHARGE
OF PROVIDING CHEMICAL AND
SURGICAL ABORTION SERVICES. TO
THE SCHOOLS AND CAMPUSES. AS A
PARENT AND A GRANDPARENT MYSELF
I CAN SAY PARENTS WANT TO KNOW
THEIR CHILDREN ARE SAFE WHEN
THEY'RE AT SCHOOL. NOT CHORUS
INTO MAKING A LIFE DECISION
WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS KNOWLEDGE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT OUR CHILDREN.
YOUR CHILDREN PLEASE AMEND AB
NINETEEN FORTY TO REMOVE THE
DIVISIVE ISSUE OF ABORTION
FUNDING IN OUR SCHOOLS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SO GOOD OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ANY
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE ANDREW
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALISON RAINY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT YOUR.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. VIDEOBOARD
REPRESENTING SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION WE ANSWERED THANK
YOU. I'M CONNIE CORNEAL FROM
FREMONT AND TYPOS AB. A REPORT
THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROXANNE GOLD WITH THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
ENGINEER. ALICE PETROVICH MY
OPPOSE AB NINETEEN FORTY YOUR- A
GREG BIRD WITH A CALIFORNIA
FAMILY COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION IF
. A PASTOR BRANDON CAMPBELL WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CAPITOL
CONNECTION REPRESENTING BAPTIST
CHURCHES UP AND DOWN THE STATE
AND I AM NOT WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. YOU KNOW WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTION THE FIGURE CURRY- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORD SLEEP I HAVE
SLEEPLESS NIGHTS THINKING ABOUT
OUR CHILDREN NOT HAVING SOME
HEALTH CARE AT THEIR SCHOOLS
MMHM AND YEARS AGO I HAD HEALTH
CARE AT THE- MY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. THIS IS WHAT I GOT. I
GOT HIS THERE'S NO ONE THAT YOU
KNOW AND THEY JUST DON'T HAVE
THAT KIND OF SERVICE AS MUCH AS
THEY USED TO AND I JUST. THINK
IN THIS TIME IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE EMBRACE OUR
CHILDREN. AND- I KNOW YOU'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS BILL BUT I THINK IT'S A
IT'S A GOOD. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOUR CURRY
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS IT WAS SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS MAKE SURE THAT
KIDS THAT NEED EYEGLASSES ARE
GETTING EYEGLASSES KIDS THAT
NEED MENTAL HEALTH ARE GETTING
MENTAL HEALTH. IT'S A NEED ANY
TYPE OF SERVICES THERE'S A PLACE
TO DO IT SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
DONE THIS ON THEIR OWN THROUGH
THEIR- ACE. WE WANT TO DO IS WE
WANT TO PROVIDE THIS MECHANISM
FOR ALL SCHOOLS I THAT FOR.
CHILDREN RESPECT TO THE
OPPOSITION. WAS THAT'S GIVEN
TESTIMONY BELIEVE IT'S- BASE
THERE'S NO. SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTER THAT'S OFFERING ANY
ABORTION SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I BELIEVE IT'S OFF BASE AND I
BELIEVE DOES NOT PERTAIN TO THIS
BILL WE'RE REALLY JUST TRYING TO
LOOK OUT FOR OUR CHILDREN I
THINK THAT'S WHY. YOU HAVE ALL
OF THE ORGANIZATIONS AND THE-
GROUPS THAT YOU'RE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THAT ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. THE ONE DO WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR THE MOTION BY
MISTER. A SECOND MISTER NAZARIAN
EMOTION BE PASSED TO EDUCATION
WHICH I TO CLOSE MISTER SOUTH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MATTER SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL WHEN I WHEN I WALDRON.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW CORREO. LARA
LOHR NO MAIENSCHEIN FAITH MAYES
NAZARIAN I REQUEST. RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO. GARCIA. YOU DON'T YOUR
THREE VOTE SOME WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF MEMBERS WHO WERE OUT ABOUT OF
AWFULLY THE BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH. WE'RE MOVING ON
TO AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY ONE. BY
MISTER FLORA THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS THAT PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY ONE WHAT TO
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM TO HELP
MORE CITIES ESTABLISHMENT MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS TEAMS TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR INDIVIDUALS IN
CRISIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. I THINK WE
ARE WE HELD THEM OFF FOR THE
NEXT COMMITTEE KNOWING YOU HAVE
A LOT. AND THEY WERE READY THAT
LAST WEEK TO- ENOUGH- ANYBODY IN
THE HEARING ROOM HOW. LIKE TO
TAKE A POSITION ON THE BILL FOR
AGAINST. IN NO ONE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE
MOTION BY MISTER LARA SECOND BY
MISTER NAZARIAN- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE ESPECIALLY ASK
PRIVATE ONE TIME TO PREPARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE TIME
IS APPROPRIATE- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHEN I WHEN
I WALDRON. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
BIGELOW RIO LAURA. LAURA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES. MAYES AYE
MCCARTY. THIS AREA. NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO GARCIA. ZERO FIVE ZERO LEAVE THAT
ALONE BECAUSE WELL I THINK THIS
IS ALLISON MEMBERS. THIS WEBER.
YEAH THREE BILLS BEFORE US- RT.
WITH HAVE TO GET YOU SOME WATER
HE LIKES. I'M LIKE TO START WITH
THE SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN IS
THAT OKAY MADNESS OKAY THANK YOU
WITH EVERY READY THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBERS I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. IMMODEST BELL TO
IMPROVE THE CALIFORNI
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY. WHICH IS
AN EXISTING PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE TOOL.
IMMUNIZATION INFORMATION SYSTEMS
ARE CONFIDENTIAL POPULATION
BASED COMPUTERIZED DATABASES
THAT RECORD MMUNIZATION DOSES
GIVEN BY PARTICIPATING PROVIDERS
. ALL FIFTY STATES HAVE THEM.
IMMUNIZATION INFORMATION SYSTEMS
ARE BENEFICIAL BECAUSE THEY
DETERMINED VACCINATION STATUS TO
A DECISIONS MADE BY CLINICIANS
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND SCHOOLS
GUIDE PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSES TO
OUTBREAKS OF VACCINE PREVENTABLE
DISEASES. AND FORM ASSESSMENT OF
VACCINATION COVERAGE MISSED
VACCINATION OPPORTUNITIES
INVALID DOSE ADMINISTRATION AND
DISPARITIES IN VACCINATION
BECAUSE- THEY ALSO FACILITATE
VACCINE MANAGEMENT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THE CALIFORNIA
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY ALSO KNOWN
AS CAR. CAME INTO EXISTENCE OVER
TWENTY YEARS AGO AND WAS
ESTABLISHED IN THE LATE NINETEEN
NINETIES. THE SYSTEM BEGAN WITH
MANY DIFFERENT INDEPENDENT
COUNTY BASED SYSTEMS AND WE HAVE
SINCE BEEN UPGRADED TO BECOME A
MORE CENTRALIZED STATEWIDE
DATABASE. TO DATE EVERY COUNTY
IN CALIFORNIA IS A PART OF THE
STATEWIDE SYSTEM EXCEPT SAN
JOAQUIN. WHO CURRENTLY HAS ITS
OWN IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY SYSTEM. ADDITIONALLY CURRENTLY ABOUT
86% OF CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
UNDER THE AGE OF SIX HAVE TWO OR
MORE IMMUNIZATIONS RECORDED IN
THE SYSTEM. THIS SYSTEM IS
OUTLINED IN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE ONE TWO ZERO FOUR
FOUR ZERO AND LAYS OUT THE LEGAL
FRAMEWORK FOR REPORTING THE
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY AND TO
WHOM CERTAIN INFORMATION THE
REGISTRY MAY BE READ DISCLOSED.
THE EXISTING LAW ALSO ALLOWS THE
IMMUNIZATION INFORMATION TO BE
SHARED WITH THE IMMUNIZATION
ALSO ALLOWS IT IMMUNIZATION
INFORMATION TO BE SHARED WITH
THE IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY AS
LONG AS THE PARENT. OR PATIENT
IS INFORMED ABOUT THE REGISTRY.
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO LOCK
THEIR RECORD SO THAT IT IS NOT
SHARED WITH ANY OTHER CARE USER.
ONLY THEIR PHYSICIAN WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT IMMUNIZATION
INFORMATION. THE IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY STATUES SHORTS STRICT
CONFIDENTIALITY AND DOES NOT
VIOLATE HIPPA GUIDELINES AND
AGREEMENT. TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
IN THE CARE SYSTEM THE PROVIDER
USER MUST SIGN A CONFIDENTIALITY
AGREEMENT AND VIEWING OF PATIENT
RECORDS ARE TRACK TO MAINTAIN AN
AUDIT TRAIL. IT IS CONFIDENTIAL
AND IT IS SAFE. PURPOSE OF THIS
BILL. IS TO ALLOW KERR'S ABILITY
TO EVALUATE THE ACCURACY OF
IMMUNIZATION RATE DEPENDS ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF TIMELY ACCURATE
AND COMPLETE INFORMATION
PERTAINING TO VACCINATIONS
RECEIVED BY MEMBERS OF A
POPULATION. CURRENTLY IN
CALIFORNIA NOT ALL IMMUNIZATION
PROVIDERS ARE RECORDING THE
IMMUNIZATIONS THEY GIVE. THE
INFORMATION IS ONLY AS COMPLETE
AS THE INFORMATION THAT IS
PLACED AND BY THE IMMUNIZATION
PROVIDERS. AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN WILL ONLY CHANGE THREE
SIMPLE THINGS TO THE EXISTING
REGISTRY. ONE IT WOULD REQUIRE
ALL VACCINE PROVIDERS TO RECORD
THE INFORMATION INTO THE
REGISTRY TO BOLSTER COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE DATA. TWO IT REQUIRES
THE COLLECTION OF RACE AND
ETHNICITY DATA ACCURATELY TO
ADVANCE HEALTH EQUITY AND
RECOGNIZE DISPARITIES. AND THREE
A. CLARIFIES THE SCHOOLS CAN
ACCESS VACCINATION STATUS DURING
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES TO AID
AND STUDENT SAFETY. AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SEVEN IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION PROTECT US SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SUPPORTED BY THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS.
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PEDIATRICIAN PHYSICIANS
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ASSOCIATION LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT SACRAMENTO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
TEENS FOR VACCINATIONS
INCORPORATED. WITH ME TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IS KATHERINE FLORES
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION AND SUSAN PARN DOLLAR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR NURSING AND
WELLNESS FROM SANTA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN WOULD AND MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KATHERINE FLORES MARTIN
I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
COALITION AND WE'VE WORKED FOR
YEARS WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
CREATE STRONG AND EFFECTIVE
LAWS. THAT RESULTED IN
PROTECTING MILLIONS OF CHILDREN
TEENS AND ADULTS. THIS BILL
MAKES SEVERAL CHANGES A DOCTOR
WEBER TO SAID IN THE END UPDATES
THE SYSTEM AND HELP ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA'S BETTER PREPARED TO
OUR NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH. AGENCY
AND WE WILL HAVE ANOTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THE UPDATES
WILL REQUIRE A START WEBER SAID
HEALTH PRACTITIONERS TO ENSURE
THAT THE DATA ON THE VACCINES
THEY ADMINISTER WILL BE RECORDED
IN THE REGISTRY WILL. CASES
PATIENTS REYES THE CITY BE
RECORDED THIS FIELD IS ALREADY
IN THE SYSTEM IT WOULD JUST
REQUIRE THAT THE THAT THE BE
RECALL THAT BE CHECKED- ALONG
WITH AUTHORIZING SCHOOLS TO DATE
ON ALL VACCINES RELATED TO
SCHOOL SAFETY AGAIN ENSURING
THAT WE'RE PREPARED FOR THE NEXT
EVENT- THE CALIFORNIA REGISTRY
IS A SECURE CONFIDENTIAL SYSTEM
USED BY DOCTORS AND OTHER HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS INCLUDING
PHARMACIES AN OPTOMETRIST THOSE
WERE REQUIRED. OR AUTHORIZED TO
GET VACCINES SO THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS CAN GET THE
VACCINES THEY NEED AT THE RIGHT
TIME- THE LEGISLATURE FIRST
AUTHORIZED REGISTRY NINETY EIGHT
AND SINCE THAT TIME MILLIONS OF.
DOSES HAVE BEEN RECORDED IN THE
REGISTRY AND IT'S BEEN AN
INTEGRAL SOURCE OF INFORMATION
FOR STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO BE ABLE TO DO
THEIR WORK. FOR HEALTHCARE
PRACTITIONERS TO FORECAST WHAT
CHILDREN NEED BEFORE THEY START
SCHOOL FOR PHARMACISTS TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP UP ADULT UP TO DATE
ON THEIR IMMUNIZATIONS. AND
OTHER AUTHORIZED USERS THIS BILL
LIKE SCHOOLS TO DOCUMENT
VACCINES FOR TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
TRACK OF VACCINES. AS OF
SUBSUMING MEMBER WEBER SAID THAT
CONSOLIDATES THE WRECKED. FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES INTO ONE
SINGLE RECORD FORECAST WHAT
IMMUNIZATIONS ARE DO
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT SINCE WE
DO HAVE A LOT OF VACCINES NOW.
MANAGES A VACCINE INVENTORY
OFFICES REALLY LIKE THIS MEDICAL
ASSISTANTS AND MANAGERS THAT USE
THESE SYSTEMS LOVE THE SYSTEM.
ASSIST PROVIDERS WITH CONDUCTING
REMINDER RECALL REMINDING
PARENTS TO GET THEIR- FLU SHOT.
AND PRODUCES A VARIETY OF
PATIENT SPECIFIC AN AGGREGATE
REPORTS. AUTHORIZE USERS INCLUDE
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND SCHOOLS
HAVE READ ONLY ALONG WITH CHILD
CARE FACILITIES HEALTH CARE
PLANS AND FOSTER CARE AGENCIES.
AS WE SAID USERS ARE REQUIRED TO
SIGN CONFIDENTIALITY AGREEMENTS
AND UNDERGO REQUIRED TRAINING
BEFORE THEY CAN USE THE SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM WAS ALREADY IN PLACE
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC AND
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAM HAS BEEN
DILIGENTLY ACCOMPLISHING
IMPORTANT WORK TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
PRACTITIONERS. ONCE COVERED
NINETEEN VACCINES BECAME
AVAILABLE AVAILABLE THE SYSTEM
GREW TO BECOME EVEN MORE
SIGNIFICANT TO OUR PANDEMIC
RESPONSE EFFORTS. WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO ALL OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH PARTNERS HEALTHCARE
PRACTITIONERS ORGANIZATIONS WHO
HAVE WORKED TO ENSURE ITS
CONTINUED SUCCESS. IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH COMMUNITY AND HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS HAVE SUCCESSFULLY USED
TO REGISTRY FOR DECADES THEY'RE
HAPPY WITH THE SYSTEM AND THEY
ARE SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION AND
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SUSAN
BARTON DOLLAR AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF NURSING
AND WELLNESS AT THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I COME
TO YOU WITH THIRTY YEARS
EXPERIENCE AS A NURSE. TWENTY OF
THOSE AS A SCHOOL NURSE IN SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
IS THE SECOND LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA WE SERVE
STUDENT POPULATION OF A HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS AT A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SIX SCHOOLS OUR
STUDENT POPULATION CONSISTS OF
NEARLY 45% OF STUDENTS WHO ARE
LATINO TWENTY THREE POINTS
PERCENT ARE WHITE. EIGHT POINT
PER WHO IDENTIFIED. THIS 73% WHO
ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN AND NINE
POINT 7% WHO ARE ASIAN. NEARLY
55% OF OUR STUDENTS ALSO QUALIFY
FOR FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH
MEALS. AS A SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
PANDEMIC HAS DEMONSTRATED AND
NEED FOR INFORMATION TO
EFFECTIVELY SERVE STUDENTS AND
TO DO IT WITH EQUITY. AT SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED WE DEFINE EQUITY
AS PROVIDING STUDENTS WITH WHAT
THEY NEED WHEN THEY NEED IT AND
HOW THEY NEED IT. AS A SCHOOL
DISTRICT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES WE FACE IN HELPING
OUR MOST IMPACTED STUDENTS IS
KNOWING WHO HAS ACCESS TO A
VACCINE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY WHO
DOES NOT HAVE ACCESS TO A FAX
SEEKING. ACCESS TO THE REGISTRY
IS CRITICAL FOR US TO ASSESS THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR SCHOOLS
IN TO ENSURE THAT OUR SCHOOLS
REMAIN OPEN EVEN DURING A
PANDEMIC. ACCESS TO THE REGISTRY
WILL ALSO ALLOW US TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THERE ARE SPECIFIC
SCHOOLS THAT NEED ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT. TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH ACCESS TO VACCINES. ACCESS
TO THE REGISTRY DURING A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WILL ALSO
REMOVE THE BURDEN ON PARENTS AND
THEY'RE VERY BUSY SCHEDULES. TO
COMMUNICATE WITH SCHOOLS WHEN
THEIR CHILD HAS BEEN VACCINATED.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WILL SIMPLY
BE ABLE TO CHECK THE REGISTRY ON
A REGULAR BASIS TO CONFIRM A
STUDENT HAS BEEN VACCINATED.
THIS WILL ALSO BE CRITICALFOR
HOMELESS FOSTER CARING YOUTH AND
MAY NOT ALWAYS BE AWARE OF THE
NEED TO INFORM THEIR SCHOOL
ABOUT A VACCINE OR ACCESS TO A
VACCINE. FOR THESE REASONS SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED IS A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. AND THANKS ASSEMBLY
REMEMBER WEBER WELL THAT WAS
EASY TO SAY FOR HER LEADERSHIP
IN OFFERING THIS PROPOSAL. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU AE
VOTE AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ARE THEIR OPPOSITION WITNESS.
HI MY NAME'S KRISTINA HILDEBRAND
FROM A VOICE FOR TRADE ADVOCACY
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
COMMITTEE STAR FOR WORKING WITH
US ON THIS BILL. OUT WILEY WE
AGREED THAT THE IMPROVEMENTS
NEED TO BE MADE TO THE
CALIFORNIA MINIMIZATION REGISTRY
THIS BILL DOESN'T ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THOSE CONCERNS. HONESTLY
THE REGISTRIES AMASSED. AMONG
CHILDREN THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
DUPLICATION OF RECORDS WITH A
HUNDRED AND 7% OF ZERO TO FIVE
YEAR OLDS IN CALIFORNIA HAVING
VACCINE RECORDS IN THE DATABASE.
WE ALSO THAT THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE AMEND THE BILL TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES SO THAT THE
DATA AND THE REGISTRIES IS
ACCURATE. THE REMAINDER OF OUR
CONCERNS REVOLVE AROUND PRIVACY
WHICH WE ARE THANKFUL CALIFORNIA
TAKES VERY SERIOUSLY. CURRENTLY
THE CALIFORNIA IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY CLAIMS TO BE AN OPT OUT
REGISTRY. BUT IT ONLY ALLOWS FOR
THE LOCKING OF DATA. CURRENTLY
NOT ALL DOCTORS OR VACCINE
PROVIDERS INPUT VACCINES INTO
THE REGISTRIES. IF THEY DO THEY
MUST DISCLOSE THAT THEY ARE
DOING SO TO PATIENTS PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS BUT THEY PEOPLE
CANNOT DO ANYTHING TO STOP THE
INPUTTING IF THEY DISAGREE. THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE ALL ACCINE
PROVIDERS TO ENTER OR VACCINES.
WE RECEIVED NUMEROUS CONCERNED
COLES AND EMAILS FROM
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES AND THOSE
WHO ARE CONCERNED FOR THE
PRIVACY OF OUR MEDIC. THE AUTHOR
SHOULD ALSO. SEND THAT THIS MAY
REDUCE THE VACCINES. THAT AMONG
THESE GROUPS. WE ALSO THE AUTHOR
IN THE COMMITTEE AMEND THE
REGISTRY TO BE OPT IN. WHERE
PATIENTS PARENTS AND GUARDIANS
CAN DECIDE IF THE RECORDS ARE
PUT INTO THE REGISTRIES AT THE
TIME OF VACCINATION. THERE'S
ALSO DISCONNECT REGARDING ONE OF
THE GOALS OF THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY REGARDING WHAT
SCHOOLS AND OTHER ENTITIES WILL
BE ABLE TO DOWNLOAD AND A PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. IF THAT IS A
LARGE DOWNLOADS OF COMMUNITY
DATA TO WHICH WERE OPPOSED OR
JUST VACCINES RELATED TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY ON AN
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT ADULT CLIENT
BASIS WE ALSO THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE TO DEFINE IMMUNIZATION
STATUS ASSESSMENTS. TO REFLECT
THE LATTER WE ALSO ALSO THAT THE
AUTHOR ENSURES THAT HIPAA AND
POP FOLLOW THE MEDICAL RECORDS
ONCE THERE ARE ACCESS BY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS. WE ALSO
COMMITTEE TO OPPOSE THE BILL
UNLESS THE AUTHOR GREASE TO
THESE REQUESTED AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THIS
POINT WILL GO TO- OTHER BROTHERS
IN EITHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME.
POSITION ON THE BILL AND ANY
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. THIS. WILL BE LIMITED JUST
AT THE BEFORE YOU START WILL BE
LIMITING THIS PART TESTAMENT TO
FORTY FIVE MINUTES TOTAL SO
PLEASE PLEASE COME BACK BECAUSE
OUR DIMINISH A SURE WAY.
QUINTANILLA BACK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH COALITION
ADVOCACY. OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS GAIL
CAMPAIGN I'M A FARMER FROM BUY
SELL YOU CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALL
FOUNDER THE PROGRESSIVE CAUCUS
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAVE PRESIDED OVER THE FIRST
MEETING STRONG DEMOCRATIC
ACTIVISTS TRYING TO GET OUR OWN
CANDIDATES SELECTED. ALSO
REMEMBER THE CALIFORNIA CAMANCHE
JUSTICE THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF CRIMINAL DEFENSE ATTORNEYS. I
SUPPOSE BECAUSE THE RACIALLY
DISCRIMINATORY ASPECTS OF THE
BILL. JUST YOUR NAME POSITION
AND ORGANIZATION OF YOUR
REPRESENT ONE AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS DENNIS QUESTOR METAL
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. KAYLEE K. ON BEHALF OF PROTECT
US AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. RACHEL
GATES EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR
WITH THE PEOPLE'S CONVOY AND
OPPOSE THANK YOU. HI MAN AT MY
NAME IS MEGAN MCKENNA AND I
OPPOSE SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN.
IF. SEAN MCKEON AND I OPPOSE AND
I'M A CITIZEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ALISON RAINY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT YOUR. BRIAN RIX OF
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KATHY MUST FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CALIBURGER SISKIYOU COUNTY FOR
MYSELF AND MY FATHER WHO IS IN
DHAKA AND OUT TO WHICH AND WAS A
GUARD AT THE NUREMBERG TRIAL. WE
DON'T WANT IT TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
THANK YOU. MAHNESHAN ALLEN-
THANK YOU I'M A RESIDENT LOCAL
CARMICHAEL- I REPRESENT THE
PEOPLE CONVOY AND I'M AGAINST IT
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS STACY
MARTINEZ I'M A LICENSED NURSE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
AGAINST THIS BILL. THANK YOU. HI
JULIE HILLS AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT CAN FOCUS ON THE
BEHALF OF PEOPLE'S CONVOYS
OPPOSING THE SPELL. THANK YOU
THANK. MY NAME IS MICHAEL HAAS
AND I'M WITH PEOPLE'S CONWAY I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THIRTY ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION IN SUPPORT AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY MONEY I
CANNOT A SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. MY
NAME IS MY NAME IS VERONICA FROM
YUBA COUNTY N. ON BEHALF OF THE
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE'S CONVOY
AND I. MS A STRONG OPPOSITION OF
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
G. EPISKOPI I'M FROM ARDEN
ARCADE AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
CONVOY HERE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU IF.
ANYONE ELSE. NO ONE BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MR MAYES. I THINK YOU
AS CHAIR- SO YOU KNOW I DIDN'T
SUPPORT THANK FORGET WHAT'S THE
ONE THAT WHAT THE BILLS AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN MAN IT'S BY A LONG
TIME AGO A LONG TIME AGO LIKE
THE NUMBERS ALL START TO GO AWAY
I DIDN'T END UP SUPPORTING. THE
VACCINE AND MANDATE IS THE LAW
IN IN CALIFORNIA MY GUESS IS THE
REASON WHY THERE'S OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IS BECAUSE THERE'S
FOLKS THAT DON'T WANT THEIR NAME
TO BE IN A REGISTRY BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T GOT THEIR VACCINATIONS
THAT'S MY GUESS THAT'S PROBABLY
WHY. MY PUBLIC EMAIL ACCOUNT GOT
BANNED- OVER THE LAST TWO WEEKS
BUT SURE ALL OF YOU GOT THOSE IS
AS WELL I'M NOT GOT AND THEN-
WHO VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE- HEY I UNDERSTAND IT- AND
I UNDERSTAND IT'S A VERY STE.
THAT YOU HAVE. A BUT IS LAW IN
CALIFORNIA- AND- IT'S UP.
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR-
THAT OUR CHILD CARE CENTERS. AND
OTHERS KNOW THAT THE FOLKS THAT
ARE THE KIDS THAT ARE GOING- ARE
ARE VACCINATED YET AND THEN
THERE THERE IS THAT. OF THAT
DATA- YEAH I'VE GOT. A THREE AND
A HALF ALMOST FOUR MONTH. OLD
AND GONE THROUGH THE FIRST SET
OF AXE IS AND GET IT READY IF.
VERY TO BE ABLE TO GO FOR THE-
NEXT SET OF VACCINES. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION SO
THAT WHEN SHE GETS READY TO GO.
TO SCHOOL THAT. IT'SALL
ALIGNED. THE ONE. THE BILL
TODAY- BUT- IN REGARDS TO THE
QUESTION TO BE ABLE TO LOCK-
THAT HE SAID TO TALK ABOUT THAT
A LITTLE BIT TALK ABOUT THE
PRIVACY OF IT- AND THE PURPOSE
ALLOWING. BE ABLE TO BLOCK. DATA
SO I'LL I WILL LET MY- ONE OF MY
WAY SPEAKING AND I'LL SPEAK FROM
A PHYSICIAN'S RIGHT SO THERE THE
SYSTEM HAVE WE HAVE A WEBSITE
THAT PARENTS. TO HAVE. NOT
SHARED WITH OTHERS- THE DATA
STILL AVAILABLE TO THE STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT BUT NO
OTHER SEAT YOU THE USUALLY
PEOPLE WANT THEIR OWN DOCTOR TO
BE ABLE TO SEE THEIR- IF. THE
LAW FOR THE- NOT TO BE SEEN BY
THE PERHAPS OR ANOTHER DOCTOR WE
FOUND IN THE PAST THE MOST
PARENTS MAY HAVE CONCERNED IF
ANY PARENT AND IS A SMALL NUMBER
IF THEY HAVE CONCERNS IN A
LOCKET THEN THEY REALIZE IT'S
NOT SHARED WITH PEOPLE THEY
NEEDED HAVE. BUT YOU. THE FORMER
. TAX BEST BUT WHAT WOULD
SOMEONE POCKET BE THE PURPOSE OF
IN THAT JUST LIKE SOME OF US
DON'T STROLLER DATE WHEN WE UP
FOR OR WHEN WE- SOME PEOPLE
DON'T WANT OTHER PEOPLE TO.
MAYBE ARE THEY FEEL. STRONGLY
ABOUT. THIRTY SERVICE THE ABOUT
PRIVACY IS. MAYBE DON'T UNDER
THAT IT. IT IS JUST THEIR
CHILD'S IMMUNIZATION HISTORY
THERE'S NO OTHER MEDICAL HISTORY
THEY MAY NOT MAY NOT REALIZE
THAT IT'S JUST THEIR
IMMUNIZATION JUST I WOULD GIVE.
CHILD CARD THAT'S WHAT REGISTRY
TO HELP THE SPACE THAT DATA. IN
A ONE. RESOURCE THAT. AFTER THIS
. THAT HELPED DOES IT DOESN'T IS
ONE QUICK STORY NOW WE A LONG
LONG- BUT I DO THINK IMPORTANT
FOR US TO HAVE ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORDS- AND DID YOU.
COOLEY FOR ME IN MY TO COUNTY
RIVERSIDE IN SAN BENITO COUNTY-
WE DO HAVE THAT AND I CHANGE
FROM ONE HEALTH PLAN TO THE
OTHER HEALTH ABOUT ONCE. AND I
STEPPED ON A- SANDALS ON WENT
THROUGH THE SANDAL INTO MY FOOT-
AND MY WIFE SAID YOU'RE GOING TO
THE DOCTOR TO GO GET- A WIN OF
LAST TETANUS SHOT COULDN'T
REMEMBER. SOME I GOT MY SHOT I
GO PLAN AND TURNS OUT THAT EVEN
WITH THE NEW HEALTH PROVIDER
BECAUSE OF THE SYSTEM THAT WE'VE
GOT. COUNTY THAT THEY HAD RECORD
IT JUST HAPPENS TO BE A TEN
YEARS AND THANKFULLY I WAS ABLE
TO GET. A TECHNICIAN OUT DIDN'T
HAVE TO GO GET ONE BUT WHEN MY-
WHEN MY BABY WAS BEING BORN- SO
YOU WERE DOUBTS. THANKFULLY THEY
HAVE HEARD OF THAT I THINK IT
MAKES. FOR A TO HAVE A- PLACE
WHERE. THAT DAY. TO THE- SAYS.
BUT THAT HAVE GOING TITERS IN
SORT OF. FIGURE OUT WHICH IS
MUSICIANS YOU HAPPY DON'T HAVE
SO AGAIN I'M SO. OF THIS. THANK
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY.
THIS AGUIAR-CURRY THING THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DR NUMBER
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. THERE'S NOTHING
BETTER THAN HAVING ALL THAT
INFORMATION IN ONE PLACE. AND I
THINK IN THE SAME WAY AT-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MACE'S JUST SAID
IS THAT. IN CHILDREN MYSELF IF I
WOULD MAKE IT MORE BECAUSE I
CAN'T REMEMBER ONE DAY FROM THE
NEXT TO WHERE I. FOR MY
INFORMATION'S GONE TOO. FAR TO
TRAVEL OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY I
DON'T REMEMBER WHAT I'VE TAKEN
SO STRONG AS TO HAVE IT ALL IN
ONE PLACE. BUT ALWAYS REMIND
MYSELF WHAT MY JOB IS ABOUT.
WHEN YOUNG PEOPLE ASK YOU WHAT
YOUR- THAT FIFTY. WHAT STREET
WROTE POLICE FIRE THE PUBLIC
SAFETY IS A BIG PIECE OF IT AND
SO THIS IS A- ALMOST. THAT THINK
. HAVE YOU MAKE WE- ALL OF OUR-
YEAH. THE WHAT. IS IT DID YOU.
SURE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR N.
AND THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I BUT
I JUST HAD A QUICK QUESTION- AND
SOMETIMES IT'S HARD TO. HAVE A-
THE XIN ABOUT THIS OUT HAVING
EITHER SIDE BE UPSET WITH YOU.
WHEN YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO
DERIVE THE DATA AND INFORMATION-
BUT- WHAT I'M JUST. WHEN I WAS
GOING THROUGH THE ANALYSIS AND
SPEAKING ALSO TO MY STAFF WHEN I
WAS TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WAS.
HOW MANY SCHOOLS WERE NOT
PROVIDING THE VACCINE
INFORMATION NECESSARY THAT
REQUIRES US. TO HAVE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS IN PLACE THAT THE
REQUIRES INFORMATION INFORMATION
TO BE GATHERED. UP TO WHAT BUT I
GUESS WHAT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT IS WHAT'S BEEN THE ISSUES
WITH COMPLIANCE THAT'S REQUIRING
US TO DO THIS BILL. RIGHT SO
THIS BILL MANY MANY PROVIDERS
ALREADY USE THE REGISTRY THE
MAJORITY PROVIDERS USE REGISTRY
WE HAVE SO MANY MORE NEW
PROVIDERS THAT ARE. ALSO USED IN
REGISTERING OUTLAW WHAT MORE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF ADULT IMMUNIZATION FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S A LIFESPAN REGISTRY
SO IN A BUT PRIMARILY AT FIRST
WE WERE FOCUSING ON CHILDREN BUT
- EVERYBODY. LIKE I SAID
MILLION. INTO DOSES OF GONE IN
SINCE COVERT VACCINES BECOME
AVAILABLE. AND THE GOAL IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL PROVIDERS ARE
USING IT I'D HAVE TO ONE ALSO
SURE THAT MAJORITY OF DATE. WAS
SHARED BY TWO MILITANTS WERE
LINKED WITH. ELECTRONIC HEALTH
WE HAVE A GREAT STAFF AT CDPH
TONS OF FOLKS WORKING ON MAKING
PERMITS IT SEEMS THIS. THE CARE
PROVIDERS GET THAT DATA THE ROOT
STREET SO WE WANT TO GO THE
EXTRA MILE NOW TO GET THOSE.
OTHER PROVIDERS THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN USING THE REGISTRY FOR
WHATEVER REASON AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE. DOES THAT HELP
ANSWER THAT'S ONE OF THEM SHOT
THE OTHER PART IS MAKING SURE
THAT SCHOOLS. ARE FINANCED OUT
THAT- THE SCHOOLS HAVE ACCESS TO
BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT VACCINES
CHILDREN HAVE. IT THEY CAN SEE
THE REQUIRED SCHOOL DOCUMENTS
VACCINATIONS RIGHT NOW BUT IN IN
SOME. THE PUBLIC HEALTH. ME NEED
TO BE. SOME GOOD. YEAH I THINK I
AM CHILDREN MOVE IN CHILDREN A
LOT AND BEFORE I CAN WOULD HAVE
THEIR OWN I MEAN IS REGISTRY OR
A SCHOOL WOULD COLLECTED THEY
WOULD HAVE THEIR OWN REGISTRY
THEIR OWN DATABASE WITHIN THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT N. AND THEN THEY
WOULD MOVE AND ALL F THAT
INFORMATION WOULD BE LOST
MILITARY IF GOOD DAY OF THAT YOU
KNOW WHICH THAT WHERE DID PUT
THAT RECORD. BEFORE I MOVED HERE
FROM STATE WHERE IS IT I GET
PERMISSION AND SO I THINK THAT.
HAVING IT ALL IN ONE PLACE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
EVERYBODY FROM CALIFORNIA CAN GO
LOOK AT THAT ONE SPOT JUST MAKE
SO MUCH MORE SENSE IT JUST GETS
RID OF ALL THAT FOR. BUT YOU
HAVE DATA TO WHAT- IF THERE'S
BEEN A CHALLENGE OR HAVE YOU
BEEN ABLE TO QUANTIFY WHAT'S NOT
BEING REPORTED THAT IS POSING A
PROBLEM TO NECESSITATE THIS. WE
NEED TO PREPARE FOR THE FUTURE
AND MAKE SURE THAT ALL PROVIDERS
ARE ACCESSING THE SYSTEM TO PUT
IN THE IMMUNIZATION DATA TO KNOW
WHERE OUR POPULATIONS THAT- WE
KNOW IT'S A SMALL AMOUNT BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
HAPPENING BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO THE WHOLE POPULATION. AND I
KNOW WHO YEAH GO AHEAD. SO I
THINK- YOU KNOW WHEN YOU KNOW
BETTER YOU DO BETTER RIGHT AND
SO. WE YOU KNOW. TEN FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO EVEN MORE WHEN I
STARTED- AS A PHYSICIAN WE WERE
RIDING ON CHART. RIGHT AND- THE
ISSUE WAS DO WE UNDERSTAND
EVERYBODY'S HAND WRITING OR WITH
A LOSS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND THEN WE SLOWLY STARTED
SWITCHING OVER TO ELECTRONIC
MEDICAL RECORDS REMEMBER WE DID
CERNER AND CHICAGO WHEN I WAS AT
COOK COUNTY AND THEN. WE'VE ALL
SWITCHED OVER TO A DIFFERENT
METHOD NOW BECAUSE WE KNOW
BETTER WE DO BETTER AND MOST
PHYSICIANS. ARE USING SOME KIND
OF ELECTRONIC MEDICAL RECORD I
THINK IT WOULD BE VERY RARE FOR
YOU TO GO INTO A DOCTOR'S OFFICE
AND HAVE SOMEBODY ACTUALLY.
WRITING DOWN AND YOU SEE YOUR
CHART RIGHT THERE ANYMORE I
THINK THE SAME THING ABOUT
IMMUNIZATION- YOU KNOW WE KNOW
THAT IT IS- BETTER FOR THE-
PATIENTS BETTER FOR THE PARENTS
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT LIKE WHERE
IS THAT YELLOW CARD I CAN'T
BELIEVE I WAS ASKED FOR A YELLOW
CARD WHEN I HAVE TO HAVE YOUR
CARD. I WAS CAN'T. BE ABLE TO
ONE PLACE IF YOU MOVE IF YOU
NEED TO VERIFY IT FOR YOUR
SCHOOL THAT YOUR CHILD HAS BEEN
IMMUNIZED YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
AND- HOBBIES OR FIND SOMETHING-
YOU KNOW A FEW YEARS AGO I WENT
TO SOUTH AFRICA ONCE I GOT THE-
YELLOW FEVER BACK. TO THE
LIFETIME THING I LOST MY YELLOW
CARD NEXT TIME I WAS GOING I HAD
TO GET IT AGAIN. SO. YOU BETTER
AND THIS IS A- OF DOING BETTER
BE WE KNOW THE- IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRIES HAVE WORKED AT THE
CONFIDENTIAL- AND- SO IF
SOMEONE. DOESN'T WANT THEIR
INFORMATION SHARED THEY DON'T
HAVE TO HAVE A CHAIRED. BUT THIS
IS JUST EXPANDING IT SO THAT
WHEN THAT NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS COMMS. WE HAVE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS POSSIBLE. WE'RE
DOING AS MUCH AS WE CAN FOR OUR
RESIDENTS TO MAKE THEIR LIVES
EASIER. AND SO THIS IS WHY IT
NEEDED TO BE EXPANDED. BUT
THERE'S NO SPECIFIC. DATA OR
ISSUE I WOULD. SO AT THIS WE
HAVE A LONG MEETING I DON'T
WANNA GO ON BUT I DO WANT TO
JUST. AT MY OWN BY CONCERN IS WE
ALSO HAVE AN IMPERFECT SYSTEM.
ANNA OUR IMPERFECT SYSTEM IS
FRAUGHT WITH VULNERABILITIES AND
WE'VE SEEN TIME AND TIME AGAIN
WITH INFORMATION BEING LEAKED
OUT UNFORTUNATELY WHEN IT WAS
UNINTENDED- SO I AM. I'M I'M
QUITE HONESTLY OF TWO MINDS AYE
AYE AYE THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT ME SUPPORTING UNIONIZATION
BUT SOMETIMES I FEEL LIKE WE
WORK AROUND THE EDGES TOO MUCH
ON ISSUE AREAS THAT WE MAY
RATHER WAIT TO SEE CHALLENGE
FIRST BROUGHT. RATHER THAN
SOMETHING TO CREATE A PERFECT
SYSTEM WHEN- AGAIN WHEN WE'RE
DEALING WITH A LOT OF
IMPERFECTIONS AND- THE WAY WE
HANDLE A LOT OF THINGS. AS WAS
EVIDENCED DURING THIS LAST
PANDEMIC- SO. WELL I THINK ONE
OF THE GOOD THINGS ABOUT THE
SYSTEM LIKE I SAID IT'S BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
AND SO HOW MANY- DATA BREACHES
HAVE. THE REGISTRY HAVE OVER THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS. ZERO OKAY.
IT'S AN EXCELLENT SYSTEM M. THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE STATE IS
INVESTED WELL IN THIS IN THIS
PROJECT FOR SURE I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS BACK AND GET
THEM ANSWERED BY- YOUR TECHNICAL
STAFF AT THE CDPH BECAUSE- THEY
HAVE. A WONDERFULLY TALENTED
TEAM THERE AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
WORKING HARD FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
AND YOU SHOULD ALL BE VERY PROUD
OF THEM. LET THE OPPOSITION A
QUESTION IF THAT'S OKAY MISTER
NAZARIAN. THANK YOU I JUST
WANTED TO ON TO GIVE MORE LIGHT
TO YOUR ON SITE AND THE MAJORITY
OF LARGE ORGANIZATIONS OR ALL OR
LARGE ORGANIZATIONS ARE KAISER
UCSF ALL OF THEM WILL GREENS IS
THE CARAMELIZATION TREE
CURRENTLY WHO DOESN'T USE IT A
MOSTLY INDEPENDENT OUR DOCTORS
BECAUSE IT DOES TAKE TRAINING IT
DOES TAKE EXTRA SOFTWARE- AND
TIME AND AN EFFORT- BUT THOSE
DOCTORS STILL KEEP ELECTRONIC
RECORDS. I THINK FOR US YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE KEY PIECES HERE IS
THE LOCKING OF THE DATA YOU CAN
LOCK IT BUT THE DATA STILL
REMAINS THERE AND SO OUR CONCERN
REALLY IS- THE FACT THAT ONCE
EVERY DOCTOR IS REQUIRED OR
HIM FOR IN THAT DATABASE IT
MEANS THAT THE IF YOU'RE
UNDOCUMENTED OR YOU DON'T WANT
YOUR INFO IN A GOVERNMENT
DATABASE IT'S GOING TO BE A
THERE. I THINK NUMBER. CHOOSE
THE WERE NOT IN SYSTEM THE WOULD
CHOOSE TO OPT IN OR NOT HAVE
THEIR INFORMATION PUT IN THERE
IS VERY SMALL BUT THE SCHOOLS
WOULD STILL FOR THOSE PARENTS
THAT YOU KNOW OUR ARE. WHAT YOUR
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID ONE THREE
MINUTE STATION RECORDS IN ONE
PLACE TO ACCESS THEM THE BE ABLE
TO DO THAT SIR YOU KNOW WE'RE
ALL ASKING FOR THE SMALL
POPULATION OF UNDOCUMENTED.
PEOPLE OVERHEAD IT WAS. IT WAS
WIDELY KNOWN WIDELY. ENCOURAGED
THAT UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA GOT VACCINATED THOSE
PEOPLE WILL HAVE THEIR
INFORMATION PUT INTO THAT
DATABASE AND THEY'RE REALLY
CONSENT AS WELL AS OTHER PEOPLE
WHO JUST WANT THEIR PRIVACY.
THANK YOU. JUST TO THAT POINT
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A PHYSICIAN
YOUR INFORMATION IS PUT INTO
SOME KIND OF COMPUTERIZED
DATABASE AT THIS WHETHER YOUR-
DOCUMENTED OR UNDOCUMENTED.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS. THE NONE- WE DON'T HAVE A
MOTION AFTER SOME OF. THE MOTION
NOW ARE DEAD MOTION AND THIS BY
MISTAKE OR CURRY SECOND BY MR
MAYES TO PASS TO EDUCATION- I
CLOSER TREVOR YES THANK YOU- SO
THIS BILL UPDATES ARE ALREADY
EXIST ALREADY EXISTING
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY I CANNOT.
EMPHASIZE THAT ENOUGH ALREADY
EXISTING. IT DOES NOT VIOLATE
HIPAA LAWS NOR DOES IT REMOVE A
PATIENT OR PARENTS RIGHT TO
DECLINE HAVING THEIR INFORMATION
LOCKED FROM BEING ACCESSED FROM
ANY OTHER OF THE USERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ALBUM
. VERY MUCH IS DOES ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON. WEBER
NO AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW RIO. LARA
MAIENSCHEIN. MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY. THIS AREA. RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO GARCIA. THREE
ONE IT'S THREE TO ONE WE'RE-
THIS IN ABOUT TEN MEMBERS SO
WE'LL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK. YOU
YOUR NEXT BILL AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
TWO. RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND ITS
STAFF FOR ALL ITS WORK AND I
WILL BE X. ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO
THE RESTROOM ACCESS ACT. SHE
WOULD HELP PROVIDED. WHO IS A
CLOSE. DISEASE OR ULCERATIVE
COLITIS IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO AN
EMPLOYEE RESTROOM IF THERE IS
NOT A PUBLIC RESTROOM READILY
AVAILABLE. THERE ARE OVER THREE
POINT ONE MILLION ADULTS LIVING
IN THE UNITED STATES WITH
CROHN'S DISEASE OR ULCERATIVE
COLITIS. THESE INDIVIDUALS OFTEN
SUFFER FROM DEBILITATING
DEBILITATING URGENCY TO USE THE
RESTROOM IMMEDIATELY OR RISK
HAVING AN EMBARRASSING ACCIDENT
. IT CONSTITUENT OF THE SEVENTY
NINTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT BROUGHT
THIS BILL PROPOSAL TO MY OFFICE
AT THE YEARLY DISTRICT
BRAINSTORMING EVENT. BUT THIS
BILL IDEA NEEDED FROM A TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE LAW PASSED IN
ILLINOIS STATE LEGISLATURE KNOWN
AS ALLEYS LAW. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR ALY BAIN WAS A YOUNG
WOMAN FROM ILLINOIS WHO HAS
INFLAMMATORY BOWEL DISEASE AND
WAS IN THE DEPARTMENT STORE WITH
HER MOTHER. ALLEN EXPERIENCED A
SUDDEN WHICH TO USE THE RESTROOM
AND WAS DENIED ACCESS TO THE
RESTROOM BY THE DIP STORE. THAT
THEN UNFORTUNATELY SALTED IN A
VERY EMBARRASSING ACCIDENT.
ALLIE TOOK ON THE INITIATIVE TO
ADVOCATE FOR HERSELF AND THOSE
WHO REMAIN SILENT WHILE
SUFFERING FROM THESE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS BECAUSE OF
EMBARRASSMENT. IF PASSED
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE THE
SIXTEENTH STATE TO PASS IT.
OTHER STATES INCLUDE NEW YORK
TENNESSEE TEXAS COLORADO AND
OTHERS. AB SIXTEEN THIRTY TO
ENSURE ACCESS TO A RESTROOM FOR
CUSTOMERS WHO PRESENT A
CERTIFIED CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH DOCUMENT SIGNED
BY A MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL
ATTESTING THAT INDIVIDUAL HAS AN
OSTOMY DEVICE HAD CROHN'S
DISEASE SORT OF COLITIS OR
ANOTHER FORM OF INFLAMMATORY
BOWEL DISEASE. OR MEDICAL
CONDITION REQUIRING ACCESS TO
TOILET FACILITIES IMMEDIATELY.
THE CROHN'S AND COLITIS
FOUNDATION SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
HERE TO SPEAK WITH ME TODAY AS
RYAN SPENCER SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE CROHN'S AND COLITIS
FOUNDATION FROM RGS CAN.
ADVOCACY RIGHT SPENT ON BEHALF
OF THE CRIMSON CLAD DISPENSATION
SUPPORTERS OF AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
TWO. CROHN'S DISEASE ULCER OF
COLITIS COLLECTIVELY KNOWN AS
INFLAMMATORY BOWEL DISEASE IBD
ARE PAINFUL MEDICALLY INCURABLE
DISEASES THAT AFFECT I JUST OF
SYSTEM RESULT IN SYMPTOMS THAT
INCLUDE LOSS OF. CONTROL AND
RECALL URGENT USE OF THE
RESTAURANT. THESE SYMPTOMS LEAVE
MANY IBD PATIENTS ABOUT WHETHER
THEY WILL ACCESS TO RESTROOM
WHEN A PUBLIC. HAPPENING THE
TIME. TELL THE STORY. IN AND
THAT WAS IN MY STATEMENT AS WELL
BUT I WILL TELL A LITTLE STORY
ABOUT HOW IS THAT IT CAN GO MORE
INTO DETAIL. SHE WAS OUT
SHOPPING WITH MOTHER DR WELL
SAID WHEN SHE PRESSED HIM SHE
SPOKE AND I'M AN EMPLOYEE THE
SAID THEY DIDN'T HAVE ONE. HE
SAID YOU PROCESS OR LATE WAY
WALK TWO BLOCKS AND THERE'S ONE
WE JUST COULDN'T USE THEIR
SPEED. RECORD SHOULDN'T TIME
THAT. PERSONALLY WITH. GO THE
STOCK- ILLUSTRATOR. SHE END UP
AN ACCIDENT THE STORE A THIRTY
YEAR OLD GIRL. SOME INCIDENT
WAS. NO THIS TOOK THIS IMPORTANT
EXPERIENCES SCALEXTRIC ILLINOIS.
YOU HEARD THE REST. TEXAS PASSED
A LAW OTHER STATES TO PASS A LAW
WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT CALIFORNIA
WILL FOLLOW SUIT. ALL WE WANT TO
DO IS ENSURE ONE WITH AN
ELIGIBLE MEDICAL EMERGENCY WITH
ACCESS TO RESTROOM IN NEED.
MAKERS YOUR SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. WHERE A
POSITION WITH. THERE ARE THE
THERE IS OKAY THESE. YOU'RE
WELCOME TO COME TO THE TABLE IF
YOU WISH. HI. THERE'S A BUTTON
THERE THE- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ARE ROBERT
WHICH WE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ERE POST AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY TWO PRESENTLY I WANT TO
BE CLEAR SUPPORT OF A GOAL THIS
BILL AND NOT OPPOSED TO IT WHEN
IS THE REST OF THE VORTEX. S.
AND- MANY OF THEM TAKEN. SEEING
THERE I WON ONLY HIGHLIGHT ONE
ISSUE IN THE RECENT AMENDS THAT
CREATED A PROBLEM FOR US WHICH
IS THE REASON THE MEN'S ACTUALLY
PROHIBIT US FROM DISCIPLINING
EMPLOYEES EXCLUDE SOMEONE IF WE
CREATE A POLICY WHICH SAYS
ISRAEL SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO USE
THE RESTROOMS AND- WITH. TEENAGE
WHAT SO. WOULD HAVE BRING THEM
INTO THE MEN'S MEETING THAT'S AN
ERROR TO FIX IN SORE HOPING END
THE OUR OFFICE SOON ABOUT AT
MOMENT WE ARE PER AB SIX THIRTY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU. NIELSEN
THE AUDIENCE- EITHER FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL THESE COMPORTED
A MICROPHONE. NUMBER BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM THE- EVER
SHRINKING CAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I'M SUPPORTING THE BILL
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE A
COMMON IN CASES OF MOVES FORWARD
IF IT I'M SURE THIS ISSUE HAS
COME UP AND IF YOU KNOW YOU'RE
MAKING AN OR AT SOME POINT- IN
MY BUSINESS I HAD A IT'S A
MANUFACTURING AND WE ALSO THE
FRONT OF THE BUSINESS WAS RETAIL
WITH PUBLIC COMING IN AND THEN
THE BACK WAS MANUFACTURING WHICH
BECAUSE OF INSURANCE RECALL THIS
WAS CLOSED OFF. AND I KNOW I
HAVEN'T BEEN PREGNANT EVERYTHING
WHEN YOU HAVE TO GO YOU HAVE TO
CALL HOME. YOU KNOW NOT BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS THE RESTROOM. WAS
IS AN- SO. DO AS A BUSINESS AND
ANYONE WHO GOES IN THE BACK IN
THE MANUFACTURING AREA YOU KNOW
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF ISSUES WITH
TRIP AND FALL OVER QUOTE MEN
ARE. YOU KNOW THINGS LIKE THAT
SO I JUST WANTED TO BRING THAT
UP. CASE THAT COMES UP. AND I'M
SURE THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS
TALKING ABOUT IT. THAT THERE'S
SOME KIND OF LIABILITY. SECTION
SOME WAY AND AS PART OF IT THANK
. THANK YOUNG ADULTS AND THE
AMENDMENTS WE DO COVER LIABILITY
PROTECTION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS. MOTION BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SECOND MISS WALDRON
THANK YOU- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I'M SO I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE I THANK THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN ALSO THANK- THE OPPOSITION
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK AFTER THIS LATEST ROUND OF
AMENDMENTS THAT CONSTANT ISSUES.
I'M BUT IT IS LONG OVERDUE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN OUR SISTER
STATES IN PROVIDING ACCESS TO
THOSE WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE RISK OF HAVING
AN EMBARRASSING ACCIDENT WHILE
THEY'RE OUT. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MESS- MOTION BY MISTAKE YOU'RE
CURIOUS SECOND BY MISS WALDRON
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW CARILLO LARA.
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY THIS
AREA RIVAS RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO
GARCIA. IT IS ZERO THREE ZERO
WHERE- YEAH OUR OUR OUR GROUP IS
SHRINKING AS WE SPEAK HERE SO-
BUT- PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
YOUR NEXT BILL AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR. HEY I AM HERE TO
PRESENT MY LAST BILL BEFORE YOU
ARE TODAY. AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR CALIFORNIA ABORTION AND
REPRODUCTIVE EQUITY ACT ALSO
KNOWN AS THE CARE ACT. THIS BILL
ENSURES ABORTION AND
CONTRACEPTIVE SERVICES ARE
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
PATIENTS AND TO PROVIDE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS FOR THESE SERVICES.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND I
DEFINITELY ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
. CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN A
LEADER IN PROTECTING AN
INDIVIDUAL'S RIGHT TO ACCESS
ABORTION AND WHILE THESE EFFORTS
HAVE HELPED TO MAINTAIN THIS
RIGHT FOR DECADES THERE ARE
STILL NUMEROUS REMAINING
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING CARE
INCLUDING COST. TO ADDRESS THESE
BARRIERS REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA OFFER
UNCOMPENSATED CARE THE PATIENTS
WHO ARE UNABLE TO AFFORD THIS
COST OF SERVICES. PATIENTS MAY
BE IN THIS SITUATION BECAUSE OF
INCOME AND PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS OR BECAUSE THEY
LACK COVERAGE FOR ABORTION AND
ABORTION RELATED REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE INCLUDING THOSE WHO
ARE UNINSURED OR UNDERINSURED
DUE TO GAPS IN THEIR PERSONAL
COVERAGE DUE TO RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTION OR SELF INSURED
EMPLOYEE. INSURANCE REGULATED BY
FEDERAL LAW. IN ADDITION TO THE
COST BARRIER THIS YEAR THERE
HAVE BEEN OVER FIVE HUNDRED
ABORTION RESTRICTIONS PROPOSED
IN OVER FORTY STATES. AND SIX
STATES HAVE ALREADY ENACTED
ABORTION BANS. THIS IS FORCING
PEOPLE TO TRAVEL FROM THEIR HOME
STATE FOR AN ABORTION.
CALIFORNIANS PROVIDERS ARE
ALREADY SERVING PATIENTS FROM
THE STATE'S AND EXPECT TO SEE UP
TO ONE POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE
TRAVELING TO CALIFORNIA FOR
CARE. AS ADDITIONAL STATES AN
ACTOR HOSPITAL LAWS AND THE
SUPREME COURT RULED IN A CASE
THAT WILL LIKELY OVERTURN ROE
VERSUS WADE. AS A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE WE MUST URGENTLY
ADDRESS AND SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
THE PROVIDERS WHO OFFER THIS
CARE TO ENSURE THEY CAN CONTINUE
TO SERVE PATIENTS WHO ARE
RELYING ON THEM FOR THIS VERY
CRITICAL SERVICE. AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR ESTABLISHES THE
REPRODUCTIVE CALIFORNIA
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EQUITY
PROGRAM WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION. TO PROVIDE GRANT
FUNDING TO CALIFORNIANS SAFETY
NET PROVIDERS OF ABORTION AND
COUNTRY TO SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO CREATE NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR SELF INSURED
EMPLOYERS WHO DO NOT PROVIDE
ABORTION AND CONTRACEPTION TO
NOTIFY THEIR EMPLOYEES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS OF WHAT BENEFITS ARE
NOT COVERED AND THAT THEY CAN
ACCESS THESE BENEFITS THROUGH
THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EQUITY
PROGRAM. AMENDMENTS ALSO ENSURE
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT INFRINGE
UPON THE RIGHTS OF EXEMPTED
RELIGIOUS AFFILIATED EMPLOYERS.
WITH ME TODAY. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR IS MOLLY ROBSON LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA. AND
STACY WHAT A ROCK FOR OFF
ASSOCIATE GENERAL COUNSEL AT THE
PACK IS ALSO HERE FOR ANY.
QUESTIONS WE- HAVE. THE
CALIFORNIA SORRY IT'S BEEN
AWHILE SINCE I'VE BEEN UP HERE
I'M PEAPACK REPRESENTS THE SEVEN
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
THE STATE WHO OPERATE OVER A
HUNDRED HEALTH CENTERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. ALONGSIDE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND JUSTICE
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA FROM
THE FUTURE OF ABORTION COUNSEL
IN THE FALL OF LAST YEAR TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO ABORTION AND
DECREASE BARRIERS TO CARE. AND
WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES TO REDUCE COST BARRIERS
TO ABORTION THEY'RE STILL
INDIVIDUALS UNABLE TO AFFORD THE
COST OF SERVICE. ABORTION AS YOU
KNOW IS A TIME SENSITIVE AN
ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE SERVICE
AND BARRIERS TO ABORTION CAN
CAUSE PEOPLE TO BE FORCED TO
CARRY AN UNWANTED PREGNANCY OR
PUSHED INTO A LEADER JUST
STATION CREATING. MORE BARRIERS.
TO ADDRESS THESE BARRIERS A
SAFETY NET PROVIDERS LIKE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD OFFER
UNCOMPENSATED CARE TO PATIENTS
WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY. ON
AVERAGE PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
OFFERED ABOUT MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF UNCOMPENSATED CARE
ANNUALLY TO PATIENTS. IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT WHEN ROSE
OVERTURNED WHICH IS LIKELY TO
HAPPEN BY JUNE OF THIS YEAR ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE FIND
THE CLOSEST. WRITER IN
CALIFORNIA. AS WE PREPARE TO SEE
THESE PATIENTS SEEKING ABORTION
SERVICES AND OTHER REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE IN OUR STATE. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT- OR IT IS SORRY WE
EXPECT TO SEE MORE PATIENTS
UNABLE TO AFFORD THE COST OF
SERVICES AS THEIR INELIGIBLE FOR
STATE PROGRAMS. AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR WILL CREATE A GRANT
PROGRAM FOR ABORTION PROVIDERS
WHO OFFER UNCOMPENSATED CARE TO
PATIENTS. ENSURING THAT
PROVIDERS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD CAN CONTINUE TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITIES AND
PROVIDE CARE TO ANYONE WHO WALKS
IN THE CENTER DOOR. IN FRONT OF
YOU YOU HAVE RECEIVED WRITTEN
TESTIMONY FROM DR JANET JACOBSON
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR FROM
PLANNED PARENTHOOD ORANGE AND
SAN BERNARDINO COUNTIES. I'D
LIKE TO READ JUST A PIECE OF HER
TESTIMONY FOR YOU. RECENTLY I
PROVIDED CARE FOR TWO PATIENTS
ONE FROM BARSTOW CALIFORNIA AND
ONE FROM DALLAS TEXAS. THE
VISION FROM BARSTOW TRAVELED ON
A BUS WITH HER KIDS TO OUR
CLINIC AND SAMPOERNA DINO FOR
CARE. SHE COULD NOT GET AN
APPOINTMENT FOR THE CARE SHE
NEEDED IN BARSTOW AND HOW TO
TAKE A DAY OFF OF WORK.
ADDITIONALLY SHE CANNOT AFFORD
CHILD CARE AND DID NOT QUALIFY
FOR. MEDICAL PROGRAM. THE OTHER
PATIENT WHO TRAVEL TO GET CARE
FROM TEXAS LEFT HER KIDS WITH
HER SISTER IN DALLAS. AND FLEW
TO CALIFORNIA WITH NO CLOTHES NO
FOOD AND NO MONEY. WHAT THAT
TEXAS PATIENT DID HAVE WAS AN
APPOINTMENT AT P. P. O. S. B. C.
WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE HER CARE
AND A SISTER WITH ARRANGING
TRANSPORTATION. MEALS AND
ACCOMMODATIONS. BOTH THESE
PATIENTS WERE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THE CARE THEY NEEDED EVEN THOUGH
THEY COULD NOT PAY. PLANNED
PARENTHOOD'S MOD. IS CARE NO
MATTER. AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR INSURERS PROVIDERS. CAN
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT PATIENTS
EQUITABLY. REGARDLESS OF THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY. FOR THESE-REASONS WERE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY. THANK YOU- I'M
JUST HERE FOR QUESTIONS RIGHT
NOW HAS SOMETHING BUT I THOUGHT
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
MY NAME IS KATHLEEN JONES FOR
THE LAST FOUR YEARS I'VE BEEN
THE CEO FOR MOUNTAIN RIGHT TO
LIFE PREGNANCY CENTER A
RELIGIOUS NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA
CORPORATION. THAT I WAS A GLOBAL
EMPLOYEE MANAGER. OR TRUCKING
AND LOGISTICS COMPANY BASED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WITH OFFICES
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND
SOUTH AMERICA. AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR CREATES A
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH EQUITY FUND
WITH MONEY FROM TAXPAYERS AND
PRIVATE DONORS. MY COMPANIES
FOCUS IS SERVING UNDERSERVED
WOMEN AND FAMILIES BUT WE NEED
NOT APPLY FOR GRANT BECAUSE WE
CHOOSE TO OFFER. ENDS WE'LL GO
TO THE WASHROOM PROVIDERS ONLY
LIKE PLANNED PARENTHOOD. AS AN
EMPLOYER I'M ALREADY FORCED TO
PAY FOR STATE FUNDED ABORTION
INDIRECTLY THROUGH BUSINESS
TAXES. THIS BILL BILL DOES
VIOLATE MY RELIGIOUS BELIEFS I
HAVE A PRIVATE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
WHAT INSURANCE BENEFITS WILL
PROVIDE TO MY EMPLOYEES. AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR IGNORE
SAID I. THE SUPREME COURT IS
ALREADY TOLD CALIFORNIA THAT
CANNOT FORCE OR FORCE ME TO TELL
EMPLOYEES ABOUT OPTIONS THAT AYE
OPPOSE BECAUSE TO DO SO VIOLATES
MY FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS AS AN
EMPLOYER. THAT CASE WAS NOT FOR
THE SERRA. SO NOW IN THE END RUN
AROUND THE SUPREME COURT'S AND
TRAMPLING OVER MY RIGHTS AS A
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYER. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR. OTHER COMPANIES
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO TELL MY
EMPLOYEES NOTHING. SOMETHING I
WON'T PAY FOR THAT INTERFERES
WITH THE EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE
RELATIONSHIP. THIS SAID ABOUT
FUNDING ABORTION THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. DON'T FORCE
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO TALK
ABOUT GETTING COVERAGE FOR OTHER
HEALTH RISKS LIKE DIABETES OR
HEART DISEASE WEIGHT LOSS HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE WELL WOMAN CARE
CHILDBIRTH SO HIS WHO IS PUSHING
ABORTION. BY TARGETING RELIGIOUS
EMPLOYERS LIKE MYSELF AND
COMPELLING PROFESSIONAL SPEECH
THAT GOES AGAINST MY RELIGIOUS
TENETS CONCERNING ABORTION AND
CONTRACEPTION AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR VIOLATES MY
RELIGIOUS LIBERTIES PROTECTED BY
THE FREE EXERCISE CLAUSE OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR IS DISCRIMINATORY
AND PUSHES A RADICAL ABORTION
AGENDA IT INTERFERES WITH
EMPLOYERS RIGHTS AND VIOLATES
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND SHOULD
BE REJECTED BY THIS COMMITTEE.
FOR THOSE REASONS I'M ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE ON AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR. NEXT WITNESS WITH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR WOULD AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE I NAME IS KATHLEEN
DOMINGO I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC
CONFERENCE. THE CATHOLIC CHURCH
IS THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF
PRIVATE NONPROFIT SOCIAL
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA IN OUR
NATION AND THE WORLD EVERY DAY
CATHOLIC MEN AND WOMEN PRIESTS
AND SISTERS SERVE THE POOREST OF
THE POOR IN EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD
IN CALIFORNIA. WE PROVIDE
HOUSING TO THOSE WHO LIVE ON THE
STREETS THOSE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS AND THOSE WHO SUFFER
FROM ADDICTION WE WELCOME
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES WITHOUT
QUESTION PROVIDE HOUSING LEGAL
SERVICES JOB PLACEMENT AND CASE
MANAGEMENT. WE PROVIDE MEDICAL
CARE AND SOCIAL SERVICES TO
THOSE IN OUTLYING AREAS AND IN
INNER CITIES. WE WALK WITH WOMEN
AND CHILDREN AND FAMILIES. FIVE
IN THE STATE. PORTABLE HOUSING
IS OUT OF REACH FOR SO MANY. I
AM HERE TODAY TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR. CONTRARY
TO THE AUTHOR'S ASSURANCES THIS
BILL DOES NOT PROTECT RELIGIOUS
EMPLOYERS PRACTICING MINISTRY TO
ALL PEOPLE. THE AUTHORS AND
SUPPORTERS OF THIS BILL KNOW
THAT IF THE EFFECT THAT IT WILL
HAVE ON THE MINISTRY'S OF THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH. FOR TWO
THOUSAND YEARS CHRISTIANS HAVE
PRACTICED OUR FAITH BY SERVING
THOSE IN NEED. OUR FAITH IS NOT
CONFINED TO THE INSIDE OF OUR
CHURCHES. OUR MINISTRY SERVE
ANYONE AND EVERYONE WHO IS IN
NEED. THIS TOPIC OF ASSIGNING
DEFINITIONS TO RELIGIOUS
EMPLOYERS HAS BEEN LITIGATED
AGAIN AND AGAIN ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. IF PASSED AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR WOULD FORCE OUR
MINISTRIES TO CLOSE. INSTEAD OF
SERVING THE POOR AND HOUSING THE
HOMELESS AND CARING FOR THE
ELDERLY HE WOULD RATHER. DOORS
FOR THE LAST FIFTY YEARS
ABORTION HAS BEEN THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL TOPIC IN AMERICAN
POLITICAL LIFE. CREATING REFS IN
POLITICAL PARTIES COMPANIES AND
FAMILIES. HOLDING SHOWS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS DO NOT
WANT THEIR TAX DOLLARS USED FOR
ABORTIONS. AND AMERICANS ARE
DIVIDED FIFTY FIFTY ON
ABORTION'S LEGALITY. AB TWENTY
ONE THIRTY FOUR DOES NOT PROVIDE
TRUE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE WHEN
OUR COMMUNITY ORGANIZER IS GO
INTO THE HOMES OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS.
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITIES
FAMILIES AND POVERTY BE FAMILY
SAY. WE CANNOT SURVIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. THEY SAY WE'RE
PUTTING OFF HAVING CHILDREN FOR
NOT HAVING THE CHILDREN THAT WE
WANT. TO HAVE BEEN AND WE'RE
NOT. GETTING FOR WOMEN WHO
CHOOSE TO GIVE BIRTH. WHICH IS
THE PARENT WHO NEED THE TO
AFFORD THE COST THE PRENATAL
CARE UNTIL AS A MIDWIFE. ALL OF
THAT COMES OUT OF. NO SIMPLE.
PAY FOR BIRTH AS THERE IS
ABORTION. NOT ONLY WOULD AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR CHANNEL
TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO ABORTION BUT
NOT HELP WOMEN WHO WISH TO
BECOME PARENTS IT WOULD ALSO
CLOSE THE LARGEST PROVIDER OF
SERVICES TO WOMEN CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
WOULD WOMEN IN FAMILIES TURN IF
THEY WANTED TO HAVE CHILDREN AND
GROW THEIR FAMILIES. ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA WOMEN AND FAMILIES
AND EMPLOYERS OF FAITH I URGE A
NO VOTE TODAY ON AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE ARE OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. JUST YOUR NAME-
POSITION ON THE BILL AND
ORGANIZATIONS YOU REPRESENT ONE
PLEASE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RECTANGLE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. IT'S A
BELL ARE QUITE ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA HAS
A PROUD CO SPONSOR IN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. DR DANIEL
GROSSMAN ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS
IN REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH UCSF IN
SUPPORT. BRENT SPENCER BEHALF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
DISTRICT NINE STRONG SUPPORT IF. MY NAME IS ELIZABETH RANGEL
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU
. I'M COUNTY CORNELL AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU-
ALICE PETROVICH AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL IF. KATHY MUST PERCENT
TO ACCESS HEALTH PRODUCE BONSER
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THERESA
BRENNAN PRESIDENT OF THE RIGHT
TO LIFE LEAGUE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION YOUR- GREG BIRD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION YOUR- BRANDON
CAMPBELL PASTOR THE FAITH OF THE
CHURCH IN WHEATLAND AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR OF THE
CAPITOL CONNECTION FOR BAPTIST
CHURCHES WERE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. IF ANYONE ELSE. YOU
KNOW BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OR-
RUSSIAN. I'LL SECOND THE MOTION
MOTION WOULD BE ODD TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. BUT
WEBER WHICH ARTICLES YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO JUST
REITERATE THAT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS I'M ENSURE THAT IT
WOULD NOT INFRINGE UPON THE
RIGHTS OF EXEMPTED RELIGIOUS
AFFILIATED EMPLOYERS AND IT IS
NOT I'M GOING TO BE CLOSING ANY
CLINICS OR HOSPITALS. CALIFORNIA
HAS LONG RISEN TO THE OCCASION
AND OFTEN LEAD THE WAY TO FIGHT
FOR HEALTH EQUITY. IT SHOULD BE
NO DIFFERENT WHEN IT COMES TO
ABORTION AND THE SAFETY NET
PROVIDER TO PERFORM THE
SERVICES. THE CARE ACT CONTINUES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO BEING
A REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE.
INTERNATIONAL LEADER IN
SAFEGUARDING AND ADVANCING
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR
WEBER OF MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE%
CALL THE ROLL WHAT I. AND
WALDRON YOUR CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
I ARAMBULA. BIGELOW CARILLO
LARA. MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. RODRIGUEZ RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO GARCIA. THE
ONE TWO TO ONE WILL BE THE BILL
A CALL JUST TO CLARIFY THAT BILL
WITH THAT THAT BUSH WAS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO PREPARATIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THE SECULAR KERR.
OKAY WE'RE DOING ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN A. B. TWO FIVE ONE SIX
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR KERRY.
JUST GIVE ME A SECOND WE'RE
GETTING OUR- OF THE I GUESS IS A
LONG LINE OUT THERE MAYBE.
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES FIRST
MY THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALL THEIR HARD WORK. AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTEEN WOULD REQUIRE ALL
HEALTH PLANS TO COVER HPV
VACCINE WITHOUT ANY COST SHARING
. REGARDLESS OF INSURANCE OR
STATUS ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD
MAKE HPV VACCINE A COVERED
BENEFIT IN THE FAMILY PLANNING
ACCESS CARE AND TREATMENT AND
TREATMENT KNOWN AS FAMILY
PACKED. MEDI CAL PROGRAM. HPV IS
THE MOST COMMON SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTION IN THE
UNITED STATES. THERE ARE
MULTIPLE TYPES OF HPV THAT CAN
LEAD TO DIFFERENT HEALTH
PROBLEMS THE MOST SEVERE WHICH
ARE CERVICAL AND OTHER TYPES OF
CANCERS. ACCORDING THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION MORE THAN THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND NEW CANCER DIAGNOSIS
EACH YEAR CAN BE ATTRIBUTED TO
R. E. V. INFECTION. IF KERN HP
VACCINATION RECOMMENDATIONS WERE
FOLLOWED THE CDC ESTIMATES
AROUND THIRTY THREE THOUSAND OF
THESE CANCERS COULD BE AVOIDED.
AND WHILE MOST HEALTH INSURERS
OFFER COVERAGE FOR THE HPV
VACCINE AS A PRO PREVENTATIVE
SERVICE UNDER THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT. SOME REQUIRE PATIENTS
TO COVER SOME OR PART OF THE
COST WHICH CAN BE UP TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS PER
DOSE. ADDITIONALLY NOT ALL
CALIFORNIANS WHO QUALIFY FOR
FAMILY PACK WILL BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN FULL SCOPE INSURANCE.
ONLY PACKED IT DOES NOT
CURRENTLY COVERED ANY VACCINES
SO MAKING THE HPV VACCINE A
COVERED BENEFIT WILL MAKE IT
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO THOSE WHO
WISH TO BE VACCINATED WELL
THEY'RE ALREADY IN THE PROVIDER
LOCATION. FOR OTHER HEALTH
SERVICES AVOIDING THE DELAYS TO
THIS CRITICAL PREVENTABLE CARE.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY TODAY'S
DR SARAH KENNEDY CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER. MEDICAL OFFICE. HELLO
AND LEGISLATIVE CAN MEMBER OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICIANS AND GYNECOLOGISTS. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU AND
FOR HEARING THIS TESTIMONY I AM
VERY GRATEFUL TO BE HERE MY NAME
IS DR SARAH KENNEDY I'M AN
OBSTETRICIAN AND GYNECOLOGIST-
ON AS LISTED ON THE C. O. O. CMO
OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I WHICH REPRESENTS
SEVENTEEN HEALTH CENTERS
THROUGHOUT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
RANGING FROM URBAN SAN FRANCISCO
AND SUBURBAN BAY AREA AND UP TO
THE OREGON BORDER SEVERE PEARL
CENTERS. AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT
AS AN OBSTETRICIAN AND
GYNECOLOGIST A CERVICAL CANCER
IS ONE OF THE MOST DEVASTATING
DISEASES THAT I CARE FOR IT IS A
HORRIFIC DISEASE- LARGELY
TARGETING REPRODUCTIVE FEMALE
BODIED PATIENTS ON LEADING
USUALLY TO VERY PAINFUL DEATH.
ON THIS HORRIBLE DISEASE IS
ACTUALLY ENTIRELY PREVENTABLE BY
THE HPV VACCINE WHICH HAS BEEN.
IF AN EFFECT AND MANY COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF THEIR HIGH VACCINE
UPTAKE HPV VACCINE UPTAKE ARE
ACTUALLY NEARING EXTINCTION OF
CERVICAL CANCER IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE SO AUSTRALIA WILL HAVE
NO CERVICAL CANCER CASES BY
TWENTY TWENTY EACH BECAUSE OF
THE HPV VACCINE. I THE ISSUE WE
FACE TODAY IS ONE OF HEALTH
EQUITY SO WILD WHITER RICHER
INSURED PATIENTS HAVE READY
ACCESS TO HPV VACCINE. FAMILY
PACKED PATIENTS DO NOT. AN
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD PATIENTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE COVERED
BY FAMILY POTS AND THESE
PATIENTS DO NOT HAVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO THE HPV VACCINE. THIS
MEANS THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR LOW
INCOME PATIENTS PATIENTS
STRUGGLING TO OBTAIN HEALTH CARE
ACCESS DISPROPORTIONATELY. AND
EXPERIENCE EXPERIENCIA. OF
CERVICAL CANCER- ORAL PHARYNGEAL
CANCER AND GENITAL WARTS ALL
OUTCOMES OF HPV. SO I'M HERE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT- OF THE HPV
VACCINE COVERAGE BY FAMILY PATHS
AND ACROSS ALL INSURERS- AS THIS
IS BOTH A HEALTH EQUITY ISSUE
AND AN ISSUE THAT WE ALL FACE
AND THAT WE WOULD WANT OUR
SISTERS OUR MOTHERS OUR
DAUGHTERS ARE AND- TO BE ABLE TO
PREVENT. THIS TERRIBLE DISEASE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEE NO ONE WILL
BRING IT BACK I WAS ACTUALLY
WITNESSES IN ANYBODY IN THE
CHAMBER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
SORRY. HEAD OF MYSELF THERE.
JUST YOUR NAME POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
WANT MY ROPES AND PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA WERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. RIGHT SPENCER BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN IS
JUST AT NINE IN SPORT THANK YOU
. KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT IF. CERAKOTE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. KATHY MUST PERCENT TO
ACCESS HELP AND SUPPORT GIVE.
THIRD ANNIVERSARY IN ADVANCING
STANDARDS REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU KNOW
WHAT ELSE TO BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE MOTION. THE
QUESTION BECOMES. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY- IS CARILLO SECOND BY
MISS WALDRON MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS AND SET UP. THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE BECAUSE SIMPLY JUST WHAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
YOU KNOW I'M ONE OF THE THINGS
WHEN YOU'VE HAD A LOVED ONE
PASSED AWAY FROM CERVICAL CANCER
THE COULD HAVE BEEN PREVENTED.
I'M HERE IN REPRESENTATION OF MY
COUSIN SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. A
VERY MUCH A FIGURE CURRY- BILL
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA BIGELOW CARILLO. RIO
AYE FLORA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES.
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO GARCIA. OR ZERO FOUR
ZERO WILL BE THE BILL ON CALL
ANOTHER BILL I SHOULD DO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF.
OKAY. MISTER CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES
FIRST AND FOREMOST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR ALLYOUR
HARD WORK ON THE ANALYSIS. AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN INSURERS
THAT COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS.
AND PROMO TORAS AND CONTINUE IN
THEIR SPECIAL ROLES BY
SUPPORTING THEM WITH THE PROPER
TOOLS AND RESOURCES THROUGH
STATE REIMBURSEMENTS. C. H. W.'S
AND PROMONTORIES ARE TRUSTED
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND HELP
ADDRESS MONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS
PREVENTED OF HEALTH CARE NEEDS
AND HEALTH RELATED SOCIAL NEEDS.
FROM A TAURUS YOU USUALLY LIVE
IN THE COMMUNITY THEY SERVE THEY
SHARE THE NEIGHBORS OF THIS THIS
TO THE LANGUAGE SOCIAL NOT
ECONOMIC STATUS AND LIFE
EXPERIENCES. BECAUSE OF THAT
THEY HAVE THE UNIQUE ABILITY TO
BRING INFORMATION WHERE IT IS
MOST NEEDED SPECIFICALLY TO
WHERE PATIENTS LIVE. EAT PLAY
WORK AND WORSHIP. THIS YEAR THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PLANTS TO MAKE SEA HW'S
AND PROMONTORIES A COVERED
BENEFIT FOR ALL SIXTEEN MILLION
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES AND THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING A THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION THE FUND
THIS EFFORT. THIS IS WHY AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE
IS ABLE TO REVIEW THE SUCCESS OF
C. H. W.'S IN THE PROPER
TORRANCE. WHILE IN A ADVOCATES
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THEY CAN
SUPPORT THE ONGOING NEEDS A
MEDIC CAL ENROLLEES. LOCAL
WORKFORCE THESE DH CS IMPLEMENTS
THE NEW BENEFIT. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS ANDREA RIVERA
SENIOR LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS
AND TAYLOR REFERENCE. PROGRAM
COORDINATOR WITH THE HEALTH
EDUCATION COUNCIL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY%
NAME IS ANDREA RIVERA AND I'M
THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK THE PLAN IS A
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY SEVEN. CALIFORNIANS
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK
WITH COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS OR
PROMOTE PRODUCTS AND ENSURE THE
LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY OF THE
C. H. W. WORKFORCE. AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY SEVEN IS FOCUSED ON
THREE KEY GOALS. ONE CODIFY
ASPECTS OF THE MEDICAL CHW
BENEFIT TO ROUTE THAT RELATE TO
WORK FOR SUSTAINABILITY. TO
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH PLANS THAT ARE
DEVELOPED BY MEDI CAL. CARE PUT
THAT WILL INFORM FISHERIES OF
THIS NEW SERVICE THAT THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO RECEIVE. AND WE BUILD
AN ANNUAL ASSESSMENTS OF THIS
BENEFIT FOR THE PURPOSE OF
MONITORING OUTCOMES AND TO
ESTABLISH THE FOUNDATION FOR
FUTURE POSSIBLE IMPROVEMENTS.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST YEAR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES HAS BEEN CONVENING
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE TO CAREFULLY DEVELOPED THE
STATE PLAN AMENDMENT THAT MUST
BE SUBMITTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THE SPOT CONTAINS
THE GUIDELINES AND PARAMETERS OF
THE DEPARTMENT AND MEDICAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS MUST USE WHEN
PROVIDING C. H. W. SERVICES
STARTING JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO. AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
SEVEN. OF THE SPA THIS FAR. WITH
REGARDS TO TERMS ON ELIGIBILITY
THE SCOPE OF SERVICES THAT C. H.
W.'S CAN PROVIDE AND MINIMUM
QUALIFICATIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO ENTER THIS CRITICAL WORKFORCE
. THE H. W. HAVE LONG BEEN A
COMMUNITY STRONGHOLDS AND EQUITY
STRATEGY AND REDUCING RACIAL
DISPARITIES HOWEVER THEY HAVE
NOT ALWAYS BEEN RECOGNIZED FOR
THEIR CENTRAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO
THE HEALTH CARE WORK FORCE. THAT
IS ONLY UNTIL RELATIVELY
RECENTLY WITH EFFORTS LIKE AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN AND THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO HIRE AND
RECRUIT NEARLY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND C. H. W. THE CROSS THE
STREET. THAT THESE WORKERS ARE
FINALLY BEING RECOGNIZED FOR
THEIR INVALUABLE ABILITY TO WORK
WITH COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN WOULD
ALSO ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS THE ABILITY TO REVIEW AND
APPROVE. PROPOSED EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH. THAT ARE TO BE
DEVELOPED BY MEDICARE MANAGED
CARE PLANS CREATING ACCESS IS
ONE STEP BUT IN ORDER FOR THE
STATE TO SEE SUCCESSFULOUTCOMES
THEN THE UTILIZATION OF
SERVICES. THERE MUST BE TARGETED
CULTURALLY AND LINGUISTICALLY
RELEVANT OUTREACH GOALS TO
INCREASE PUBLIC AWARENESS.
LASTLY AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
SEVEN WILL REQUIRE MANAGED CARE
PLANS TO ANNUALLY ASSESS CHW
OUTCOMES ENSURE THOSE
ASSESSMENTS WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
I TRACKING OUTCOMES THE
DEPARTMENT THE LEGISLATURE
CONSUMER ADVOCATES AND COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS CAN MONITOR
IMPLEMENT IMPLEMENTATION TO
ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING SERVED WE URGE AND I BOTH
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON AB TWENTY
SIX NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
IT CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M TAYLOR WITH THE
SACRAMENTO HEALTH EDUCATION
COUNCIL ON THE LOWER LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
. COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS. OR
AS THEY'RE KNOWN IN SPANISH
BERMAN THOUGHT US ARE AN
IMPORTANT CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY DIVERSE WORK
FORCE THAT COMPLEMENTS OUR
STATE'S MEDICAL AND HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS. WE HOPE TO DELIVER
QUALITY INAPPROPRIATE CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE COMMUNITIES
. AS A PROMOTER WE CAN HELP
REACH PEOPLE WHO OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO CARE IN
INFORMATION IN THEIR LANGUAGE. I
PROVIDE SERVICES SIX TIMES A
MONTH IN THE MEXICAN CONSULATE
OF SACRAMENTO. TWO WEEKS AGO I
MET LIZ A MONOLINGUAL SPANISH
SPEAKER WHO ORIGINALLY CAME IN
TO GET HER TAXES FILED. THERE
WERE NO NO SPANISH LANGUAGE
INTERPRETERS THAT DAY AND AS I
INTERACTED WITH HER SHE SAW THAT
I WAS THERE IS A COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKER. IT IS REVEALED TO
ME THAT SHE WAS CURRENTLY
UNINSURED. SHE WAS EXPERIENCING
SOME STRESS ON HOME DUE TO LACK
OF SOCIAL SUPPORT AND
OCCUPATIONAL INSTABILITY. AND
WAS ALSO LOOKING FOR LEGAL
ADVICE. BEFORE SHE LEFT THAT DAY
I REFERRED HER TO A LOW COST
CLINIC SO SHE COULD RECEIVE CARE
IN THE MEANTIME. AND I
INTRODUCED HER TO MY COWORKER
WHO ARE PROVIDES MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELLING. AND GAVE HER SOME
OTHER RESOURCES AND ABOUT THE
COURSE OF IN OUR LIVES HARD HER
TAXES FILED. SHE KNEW WHERE SHE
COULD GO FOR HER NEXT PRIMARY
CARE VISIT. SHE FOUND A TRUSTED
IMMIGRATION LAWYER OUT NO COST
TO HER. AND SHE RECEIVED THE
BENEFIT OF MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
AND SOCIAL CONNECTION. UNITY
HEALTH WORKERS SERVE AN
ESSENTIAL FUNCTION OF HEALTH
CARE OUTSIDE OF THE TRADITIONAL
IMPATIENT SIDING. THERE BEEN
MANY TIMES WHEN WORKING ON A
MOBILE WORLD BOXING CLINIC WHERE
MOST PARTICIPANTS ARE SPANISH
SPEAKING THE I AM THE ONLY STAFF
ON THE FLOOR HELPING CLIENTS.
I'M PRESENT ALL POINTS OF
INTERACTION FROM HELPING
REGISTER FILLING OUT PAPERWORK.
I AM TRANSLATING MEDICAL HISTORY
QUESTIONS. IN CARE
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THEIR STAFF
AS WELL AS CONDUCTING PATIENT
EXPERIENCE SURVEYS. PROMISED
VOTERS ARE THE BEST ADVOCATES
FOR MANY OF OUR STATES PATIENCE
WE ADDRESS ATTITUDES FEELINGS
AND BEHAVIORS AROUND HEALTH TO
HATE TO HELP THE INDIVIDUAL
IDENTIFY THEIR PROBLEMS AND
RECOGNIZE WHAT BARRIERS KEEP
THEM FROM LIVING A HEALTHFUL
LIFE IS POSSIBLE. BECAUSE WE
REPRESENT A SIMILAR CULTURE TO
THE COMMUNITY WE LIVE IN AND WE
HAVE LIVED IN EXPERIENCE OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE DISCUSSED AROUND
HEALTH. UNITY HOLD WORKERS GO
BEYOND OVERCOMING COMMUNICATION
BARRIERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION AND I HOPE YOU
CAN SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIX NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. IN WILL GO TO OF
PEOPLE IN THE IN THE HEARING
ROOM JUST YOUR NAME POSITION OR
AN ORGANIZATION TO REPRESENT
ONE. KATIE ANDREW CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINDA WAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALISON RAINY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LUCY
QUINTANILLA ON BEHALF OF
MATERNAL AND CHILD HEALTH ACCESS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. PAUL
SIMONS WITH THE DEPRESSION AND
BIPOLAR SUPPORT ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. SOME OF THEM WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AMR SHE'D WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
THANK YOU I THINK YOU. KATHY
MUST PER PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
IN SUPPORT GIVE. AB WHO ARE
PRESENTE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF MENTAL HEALTH CARE IN
ORGANIZATIONS WE ARE IN SUPPORT
IF. ADRIAN HOW DEGREE WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. DAVID GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT IF.
PRODUCT OF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE
ELSE WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THE MOTION. THE MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY MR
RODRIGUEZ MOTION TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. JOINS A NEW
PASSED RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR WHICH LIKE THE CLOSENESS
AGUIAR-CURRY. YOUR PUT YOUR-
IT'S A PHENOMENAL PROGRAM AND
IT'S BEEN IN MY COMMUNITY FOR
YEARS A SO NIGHT NICE WE'RE
ACTUALLY KIND QUALIFY IN THIS TO
MAKE SURE WE GO FORWARD. AND I
WANT TO THINK THESE OF SPONSORS
FOR ATTENDING TODAY IN TELLING
THE STORY ASSEMBLY ELSEWHERE I
WROTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU TO YOUR WITNESSES AS
WELL- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL. WHAT I WHAT I WALDRON
AGUIAR-CURRY I FIGURE CURRY I
ARAMBULA BIGELOW CARILLORIO AYE
FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO GARCIA. OR
ZERO FOUR ZERO WITH THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
MUCH. THIS WEEK'S.
YOU HAVE AB TWENTY TWENTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
LETTING ME SNEAK IN HERE. YOUR
OPRICHNIKI SRU THE PROBLEMS OF.
YOU'RE VERY LUCKY I SEE MISTER
MURATSUCHI THERE IS WAITING I
THINK WE TO BUILD AND I WAS THIS
IS A LOCAL FOR THE FAST I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND ACCEPT THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AS AMENDED
AB TWENTY TWENTY OF THE BILL.
GREAT AS AMENDED AB TWENTY
TRAINING WILL INCREASE ACCESS TO
FERTILITY SERVICES INCLUDING.
IVF TO MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
BY REQUIRING LARGE GROUP HEATH
INSURANCE PLANS. TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE. I WILL SAY I THINK
THIS BILL MODERNIZES OUR CURRENT
LAW IT BRINGS EQUITY WE HAVE TOO
MANY OLD. TO WE CANNOT OF THESE
RESOURCES WE ALSO FOLKS WHO
SUFFER FROM CANCER AND OTHER
AILMENTS THAT NEED THIS AND I
ALSO JUST SENT A PERSONAL NOTE-
MY SECOND DAUGHTER IS A PRODUCT
OF IVF- AND SO I KNOW THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR MANY FEW
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO START A
FAMILY IT'S DEEPLY PERSONAL TO
ME- WITHOUT EVER RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I'VE- IDENTIFIED.
THANK YOU PERFECT THANK YOU.
YOUR PERCEPTION THERE SO WE CAN
HEAR YOU THANK YOU MY NAME IS
MARCEL CEDARS AND I AM A
PHYSICIAN AT UCSF I'M A
REPRODUCTIVE ENDOCRINOLOGIST AND
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF REPRODUCTIVE
MEDICINE. BERMAN GOOD ANY
MEMBERS INFERTILITY HAS LONG
BEEN RECOGNIZED AS A DISEASE BY
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION.
THE AMERICAN MEDICAL SOCIETY
NEWS ORGANIZATION I AM PROUD TO
HEAD THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE. AND YET
CALIFORNIA LAW SETS INFERTILITY
APART FROM OTHER DISEASES ID
ONE. PERVERSE WAY. INFERTILITY
IS THE ONLY DISEASE THAT IS
FREQUENTLY COVERED TO DIAGNOSE
BUT NOT TO COMPREHENSIVELY TREAT
. CALIFORNIA'S ANTIQUATED
INFERTILITY INSURANCE.
AND EVEN WHEN A PLAYER'S REQUEST
COVERAGE INSURERS CAN EXCLUDE IN
VITRO FERTILIZATION. IT ALSO
DEFINES INFERTILITY IN SUCH A
NARROW WAY AS TO EXCLUDE THE
LGBTQ COMMUNITY AND SINGLE
PEOPLE NEEDING MEDICAL
INTERVENTION TO BUILD THEIR
FAMILIES. AS DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
AT UCSF I CAN ATTEST THE ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES TO THIS OUR
DAUGHTER DAVID LAW ARE TWO FOLD
. THERE ARE THOSE CALIFORNIANS
WHO DO NOT EVEN SEE CARE BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS OR
FINANCES AND THEY THEREFORE
SUFFER THE EMOTIONAL COSTS OF
STRUGGLING TO GROW THE FAMILIES
THEY WOULD LOVE TO HAVE. PATIENT
BUT ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS THE
MOST EFFECTIVE EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT OF IVF BECAUSE COST
WOULD BE OUT OF POCKET AS IVF IS
NOT A COVERED BENEFIT UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. THESE PATIENTS
OFTEN SEEK LESS EFFECTIVE
SOMETIMES RISKIER AND COSTLY
TREATMENTS THAT ULTIMATELY LEAD
TO DOWNSTREAM HEALTH ISSUES FOR
BOTH THE PREGNANT PERSON AND
CHILDREN OR CHILD OR CHILDREN.
WE INCREASING THE FAT AND THE
STATE. WHEN THE FULL SUITE OF
TREATMENTS INCLUDING IVF IS
COVERED PHYSICIANS ARE ABLE TO
TAILOR CARE TO EACH PATIENT
CHOOSING THE LEAST EXPENSIVE AND
LEAST INVASIVE THAT IS MOST
MEDICALLY EFFECTIVE ACCORDING TO
CURRENT GUIDELINES. FERTILITY
TREATMENT IS PART OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE JUST
LIKE MATERNITY CARE IN FAMILY
PLANNING IT IS. THAT OUR
INSURANCE LAW. THIS REALITY AND
PROVIDE THE SAME KIND OF
INSURANCE COVERAGE PEOPLE SHOULD
NOT HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PAYING RENT PUTTING FOOD ON THE
TABLE OR USING THOSE SAME
DOLLARS TO START THEIR FAMILY.
ASK THAT YOU PASS. B. TWENTY
TWENTY NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS WITH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WOULD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ANABEL ADAMS AND I SUPPORT AB
TWENTY TWENTY NINE BECAUSE IDEA
OF COVERAGE IS HEALTHCARE.
WITHOUT THIS HEALTHCARE I HAVE
SUFFERED SIX PREGNANCY LOSSES
BUT SEVENTY TWO WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY SYMPTOMS LIKE MORNING
SICKNESS AND NAUSEA. OVER THREE
AND A HALF. THAT'S COUNTLESS
PRESENTS AND A YEARNING TO BUILD
A FAMILY THAT HAS BEEN CRUSHED
BY DRAMATIC LOST TIME AND TIME
AGAIN AFTER ALL THIS I STILL
HAVE ZERO LIVING CHILDREN. I AM
THE ONE WITH THE DISEASE OF
INFERTILITY WHICH INCLUDES
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TROUBLE GETTING
PREGNANT. AND PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TROUBLE SUSTAINING A PREGNANCY.
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT THE
FAMILIES WHO CAN CONCEIVE
NATURAL PREGNANCIES BUT FOR WHOM
IVF WOULD HELP THEM BRING HOME
THE BABY IN THEIR ARMS. I WAS
BORN WITH TOPIC TWIST. ON ONE OF
MY FIFTH CHROMOSOMES JUST CALLED
A CHROMOSOME VERSION. IT'S ONE
OF A HANDFUL GENETIC ALTERATIONS
CALLED STRUCTURAL CHROMOSOME
REARRANGEMENTS. BECAUSE THE ONLY
AFFECT A PERSON'S ABILITY TO
CONCEIVE. MOST PEOPLE BURKE
ABILITY TO CONCEIVE A HEALTHY
PREGNANCY MOST PEOPLE DON'T KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE ONE OR THAT THEIR
PARTNER HAS ONE UNTIL THE
EXPERIENCING BECAUSE HE US.
GENETIC IS FAX THIS PLEA THIS IS
GENDER PARTNER HAS THE ISSUE AND
HIS SISTER AND FOR. NOT CHEAP
THIS IT'LL FOR THE FAMILY AS OF
HAD THE HERSELF. WOULD I BE A
PEOPLE WITH DO LIKE MINE TELL IT
WAS TO IT THERE ARE. TRANSFERRED
WHEN I FOUND OUT THAT THE DOCTOR
RECOMMENDED CURE TO MY CONDITION
IVF WAS UNCOVERED BY MY
INSURANCE IT FELT LIKE ANOTHER
LOSS HANG UP GOOD FOR US F. MY
HOPE NIGHT ARE ALL. OUR CHILDREN
SPEND. HERE TO THEIR BIRTH. WITH
ANY OF COVERAGE. WE FELT
INCLINED TO PLAY THE LOTTERY OF
CONCEIVING NATURAL PREGNANCIES
AND THE HOPES WE GET A PREGNANCY
UNAFFECTED BY MY GENETIC ISSUE.
ONE OF THE MOST COMMON CANCER IN
MANDATING IVF COVERAGE IS THAT
IT MIGHT BE EXPENSIVE I'D LIKE
TO. CONCERN INTO THIS MANDATING
IVF COVERAGE RECURRENT PREGNANCY
LOSSES BECAUSE FINANCIAL
PHYSICAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL HARM
MY LAST MISCARRIAGE SURGERY COST
UTERINE SCARRING WHICH HAD
UNSUCCESSFULLY TREATED WITH A
LEFT ME STERILE. AND THERE ARE
COPS DORSAL ISHANT IS LOST AND
THERE'S AN ADDED LAYER OF HARM
WHEN IT COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED WITH IVF. SUPPORTING
AB TWENTY NINE SUPPORTING THE BE
FOR PEOPLE THAT NEED TO START
YOUR FAMILIES WITHOUT AN DURING
THE PHYSICAL CYCLE JEKYLL AND BY
TOTALS NOT HAVING IVF COVERAGE
NO ONE FOR TO SAYS. ON THEIR
PAGE RECKONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WHEN IN OPPOSITION TO
PLEASE COME IN. B.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESTON YOUNG
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE TODAY RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AB TWO ZERO TWO NINE
I'M THE HEALTHCARE MANDATE BILL
ALWAYS A DIFFICULT SITUATION NO
X. OBVIOUSLY- PENSION. VERY
CLEAR THE INTENTIONS HERE GOOD
I'M I'M HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT- THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
COME ALONG WITH THIS DIDN'T.
PRESS UP. I WILL RESIST JONES
THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE B. TWENTY TWENTY NINE ARE
THE COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED
WITH IT YOU KNOW THE CALIFORNIA
BUT IF YOU PROGRAM CAN ALICE'S
OF. THAT IF BILL. PRINT THE DAYS
THE LIES WENT INTO AFFECT IT
WOULD HAVE NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PREMIUM IMPACT ON
EMPLOYERS IN THE STATE OF FOR.
ONLY IF NOT SIMPLY YEARS THAT.
BILL IT'S GOING TO BE THE
EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WELL DRIVEN OUT
INDICATED THAT THE EMPLOYEE
PREMIUMS WOULD INCREASE OVER TWO
HUNDRED TEN DOLLARS. WHEN DOES
THE FACT EMPLOYERS BUT IT
DIRECTLY IMPATS HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABLE ABILITY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE. AGAIN I
WANT TO MAKE. EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS IS A WELL IN THE BILL. BUT
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
REGARDING HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY OF TO BE RICH
BASED. I IN THE CONTACT YOUR- AS
FIFTEEN MAN GOALS NOS COLLECTIVE
WOULD HAVE A PREMIUMS FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLAR
THIS ONE MANDATE HERE IS-
COMPARABLE TO THOSE FIFTEENTH
COLLECTIVELY ANALYZE LAST FOR
FOUR OF THE WHOLE. BECAUSE THIS
IS. LAST YEAR'S AB. REMAINS FROM
IS COVERS IN 22% A TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE KAISER FAMILY
FOUNDATION PLAYER HEALTH
BENEFITS SURVEY INDICATED THAT
ARE JOB BASED COVERAGE THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL PREMIUM FOR
FAMILY COVERAGE IS TWENTY
THOUSAND TO HUNDRED ONE DOLLARS.
INCREASED TWENTY TWO POURTANT
YOU I- EXPRESSED CONCERN TODAY
IN JUST WISH THE REMAINING-
COGNIZANT OF THE IMPACT THAT THE
MANDATE AS A HEALTH CARE VOUCHER
THE- BOTH YOU FOR YOUR- MISTER
CHAIRMAN OR THE COMMITTEE HAD
JEFF HAMPTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION PLANS ALSO HERE. AND
THAT TWENTY. I WE ALL FROM ARE
TO INCREASE OF THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL- AS MISTER YOUNG I
JUST MENTIONED- AND WE WOULD
LIMÓN OUR MEN'S- AT FOUND THE
OPPOSITION I POSTED A MYSTERY
COMMENTS NAV YOUR CHEN. ABOUT
THE COST TAKE A LOOK- IT. IT IT
THE- ABSOLUTE BUT PRETTY SOON- I
ALSO LIKE TO JUST MENTION THAT-
YOU KNOW THIS MANDATE ALONG WITH
THE OTHER THIRTEEN BENEFIT MAN.
RICHARD THIS YEAR COLLECTIVE HE
A HAVE A PREMIUM PACK. I A-
MEMBER. OF FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
JUST THE YEAR SO TAKING CALL
TAKE AT CLAY. AND AN YOU KNOW.
THE HEARING ROOM PLEASE COME UP
. AGAIN JUST GAME OUR POSITION
ON THE BILL AND ORGANIZATIONS
WHO REPRESENT ONE. ISABEL ARE
QUITE ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. HIS GREENBERG TRAURIG
REPRESENTING ACADEMY OF
CALIFORNIANS OPTION LAWYERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ERIN REID
BURKE WITH STATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. SHARE MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS THAT ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE CHAMBER AND
CAP THANKS. THANK YOU. KATIE
MADE BY A YOUNG CANCER SURVIVOR
AND A BOARD MEMBER OF THE BAY
AREA YOUNG SURVIVORS IN SUPPORT
. TOMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN
SUPPORT MIGHT HAVE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO REGISTER SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF. VISIBLE CALIFORNIA'S
STATE TRONG WITH THE PROPER OUR
FAMILY COALITION. MEN HAVING
BABIES THANK I DON. TION OF MAY
. ALLOWANCE HOW FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWER. MILITARY FOR BUILDING.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE THANK YOU. IF. HI
JOYCE REINECKE- WE ARE ALSO A
CUT A CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL
FROM THE ALLIANCE FOR FERTILITY
PRESERVATION I ALSO WANNA
REGISTER SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY FOR RE
MEDICINE IN RESERVE THE NATIONAL
FERTILITY ORGANISER. Q. HI I AM
OF PEDIATRIC IN SURVIVE AND USES
OF MEDICAL AND IT'S- IF. WHAT
ELSE. YOU KNOW BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE WE
DO HAVE A MOTION I MISS CARILLO
IN THE SECOND BY MR RODRIGUEZ.
THIS KOREA THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND JUST THINK IT
TO THE AUTHOR AND TO THE
SUPPORTERS AND SPONSORS FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT A
FOR WOMEN WHO. TO ONE DAY BE
ABLE TO BECOME MOTHERS OF FOR
AND FOR ALL PEOPLE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO EVENTUALLY HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHILDREN. I DO
HAVE TO DO THAT I'VE JUST
SLIGHTLY STRIKING AND NO
DISRESPECT TO THE GENTLEMAN BUT-
TAPPED TO MEN COMMON OPPOSED
THIS BILL JUST LOOK AT THE
SERVER END OF WAY. AND SO I JUST
HAVE IT AND I THINK. THIS IS NOT
A DID. THE ORGANIZATION THAT.
AND BUT IT DOES LOOK A CERTAIN
KIND OF WAY. AND NIGHT. CAN HELP
YOU WITH OUT OF IT RELATED TO AN
EQUITY- WE TALK ABOUT WHAT THAT
LOOKS WOMEN WHAT JUSTICE LOOKS
LIKE WHAT OPPORTUNITY LOOKS
LIKE. THE RIGHT SHOES INCLUDES
THE RIGHT TO FIND AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BECOME A MOTHER. AND I THINK
OF SOMEONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
A MOM ONE DAY I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THAT CHOICE AVAILABLE MY
HEALTH PLAN. AND NOT TO BE A
BURKE. MY OWN FINING THIS. WAS
CERTAINLY OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EVERYONE ELSE AND SO I THINK
YOU. FOR THE COURAGE THAT IT
TAKES TO BRING THESE INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT. BILLS FORWARD. AND I
HOPE THAT THE OPPOSITE. IS THE
WAY. TO WORK WITH WOMEN. AND TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY IN WHICH CAN
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES IN A WAY
THAT FAMILY PLANNING CAN BE MORE
EQUITABLE. THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO. YOU KNOW GO OUT OF POCKET
AND- YOU KNOW PAY AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO BE ABLE TO
CREATE A FAMILY OF YOUR OWN
ESPECIALLY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE PRIDE OURSELVES ON
BEING THE FIFTH LARGEST. AN
INITIAL. FOR WOMEN CONTENT.
FRIENDS CENTER. OF HEALTH CARE
DISCUSSIONS AND I HOPE. THAT WE
CAN FIND A RESOLUTION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU. VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
. IN NONE OKAY SAID WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AT THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
CORPORATIONS IT WAS A PET DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR WHICH OUGHT TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU AND ALSO- APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS BY MISS CARILLO
ALSO JUST WANNA. THE AND THE
PENANCE TOOK FROM COMMITTEE- OF
LIMIT THE BILL TO THE LARGE
HEALTH GROUP PLANS- AND LIVER
LIMON COVERAGE OF FOR TREE-
HOPEFUL AS WELL AS WITH THE CAP
OF LIFE AND OF THESE TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR OFF. PLOWING THE
MISCREANTS I'M SO A- DISCUSSED I
WILL ALSO SAY THERE WAS A TWO
TWENTY ONE MERCER SERVE OF MORE
THAN HUNDRED. 16% OF PLAYERS
OFFERING AND FERTILITY COVERAGE
INCLUDING IVF HAVE NOT
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES IN THEIR MEDICAL COSTS
SO I THINK THERE'S A WAY WE CAN
DO THIS I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
TEN CONVERSATIONS OFFICE
WITHOUT. RESPECT I. WICKS- MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD I WALDRON. WALDRON I
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW YOU KNOW I
FLORA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO GARCIA. THE
FIVE VOTES WILL BE THE BILL ON
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NOW BE
MOVING TO MISTER BRIAN. ARGUS
RESEARCH IT'S ENOUGH. WHAT'S
YOUR BILL. THE YOU HAVE A AB
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY FOUR MISTER
BRYANT CORRECT. GOTTA LOVE BY
ORDER. ONLY IF YOU'RE A B. AND
NOT M. RIGHT NOW HE'S NOT LOVING
YOU VERY MUCH. OUR W. YEAH YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR-
AND MEMBERS BEFORE I BEGIN I
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO THANK.
BOTH WHICH ARE IN THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING
SO CLOSELY WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS BILL. ARISE WITHIN A-
THIRTY FOR A BILL THAT WOULD
CREATE A PILOT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS
OF CRIME THAT IS SEPARATE. LAW
ENFORCEMENT CURRENTLY SURVIVOR.
FILE OF VIOLENCE MAY RECEIVE
SERVICES RESOURCES LIKE CRIME
RELATED COUNSELING EMERGENCY
SERVICES ASSISTANCE WITH
RESTITUTION COMMONSENSE
COMPENSATION CLAIMS. ONLY IF
THEY COOPERATE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT BY OPENING A CASE
AGAINST A- THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
CURRENT THAT BY TYING THESE
SERVICES FOR SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE. CONTACT WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT THERE CAN BE A
DAUNTING AND ARDUOUS BARRIER FOR
PEOPLE STRUGGLING WITH TRAUMA IN
FACT LESS THAN A THIRD OF CRIME
SURVIVORS REPORT RECEIVING HELP
. SO MEDICAL OR MENTAL HEALTH
HELP. ONE RECENT SURVEY BY THE
NATIONAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
HOTLINE REVEALED THAT HE PERCENT
OF SURVIVOR SURVEYED REPORTED
FEELING SOMEWHAT OR EXTREMELY
AFRAID. TO CALL LONG FOR THE
VICTIM SERVICES. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY FOUR WILL CREATE A PILOT
PROGRAM IN FIVE COUNTIES
INCLUDING LOS ANGELES AND
ALAMEDA TO PROVIDE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES FOR ALL SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
THEY ARE WILLING TO OPEN A CASE
THAT MAY EXPOSE THEMSELVES.
THEY'RE LUCKY TO PROCESS. GEISHA
IS COUNTY WILL STAB AN OFFICE OF
SURVIVOR SUPPORT AND HARM
REDUCTION THAT IS INDEPENDENT
FROM THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. THE OFFICE WILL ACCEPT
WALKING SELF REFERRALS REFERRALS
FROM QUARTZ COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATION SCHOOLS SMALL
BUSINESSES PUBLIC DEFENDERS.
PROSECUTORS LAW ENFORCEMENT
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. AND OTHERS.
THESE OFFICES WILL SAYS THE
SURVIVORS NEED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES THAT INCLUDE HEALTH
SERVICES BOTH. OR HOW EXPERIENCE
. LAW PROVIDE HOUSING REESE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT FOR VICTIMS
AND SURVIVORS INCLUDING HELP
FILLING OUT VICTIMS
COMPENSATION. FUND REQUEST WE
KNOW THAT AN UNDER UTILIZED TO
HEAR AT THE STATE LEVEL.
UTILIZING THE SERVICES THE
WHOLE. IVERS WHEN THEY'RE VOTE
SEEKING. DRIVERS SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THEIR NEEDS
AND THEIR FEARS WITH THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM TO GIVE
TESTIMONY WITH ME TODAY I'M
JOINED BY APRIL GRAYSON POLICY.
THE FREEDOM CENTER. PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. YEP
YEP RESETTLE BUTTON THERE M. I.
C. A. R. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR. HEALTH
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DARCY GREEN
AND I'M AS THE JUSTICE GROUP
MEMBER AND LEADER AS THE JUSTICE
GROUP IS INTENTIONAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT HARNESSES THE
POWER WOMEN WITHIN RATED LOVE
WHAT TO AND THANK. TWIN CITIES
THE WINNER THE ONE IN MAN WHO
HAVEN'T LOVELAND AS IT SPOKE
WITH HER OF AB TWO THREE FOR. AS
A PART OF AND IT AS A PART OF
THE CARE FOR COLA. AS A SURVIVOR
. BY ENABLE SAID VICTIM SUPPORT
SERVICES A RE. NO FOR HAND THAT
YOU'RE SO OF. TWO FIVE THIRTY.
I WAS WRONGLY IDENTIFIED AS THE
PERSON WHO CAUSED HARM
THANKFULLY AFTER MY ATTORNEY
PROVIDED THE FACTS REGARDING THE
SITUATION THE DA DIDN'T PICK UP
MY CASE HOWEVER. THAT THERE WERE
NO WAY FOR ME TO BELIEVE YOU
THAT I WAS A PERPETRATOR AND IT
IS A UNTIL LONG. LATER THE COURT
. WRITING FOR OF. KNOWLEDGE THE
ACT. DURING THE SIX I WAS TAX
MANY SIR SERVICES BECAUSE OF THE
STRICT RULES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SOME SOME HAPPENED
AND THE OFFICES OFTEN HAVE
AROUND SERVING ONLY THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN FOR A DENTAL IT AS THE
- I'M- DURING. HAVING ACCESS TO
ADD FOR SERVICE WITH EVERY THE
PAY AND BRING MY EXPERIENCE I
HAD TO NAVIGATE MY SITUATION
WITHOUT THIS. OF ADAM SERVICE OR
LEGAL SYSTEM THAT SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE ME SUPPORT HAD I BEEN
ABLE TO ACCESS IN A PET ALONG
PORT WHAT IF THE FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS I PAID TURN. SAFE I'M
THANKS HE WOULDN'T LONG DURING
THE OF SEEKING SURVIVORS SUPPORT
SERVICES YOU TEND TO THINK THAT
YOU'RE NOT ELIGIBLE YOU TEND TO
THINK THAT IF YOU'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE. THEN MAYBE. CARE NO
ONE CARES ABOUT HEALING TRAUMA
OR STE SUPPORTING SURVIVORS AND
THERE'S A FEELING THAT YOU DON'T
FIT THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
MAYBE DON'T BELONG. AB TWO
BEFORE WOULD REMOVE THESE
BARRIERS I FACED IN ACCESSING
SERVICES BY ESTABLISHING A PILOT
IN THE PROVIDE HELP BASED
INFORMED SERVICES INDEPENDENT
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT. SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE LIKE MYSELF
EXPERIENCED THE NOT. THE RATE.
RESEARCH THANK IS A COOK AND
SUCH AS- THAT'S RIGHT AS MY
DEBUT AND OTHER. ILLNESS THIS IS
WHY WE NEED THIS A- WITH FOUR
WITH A THAT BEING RESPONSIVE TO
SIR PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS AND SAID EVERY PUNITIVELY
OUT RELY UPON. PLEASE A LOT
EXPERIENCES AND OF ALSO. YOUR
VOTE AND SO OF AB TWENTY THIRTY
FOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WEEK PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR WOULD AND HEALTH COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ABLE GRAYSON
I AM A POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH THE
YOUNG ONES FREEDOM CENTER. I'LL
A SURVIVOR. IS YOUR VOTE I WAS
CRIMINALIZED TRAFFICKED AND
SERVED SEVENTEEN YEARS IN THE
WORLD'S LARGEST WOMEN'S
INSTITUTION. THE STATED PURPOSE
WAS TO COME ALIVE MY
VICTIMIZATION BECAUSE THE FIRST
RESPONSIBILITY WITH KARMA
VIOLENCE IN OUR SOCIETY IS
PUNITIVE. I WAS PROMOTED TO THE
OTHER TEAM. AND AN EFFORT TO
GIVE BACK TO MY COMMUNITY I
BECAME FAMILIAR WITH THE
COMMISSION WITH. THE COMMUNITY
AGAINST SEXUAL HARM. A LOCAL
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATION.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR TERRY GARVIN
WAS THE FIRST PERSON EVER SEE ME
AS A SURVIVOR OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AND PROVIDE ME WITH
THE RESPECT OF THE SERVICES I
NEEDED TO HEAL. THIS IS BECAUSE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
RECOGNIZED THE VIOLENCE THE HELP
BASIS THAT LET LEFT BARBERS IN
DIRE NEED OF TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE. THIS ORDER BASIS. BALANCE
WHEN I LEFT THE CLIMB.
UNFORTUNATELY I AM NOT ALONE THE
NUMBER OF WOMEN WERE
INCARCERATED AND ALSO SURVIVORS
OF CRIME IS ASTOUNDING STUDIES
SHOW THAT OVER 60% QUESTRADE
WOMEN EXPERIENCE PHYSICAL OR
SEXUAL AS PART OF THEIR CORE
MISSION. HOW THE BILL HELP TRUMP
ONCE. DIFFICULT THANK. FORCE OF
OUR- IN DOING SO THE EXISTING
SURVIVOR THE EXISTING STRUCTURE
DENIES SURVIVORS OF CRIME THE
HEALTH ACCESS THEY NEED TO HILL
AFTER THEY BECOME SURVIVORS. AS
A RESULT. MANY SURVIVORS BIGLEY
WOMEN OF COLOR CONTINUE TO LIVE
IN A CYCLE OF TRAUMA VIOLENCE
THAT CONTINUES TO HARM OUR
COMMUNITIES. AT THE SERVICES I
RECEIVED. I DO NOT KNOW NOW
WHERE I WILL BE TODAY. WHICH IS
WHY AFTER. THE CREATION OF THIS
PILOT PROGRAM WILL HELP INCREASE
ACCESS TO TRAUMA FOR PROGRAMS
THAT HELP THE BARBERS HILL WHILE
PREVENTING FURTHER HARM. BUT IT
IS. URGENT SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THREE NINE WILL ASK AT
ANYBODY IN THE CHAMBER LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
IS YOUR NAME AND POSITION
ORGANIZATIONS YOU REPRESENT ONE
. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DRINKING
THERE ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. REMARKING
THAT ESSIE JUSTICE GROUP AND
ALSO HERE TO REGISTER THE
SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS CAN YOU CAN USE
SPEAK UP TO SOLAR POWER PLEASE.
OUR FIRST CALLER NASA DIDN'T
POWER NOT NOT THE FENCE OFF.
IMAGE JUSTICE FREEDOM FOR YOU.
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR WOMEN
PRISONERS. YOUNG WOMEN'S FREEDOM
CENTER. SAN FRANCISCO BAY DRIVE
A VERSA DIVERSION PROJECT. AND
THE COURTS ARE CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE.
FINORA BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WALDRON
PLACE I'M THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD- YOU KNOW WE DO
KNOW WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE
CAR SCHOOL SETTINGS- HAVE
EXPERIENCED TRAUMA SOMETIMES
MULTIPLE TRAUMAS PRIOR TO THEIR
INCARCERATION- AT A VERY HIGH
LEVEL I THINK I HEARD SOMETHING
LIKE 86% OF WOMEN WHO ARE
MCCARTY RATED HAVE BEEN THIS
VIEWS ARE ARE OF MENTALLY ABUSED
AND- TRAUMAS. ARE EXASPERATED
WITH. PRISON OR JAIL- PUTTING
PEOPLE INTO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS NOT HELPING I'M NOT
ADDRESSING THAT AND WE REALLY
NEED TO HAVE A NEW WAY OF
LOOKING AT- YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE
DEALING WITH THE ISSUE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING THE THOMAS
WE'RE JUST MAKING THE WORST SO-
I WOULD SUPPORT THE BILL A MOVE
THE BILL. THANK YOU ANY ANYONE
ELSE. YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAVE A
WILL TAKE MOTION FOR MISS OUT
MISSILE WALDRON SECOND FOR MISS
CARILLO- MISTER PRIME WHICH THAT
CLOSES JOINT DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MOTION WOULD BE
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RESEARCH AND- I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE BASED ON THE
IDEA THAT VICTIMS OF VIOLENCE OR
BEING A SURVIVOR IS A
DESIGNATION THAT YOU ONLY GET IF
IT'S ON A POLICE REPORT. OR IF
YOU ARE A FORMAL PARTICIPANT IN
THE PROSECUTION OF ANOTHER
PERSON- EXCLUDE A LOT OF PEOPLE
FROM THE HELP THAT THEY NEED A
LOT OF PEOPLE AND SO STARTING
THIS PILOT HERE IN CALIFORNIA A
VALUE WAITING. DO THINK. IT IS
IN A POLICY GOAL I AND I
APPRECIATE THE JURY'S
RECOMMENDATION IN RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR BRYAN M. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. BIGELOW RIO RIO AYE
FLORA. OR NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I MAYES. MCCARTY
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN IRA RODRIGUEZ
. SANTIAGO GARCIA. THANKS TO ONE
SIX ONE WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A
SURPRISE THANK YOU. THIS
FRIEDMAN PRESENTING FOR MISS
CALDERON AND THEN YOURSELF.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- I AM
PRESENTING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SIX IN ADDITION TO THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
WORK WILL PROHIBIT THE
OSTEOPATHICMEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND THE FA'S
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT BOARD
REVOKING OR SUSPENDING A LICENSE
MEDICAL PROFESSIONAL FOR PROVIDE
A SAFE AND LEGAL ABORTION CARE
TO PATIENTS AND MANY AND OTHER
STATES TWENTY SIX STATES ARE ACT
TO BAN ABORTION. RUSSIAN
PROVIDER AS A REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM STATE CALIFORNIA IS
LIKELY TO BE A DESTINATION FOR
MILLIONS OF PREGNANT WOMEN
DESPERATE TO SEEK AN ABORTION.
OF FOR CARE THAT THEY CANNOT
GET. IN THEIR OWN STATES. THIS
LEGISLATION EXTENDS PROTECTIONS
TO OTHER CALIFORNIA PORTION
PROVIDERS BY PREVENTING RELEVANT
PROFESSIONAL PORTSMOUTH POKING
OR SUSPENDING A LICENSE FOR
PROVIDING A LAWFUL ABORTION TO
PATIENTS SEEKING CARE IN THE
STATE. HOPEFULLY NOT ONLY
PREVENTING THE- HARM TO THE-
NATIONALS BUT SAVING LIVES AND
PREVENTING WOMEN FROM SEEKING
BACK CHANNEL A BACKROOM IN A
BACK ALLEY ABORTIONS IN THEIR
OWN STATES. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX IS
DOCTOR GANTT DANIEL GROSSMAN A
PROFESSOR PROFESSOR OF OPT
OBSTETRICS GYNECOLOGY. SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE HE DIRECTS A
RESEARCH PROGRAM CALLED
ADVANCING NEW STANDARDS IN
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH. HELP THANK
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULDN'T COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AS A
PRACTICING OBSTETRICIAN
GYNECOLOGIST- I'VE LIVED AND
WORKED IN IN OTHER COUNTRIES
WHERE ABORTION IS ILLEGAL OR
HIGHLY RESTRICTED AND I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND HOW IN THESE CONTACT
. I HAVE TO SAY PROP TO
TERMINATE THEIR PREGNANCIES IN
THE- I'VE SEEN HOW THEY CAN
SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES OF
UNSAFE ABORTIONS SOMETIMES A
THING WITH THEIR LIVES- I NEVER
THOUGHT THE DAY. COME WHEN
ABORTION CARE WOULD BE ILLEGAL
IN THE U. S. STATE BUT THAT TIME
HAS ARRIVED- HERE ALREADY IN
TEXAS- AS WE'VE HEARD AS WE WAIT
FOR THE U. S. SUPREME COURT
DECISION. IN THE-
AND- OVERTURNED LEADING TO
SEVERE RESTRICTIONS IN ABOUT
HALF THE STATES. AS A
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM STATE WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION- AND THAT'S A
RESPONSIBILITY THAT MY
COLLEAGUE. ABORTION PROVIDERS
AND MYSELF TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY- WE CANNOT SIT BY IDLY
AS WE SEE PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TAKEN
AWAY IN OTHER STATES PUTTING
THEIR HEALTH AT RISK. WHILE WE
HAVE THE SKILL. TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN IF A PATIENT A STATE WITH
SEVERE RESTRICTIONS SEEKS OUT MY
HELP TO OBTAIN SAFE ABORTION
CARE I WOULD FEEL COMPELLED TO
HELP THEM- FOR EXAMPLE PATIENT
ME TRAVEL HERE. EIGHTEEN ME
TRAVELING. MEDICATIONS TO THE
ABORTION HERE- AND HAVE THE
COMPLETED IN THEIR HOME STATE-
OR THEY MAY SEEK OUT TELEHEALTH
SERVICES HERE TO OBTAIN A
MEDICATION ABORTION. FROM A
CALIFORNIA WRITER. ALL OF THESE
SERVICES ARE SAFE EFFECTIVE AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE STANDARD OF
MEDICAL CARE- THERE IS OFFERED
TWENTY CENTS. ELBOW FOR OUT OF.
AND STATE. THE STATE RUN. WELL
AS- THOSE WHO ARE VERY. HERE IN
THEIR HOME. NUMBER ONE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE WHO SEEK OF CARE ARE-
BLACK AND OTHER PEOPLE- AND
THREE FOR OR ON LOW AND THESE
ARE THE PEOPLE WHO WILL BE MOST
GRAVELY AFFECTED BY THE BAN.
OTHER STATE THIS MY GOOD INTO TO
HELP PEOPLE OF CARE OTHERS I
UNDERSTAND THAT WOULD FACE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE READ BY
PROVIDING THE THAT I OUTLINE
PATIENT PURPOSE. PORTION INCLUDE
CIVIL HE'S- STILL LOSING LICENSE
. AB TWO SIX TWO SIX WITH TO
ADDRESS THAT LAST CONCERNED
ENSURING THAT MY MOTHER LICENSE.
WOULD NOT BE SUS OR- SIMPLY
BECAUSE I PROVIDED. CARE THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE LEGAL YOUR-
YEAH SO I YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MUCH WE HAVE A WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE GO UP WE HAVE
PUSHED THE BUTTON THERE ON THE
FOR THE MIKE FROM. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS THERESA
BRENNAN I'M A CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY THE THIRD GENERATION
PRO LIFE ACTIVIST MOTHER OF FIVE
AND PRESIDENT OF THE RIGHT TO
LIFE LEAGUE. AMERICA'S FIRST PRO
LIFE ORGANIZATION. REPRESENTING
FIFTY TWO PREGNANCY HELP CLICK
CENTERS OF. THE HOMES IN
EVERYONE. SIX THIS SOLE PURPOSE
IS TO INSULATE AND PROTECT
DOCTORS NURSES AND OTHER MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHO PERFORM
ABORTIONS BUT ABORTION IS NOT
HEALTH CARE. ITCAN NEVER BE
HEALTH CARE WHEN THE OUTCOME OF
THE PROCEDURE IS THE DEATH OF A
LIVING HUMAN BEING. AT ET EACH
OF YOU UNDERSTANDS THE SOMETIMES
DEPLORABLE HISTORY OF OUR NATION
WHEN LOOKING BACK IT HAS ALWAYS
TURNED OUT TO BE A SHAMEFUL
TRAVESTY WHEN SOCIETY IS WILLING
TO INTENTIONALLY DE HUMANIZE AND
MISTREAT A GROUP OF HUMAN PEOPLE
FOR REASONS OF CONVENIENCE OUR
FINANCIAL BENEFIT OF ANOTHER
GROUP OF PEOPLE. THE ISSUE
PRESENT THIS BILL I AT ITS CORE
A HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE. AND PRO
LIFE CITIZENS ARE STANDING ON
THE RIGHT SIDE OF HISTORY. WE
FEEL FOR MOTHERS WHO WILL BE
BURDENED BY CARRYING THEIR HUMAN
CHILD INTO IT CAN BE ADOPTED OR
OTHERWISE CARED FOR. AND WE MUST
PROVIDE EVERY POSSIBLE SERVICE
AND SUPPORT TO BOTH MOTHER AND
CHILD. BUT WE CANNOT PRETEND
THAT THESE ARE NOT PEOPLE WHOSE
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS. BEING
TRAMPLED IN THIS CAPITOL
BUILDING EVERY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION. CONSIDER WHETHER YOU
CAN FIND ONE INSTANCE IN HISTORY
WHERE ACTIVISTS STANDING AGAINST
THE DE HUMANIZATION OF A GROUP
OF PEOPLE WERE ULTIMATELY FOUND
TO BE WRONG. CONSIDER MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMUNITY COMMITTEE WHETHER
YOU ARE ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
HISTORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHAT IN THE CHAMBER POSITION
POSITION ON THE BILL IN NAME
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE MY REPS AND
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE IN SOME. THE
YOU. BRENT SPENCER WITH THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STRYCHNINE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. ISABELLA ARE QUITE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION AND NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. SURE MEMBERS KATHY MOSSBERG
ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS ROXANNE GOAL WITH
THE AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS ARE YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. NO ONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOTION HAS NOT BEEN MOVED MOTION
SECOND FOR BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY-
THE DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH LIKE THE
CLOSENESS FRIEDMAN JUST BRIEFLY
MY MOTHER WAS A NURSE WHO SPENT.
LIFE FIGHTING FOR SURE WHICH IS
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS AND RIGHT TO
SELF DETERMINATION FOR EVERYONE
THIS COUNTRY AND I AM HORRIFIED
BY THE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO TAKE
THAT. LONG FOUGHT AWAY FROM US
AND I'LL GEN I BOUGHT ON THE
BILL. MISTREATMENT AS PLEASE
CALL THE- WHAT I WOULD I WALDRON
. WALDRON NO AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I AROUND. BIGELOW
RIO RIO AYE FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
GARCIA. SIX ONE FOUR SIX ONE
WILL BE THE BILL ON CALL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. YOU HAVE AB
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU-
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND WOMEN A YEAR WILL BE
DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST CANCER AND
IN JUST ONE YEAR ALMOST FIVE
THOUSAND OF THE THOSE WOMEN DIE
FROM THE DISEASE AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THANKS TO THE
AFFORDABLE CARE MILLIONS OF
WOMEN ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE
SCREENING MAMMOGRAMS. FOR
EMIGRATE ALL DECIDE IF THERE IS
A TISSUE IN FALL AND SO MANY
DOCTORS IF THEY SEE SOMETHING
ABNORMAL WILL REQUEST A MORE
DANCE TYPE OF SCREENING LIKE AN
MRI BUT UNFORTUNATELY ABOUT TEN
PER OF SAID ABOUT 60% OF MEMBERS
TO LEAD TO THE KIND OF BLOW UP
REQUEST. EVER BERMAN HE FOUND
PARKING CALL. RIGHT IMAGINE TO
BE PARTICULARLY HIGH AND CAL
RANGING FROM TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DOLLARS UP TO THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND FOR MANY
WOMEN WHO ARE ALREADY LIVING ON
THE EDGE FINANCIALLY THEY WILL
HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN PAYING
THE RENT THAT MONTH WE'RE
GETTING ONE OF THESE LOW. IMAGES
PRESS. EVER MY I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT EARLY DETECTION IS.
AND IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE DON'T GIVE REASON WOMEN A
REASON WHEN THEY'RE ALREADY IN A
VULNERABLE. RIGHT IN STATE OF
MIND. THESE I'M A SCREENING
TOOLS IF THEIR DOCTOR RICK
REQUESTED. SO THIS BILL WOULD-
AT A LIMITED COST SHARE
DEDUCTIBLES AND COPAYS FOR THE
SCREENING MAMMOGRAMS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY DIAGNOSTIC OR
SUPPLEMENTAL BREAST EXAMINATIONS
AND TESTS AND I WANT TO ALSO
NOTE THAT WE'RE NOT ALONE IN
THIS EFFORT- STORE LEGISLATION
IS BEEN PASSED IN ARKANSAS
COLORADO ILLINOIS LOUISIANA NEW
YORK AND- THIS. THEIR STATE
SIMILAR BILLS MOVING THROUGH
THERE JUST LATE LEGISLATURES AND
IN THE END THIS WILL SAVE MONEY
BECAUSE IT'S MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
TO TREAT ADVANCED BREAST CANCER
THAN TO TREATED WHEN IT IS.
EARLIER WITHOUT WOULD REQUEST AN%
AYE VOTE WE DO. SUPPORT SOMEONE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND TO MADAM
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
PLASTIC SURGEONS. THANK YOU
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I HELLO MY NAME IS A
KIMBERLY BUS I AM A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN WITH SUTTER HEALTH
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND I'M
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. TWENTY
FOUR I'M BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS AB TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
AS YOU HEARD REQUIRES- HEALTH
PLANS AND INSURANCE IS TO
PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR MEDICALLY
NECESSARY DIAGNOSTIC
SUPPLEMENTAL TESTS- FOR BREAST
CANCER SCREENING- IN ADDITION TO
BASS AND GRAMS. WITHOUT COST I'M
ONE PATIENTS IN OUR PRACTICE-
HAVE AN ABNORMALITY ON INITIAL
SCREENING MAMMOGRAM THEY- MAY
NOT COMPLETE THEIR WORK UP IF
THEIR OUT OF POCKET COSTS ARE
REALLY HIGH. ANY FREE 8560% OF
THE TIME OUR PATIENTS DO NEED A
FOLLOW UP TEST AND ULTRASOUNDS
BIOPSIES. MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
THROUGH THAT WE KNOW WHAT IT
FEELS LIKE- MRI ARE. CHOIR IS
PRETTY. THAT THE BILL IS PASSED
- WOMEN DIE FROM METASTATIC
BREAST CANCER YET IF DETECTED
EARLY BREAST CANCER AS A VERY
HIGH SURVIVAL RATE AND EARLY
DETECTION SAVES LIVES THE USUAL
WAY TO SCREEN FOR BREAST CANCER
MAMMOGRAPHY WHICH USUALLY HAS NO
COPAY BUT WHEN THESE FOLLOW UP
TESTS ARE REQUIRED THERE OFTEN
CAN BE A REALLY HOT JUST SHE
EXPLAINED AND A LOT OF WOMEN
WILL NOT GET THE TESTS OF COPPER
TO HIGH- ONCE. AGAIN BOND ALL
SPREAD IT BECOMES MORE DE AND
MORE EXPENSIVE TO TREAT. FOR
THIS REASON ARE THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
STRONGLY SUPPORTS AB TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK CHAIR MEMBERS TO
MADDEN REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY PLASTIC
SURGEONS THE AUTHOR DR BUS IN
THE ANALYSIS DO AN EXCELLENT JOB
IN OUTLINING THE BACKGROUND ON
THE NEED FOR FOLLOW UP PRESS
EXAM. AND THAT TO SERVE IT WITH
MS PLASTIC SURGEONS OF MORE SPUR
WITH ME I PATIENTS THAT THEY
HAVE TREATED FOR BREAST WE- AS A
OF HAVING. WERE PATIENT HAD
SCREENING PROGRAM WHICH AND
REQUIRE TO FOLLOW HIM. XAMPP IS
A PATIENT DID NOT PURSUE THE
FOLLOW UP EXAM LARGELY DUE TO
THE- OF THE FOLLOW UP EXAMS.
THESE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE IF
THE FATHER. HAD BEEN PERFORMED
THE CANCER WOULD HAVE BEEN
DETECTED IN TREATED AND
TREATMENT COULD HAVE STARTED
EARLIER. THIS WOULD HAVE AVOIDED
THE PAIN AND SUFFERING AND
SOMETIMES LOSS OF LIFE THIS
ASSOCIATED WITH LATE STAGE
BREAST CANCER. IN THESE
SITUATIONS IN THESE SITUATIONS
PATIENTS ARE MAKING DECISIONS ON
WHETHER THEY SHOULD PAY FOR A
FOLLOW UP EXAM. OR PAY FOR THE
RENT. OR PAY FOR FOOD TO FEED
THEIR FAMILY WE SHOULD NOT BE
PLACING WOMEN IN A PLACE TO BE
FORCED TO MAKE THIS TYPE OF.
POSITION REASONS WE- SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE COME HAD
BECOME FOR EXCUSE ME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR- AGAIN VERY WELL
INTENTIONED BILL MY COMMENTS-
DON'T DEVIATE MUCH FROM MY
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY THIS IS
INTENDED AND DESIGNED TO DO
THANK. YOU OVER KANNST WE HAVE
OF THE COST IMPLICATIONS THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THE TRAVERSE
ANALYSIS INDICATED THAT IT WOULD
HAVE A PREMIUM IMPACT FROM
FLOORS A FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. IN EMPLOYEE. HELLO TO
THE PROVISIONS IN THE BILL. WITH
THE MANDATE BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR- KEEPING IN
MIND WHAT CAN HAPPEN IN THE
AGGREGATE IF THE ALL PASSED
THROUGH IN THE CURRENT FORM THAT
THEY ARE THAT IS THE CONCERN
THEY DO- ADD UP QUICKLY BUT
AGAIN IT IS A WELL INTENTIONED
BILL IT IS- RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION IS REALLY SERVER
OPPOSED AB TWENTY TWENTY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE SO. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION. ON THE BILL. AN
ORGANIZATION TO REPRESENT ONE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBER THE
COMMITTEE DAVID GONZALES ABOUT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
I IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
. MEYER OF THE NORTH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA AND SPORT THANK YOU.
THE BUTLER CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
RADIOLOGISTS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. RIGHT SPENCER WITH AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBGYN IS JUST AT NINE
IN SPORT THANK YOU. HI THERE
SENATE NUDELMAN WITH BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE DOES ANYBODY ELSE OF BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. FIRST
THEY CAN RESIST- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORD AND- USE
STRUCK A NOTE WITH ME IS THIS IS
NOTHING AFTER YOU HAVE A
MAMMOGRAM AND THEY ASKED YOU TO
COME BACK. AND IF I HAD TO MAKE
THAT DECISION DIDN'T NOT TO BE
ABLE TO AFFORD TO COME BACK AND
BREAK MY HEART. BECAUSE I WANT
TO GET THINGS AND WHEN THOSE
CARE OF AND- MAKE SURE THAT I
HAVE THE BEST OF HEALTH CARE.
AND EVERYBODY CAN DO THAT. AND I
WOULD HATE TO BE IN THOSE SHOES
OR SOMEONE THAT COULDN'T DO
THAT- TO THE FIFTH THE SHOULDN'T
HAVE A QUESTION BECAUSE WE DO
NOT KNOW THE MAN WELL CAN GET
BREAST CANCER. MY NOT RIGHT.
YEAH THIS WOULD ALL. PERTAIN TO
THEM IF THEY NEED TO HAVE A
MAMMOGRAM OR IS A MAMMOGRAM I
MEAN THAT'S JUST ME- RATE. AN
MRI YEAH ENUMERATOR. HOW DO YOU
DO THAT YEAH SO LET ME JUST- TWO
POINTS TO THAT IT ACTUALLY DOES
APPLY TO MEN AS WELL AND- SO
APPLY TO WOMEN WHO ARE YOUNGER
OR OLDER THAN OUR TYPICAL
SCREENING- RECOMMENDATIONS AND-
AS MOSTOF YOU KNOW. THAT
CERTAIN PEOPLE PARTICULARLY
RISKS NEED TO SCREENING OUTSIDE
OF THE REGULAR TIME AND NEED TO
DO SCREENING OUTSIDE OF REGULAR
MAMMOGRAMS. SO SOMEBODY I KNOW
HAS A VERY STRONG FAMILY HISTORY
OF BREAST CANCER SO SHE GETS
MRI'S. NOT SPEAK MAMMOGRAMS AND
IF SHE WASN'T ABLE TO GET THAT
COPAY COVERED. THEN SHE WOULDN'T
BE ABLE TO GET THE NECESSARY
SCREEN TESTS DONE. SO ABSOLUTELY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND I YOU
KNOW JUST. SPEAKING TO THE
PERSON IN OPPOSITION. THAT WE
KNOW THAT THE COST OF. NEEDED
ACTION- WE- IS FAR LESS THAN THE
COST OF TREATING ADVANCED
CANCER. SO ULTIMATELY IN TERMS
OF THE BURDEN ON OUR PATIENTS
LIVES AND ON OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM THE STATE'S MONEY. EVERY
YEAR I GIVE MYSELF A BIRTHDAY
GIFT JUST LIKE A BIRTHDAY CARD
AND ON MY BIRTHDAY I GOING GET A
MAMMOGRAM. CLOCKWORK SINCE MY
MOTHER PASSED CAN'T. OKAY S.
KOREA. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO YOU
AND TO ALL OF US THAT HAVE HAD
THESE CONVERSATIONS- AB THREE
AUNTS- BE A LITTLE BIT MEDINA
MEDINA AND MY DENTAL SEAT. ALL
AGES. BEING THE OLD. AND THEY
ALL DECIDED SOME YEARS AGO TO GO
GET MAMMOGRAMS- WAS TOO LATE FOR
MY OF MY DEVELOPER WHO WAS THE
OLDEST OF THE THREE SISTERS.
THEY ALL HAD SOME FORM OF BREAST
CANCER. THEY ALL HAD DOUBLE
MASTECTOMIES. MIGHT BE A LITTLE
BIT LOST HER LIFE. MY IDEALISTIC
THE HER BREAST CANCER CAME AGAIN
. AND MY DEMARTINO MIGHT. THE
YOUNGEST SISTER WAS ABLE TO
DETECT IT EARLY BUT BECAUSE IT
WAS OF THEIR AGES. AND FROM A
LATINO FAMILY. IT IS OFTEN A
CONVERSATION THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
WITHIN OUR FAMILY SO THERE'S A
LOT OF EDUCATION THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN WITHIN. COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WITHIN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY THE LACK OF ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE RELIANT ON COMMUNITY
CLINICS FOR HEALTH CARE MOST OF
THE TIME IF YOUR MEDICAL
RECIPIENT. I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
HEALTHCARE THAT THEY HAD WITH
THEIR UNION THE TEAMSTERS. BUT
IT WASN'T- SOON ENOUGH IT WASN'T
DONE EARLY ENOUGH FOR- MIGHT BE
A LITTLE BIT THE ELDEST OF THE
THREE. AND UNFORTUNATELY SHE
LOST HER LIFE TO IT. BUT I'M
GLAD THAT AT LEAST THERE WAS
ACCESS AND THEY WERE ABLE TO
RETURN THEY WERE ABLE TO GET
ADDITIONAL CARE BUT WE ALL IN
SOME POINT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED BY
IT AND IT'S SOMETHING MY SISTERS
AND I THINK ABOUT OFTEN AND THE
REST OF- THE WOMEN IN MY FAMILY.
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FOR
BRING IN A VERY VALID POINT.
THAT BREAST CANCER IS SOMETHING
ALSO THAT. MEN CAN ALSO GET. AND
SO I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE MOVING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND I'M
THANKFUL FOR THOSE THAT ARE IN
SUPPORT AND I HOPE AGAIN. THAT
THE OPPOSITION. LUSATIAN THAT.
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A CONVERSATION
THAT TAKES PLACE IN THE
LEGISLATURE UNTIL WE ABSOLUTELY
HAVE. HEALTHCARE FOR ALL. AND
THE WHOLE OTHER CONVERSATION.
BUT WE START YOU KNOW WITH THIS
THAN WITH OTHER THINGS AND MOVE
IT ONE STEP AT A TIME AND I HOPE
THAT WE DO FIND SOME PLACE TO AT
THE END OF THE DAY PROVIDE
EQUITY AND ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS CARILLO. ANYBODY ELSE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS. WE COULD USE
A MOTION AND- OKAY WAIT OKAY
THERE WE GO WE GOT A MOTION AND
A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO SECOND
BY MISTAKE. I JUST COMMENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH A MYSTERY
REFERRING IN THIS BILL- I LOOK
AT THIS IN MANY WAYS AS A AS
PREVENTIVE I MEAN IT ISN'T THE
PRIMARY SCREEN BUT IT'S
ADDITIONAL SCREENING AND- WHEN I
LOOK AT THAT RIGHT THINK ABOUT
THAT. THE VALUE OF THAT FOR THE
LIFE OF THE PERSON INVOLVED-
ACTUALLY EAT. FISH DINNER
REDUCING THE COSTS OF HEALTH. OF
OVER ALL. I SOMETIMES WHAT IF
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION IS PENNY
WISE AND POUND FOOLISH- WHEN
YOU'RE- OUT ITS- NOT A HUGE
IMPACT I DO RECOGNIZE THAT THE
WITH THAT THE BILL'S ARE THAT
OUR MANDATES DO I COME RETIRE AT
BUT ALL ALL THINGS CONSIDERED
THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND I
APPRECIATE BRINGING IT FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DO HAVE A
QUESTION A SECOND WHICH I CLOSE
I TO SAY THAT I HAD NEVER HAD
AMERICA- ABOUT IT. WE'RE MADE
IT. IMPOSSIBLE TO IGNORE.
BECAUSE I WAS IN MY THIRTIES I
WAS TOO YOUNG FOR REGULAR
SCHEDULED MAMMOGRAMS. AND I WAS
LUCKY IN THAT. THE TREATMENT
THAT I HAD WERE YOU KNOW WORKED.
BECAUSE MEDICAL SCIENCE. I'M MY
SISTER IMMEDIATELY WAS GIVEN A
COUPLE WAS GIVEN A YEARLY MRI
SCREENING- BECAUSE OF THAT RISK
AND BECAUSE OF THE- CENSUS OF
HER TISSUE. SURE ENOUGH FOUR
YEARS LATER SHE ALSO WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH BREAST CANCER
WHICH WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN FOUND
ON A REGULAR MAMMOGRAM IT.
TOMORROW DETAIL. VERY EARLY. SO
I THINK THAT THIS WILL SAVE
LIVES AND I APPRECIATE YOUR AYE
VOTE IN YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISS FRIEDMAN- THAT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHEN I WOULD I WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE ARAMBULA. BIGELOW. CARILLO I
FLORA FLORA NOT VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES. MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I REQUEST RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE GARCIA. THE BILL HAS EIGHT
VOTES AT BILLS OUT- AND THAT
JUST TO CLARIFY THE MOTION WAS
FROM- THIS CARILLO SECOND
PREMISE AGUIAR-CURRY IT WAS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO PREPARATION
SO THEY GIVE YOU HAVE ANOTHER
BILL YES AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
ONE- WE HAVE HAD HEARD A LOT
OVER THE LAST IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS ABOUT P. FOSS- THESE DAYS
FIRST CLASS PERSON COME THAT ARE
. IN OUR WHAT. PLACES THEY ARE.
PENSION SURPRISING ENOUGH IS.
CARE PRODUCTS. MAKE UP. SKIN
CARE- HAIR IS SUPPLIES YOU'RE
SMEARING IT ON YOUR FACE IF YOU
PUT ON A SKIN CREAMS OFTEN. AND
UGH THESE PRODUCTS SHED P. FOSS
NOT ONLY EXPOSING HUMAN BEINGS
BUT AGAIN WHEN YOU WASH YOUR
FACE GOING INTO THE WATER
SUPPLY. AND WE KNOW THAT THESE
CHEMICALS HAVE ADVERSE HEALTH
EFFECTS AND ARE A HUGE SOURCE OF
CONCERN AS AN EMERGING
CONTAMINANT FOR WATER SUPPLIERS
AND- MANY FACTORS I DO ADD. HE
FOSS INTENTIONALLY TO PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS. AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THEY ARE NOT ESSENTIAL THAT
THERE ARE PRODUCTS THAT ARE MADE
WITHOUT THESE THAT ARE PERFECTLY
GOOD. A RESTRICTION ON THE SALE
OF PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
CONTAINING INTENTIONALLY OUT OF
PEOPLE US IS THE ONLY WAY TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO PRODUCTS. THAT DO NOT
PRESENT A DIRE RISK TO THEIR OWN
HEALTH AND TO THE ENVIRONMENT.
IT IS BILL. ONLY OUT. ST TO FIND
OUT IF THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
COMPLY. WITH THE EFFORTS TO BAN
P. FOSS. AND I HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEM VERY CLOSELY ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND WILL CONTINUE TO
MEET WITH THEM TO ADDRESS ANY
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE. BUT
THEY SEEM TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS AND THE
NECESSITY OF IT- WE- I BOUGHT A
CALIFORNIA EXPECTED IF THEY'RE
GONNA BUY SOMETHING ON THE
SHELVES AND A CALIFORNIA STORE
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE SAFE FOR
THEM AND THEIR FAMILY AND THIS
BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY ONE IT'S
JANET NUDELMAN DIRECTOR OF
PROGRAM AND POLICY WITH BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS. AND
ANY JACKSON A CO FOUNDER AND THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT CREDO
BEAUTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JANET
NUDELMAN I'M THE SENIOR DIRECTOR
OF PROGRAM AND POLICY AT BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS. I AM
SO USED TO BE TESTIFYING TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY ONE ON BEHALF OF THE CPP
AND BILLS OTHER TO CO SPONSORS
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
INTEREST RESEARCH GROUP AS WELL
AS THE SIXTY LEADING NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND BUSINESSES
THAT SUPPORT IT. CONCERNS ARE
MOUNTING WORLDWIDE ABOUT THE
TOXICITY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PERSISTENCE OF P. FIVE
CHEMICALS. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALREADY PROHIBITED THE ENTIRE
CLASS OF P. FAST FROM BEING USED
IN FIREFIGHTING FOAM FOOD
PACKAGING IN JUVENILE PRODUCTS
YET THERE IS NO STATE OR FEDERAL
LAW THAT PROHIBITS THE USE OF
THESE VRY TOXIC FOREVER
CHEMICALS. FROM COSMETIC
PRODUCTS THIS IS A PROBLEM
BECAUSE A RECENT STUDY CONDUCTED
BY THE UNIVERSITY OF NOTRE DAME
FOUND HIGH AMOUNTS OF P.
FASTENED OVER HALF OF THE BEAUTY
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS THEY
TESTED. HOWEVER EQUALLY
CONCERNING IS TE FACT THAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE P. FAST DETECTED
IT BY THE STUDY DIDN'T EVEN
APPEAR ON THE PRACTICALLY OF THE
PRODUCTS THAT WERE TESTED.
CREATING A BUYER BEWARE
SITUATION. TO ASSEMBLY. IS A
PUBLIC PROBLEM. THESE LOCALS
HAVE ALSO. THE DRINKING OF OVER
SEVENTY MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
VERY LOW DOSES OF PEETHAS
CHEMICALS IN DRINKING WATER HAVE
BEEN LINKED TO AN INCREASED RISK
OF CANCER REPRODUCTIVE AND
INSISTED PART. AND LET AND FIERY
DISEASE AND P. FAST EXPOSURE IS
ALSO LINKED TO ELEVATED RISK OF
BREAST CANCER HORMONE DISRUPTION
AND OTHER SERIOUS HEALTH CAN.
THIS WELL. CAN HIM CALIFORNIA
CAN WATER HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
JUST. IMPACT ALREADY BURDENED
COMMUNITIES BY MULTIPLE SOURCES
OF POLLUTION AND BY OTHER
FACTORS THAT MAKE THEM EVEN MORE
SENSITIVE TO POLLUTION. IN THESE
OWNERS KEEP A GREATER RISK OF
HARM FROM P. FAST EXPOSURE.
ELIMINATING P. FAST FROM
COSMETIC PRODUCTS WILL REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF P. FAST THE
FLUSHES DOWN THE DRAIN AFTER WE
BATES THAT WATER AND SANITATION
AGENCIES HAVE TO MANAGE AND
REMOVE. EVEN THE VERY SERIOUS
IMPACT P. FATS CHEMICALS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT CHEMICAL SHOULD NOT
BE IN THE BEAUTY AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS YOU EVERY DAY.
THING AND NOT PRICES. THANK EXT
CALIFORNIA ONCE HOW THE
OPPORTUNITY LEAD THE WAY IN
TERMS OF COSMETIC SAFETY I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK
YOU- AND MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
ANNE JACKSON CO FOUNDER AND CEO-
ACT CREDO. CREDO IS THE LARGEST
RETAILER OF CLEAN BEAUTY
PRODUCTS IN THE WORLD SELLING
OVER ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
INDEPENDENT BEAUTY BRANDS
THROUGH OUR BRICK AND MORTAR
STORES AND WEBSITE. AND WE ARE
HEADQUARTERED IN ST SCOUT. IT IS
ARTWORK CITING SAFETY AND
SUSTAINABILITY STANDARDS CREDO
IS CONSIDERED A LEADER IN THE
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR CLEAN
COSMETICS INDUSTRY. CREDO
INTERBRAND HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO CREATE THE SAFER MORE
SUSTAINABLE BEAUTY AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS THAT AMERICANS ARE
ASKING FOR. WE PROHIBIT BRANDS
FROM INTENTIONALLY ADDING P.
FOSS IN THE PRODUCTS THAT WE
SELL AND SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN
THE ENTIRE CLASS OF P. FIVE S.
AS BEEN ON CREATORS RESTRICTED
SUBSTANCE LIST OF CHEMICALS.
SOME PRODUCT FOR FORMULATORS
THESE ARE THE CAMERAS TO MAKE
THE SKIN CARE AND BEAUTY
PRODUCTS THAT WE ALL USE
INTENTIONALLY ADD P. FAST AS
LISTED INGREDIENTS. OTHER TIMES
P. FOSTER USED AT ASSESSING AIDS
COATINGS OR TREATMENTS TO HELP
WITH AN INGREDIENT OR
PACKAGING'S PERFORMANCE. BUT
THESE TRACE OR INCIDENTAL
INGREDIENTS DO NOT HAVE TO BE
DECLARED TO BRANDS OR RETAILERS
LET ALONE REMARKS. SO IN SOME
INSTANCES HE LAST MAY BE
DETECTED IN A COSMETIC PRODUCT
NOT BECAUSE THE SKIN CARE BEAUTY
BRAND WANTED IT THERE AS PART OF
ITS RECIPE. BUT BECAUSE IT WAS
ADDED SOMEWHERE A LOT BECAUSE
NEXT APPLY CHAIN OFTEN WITHOUT
THE KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT OF THE
BRAND OWNER. SO CREDO AND OUR
BRAND PARTNERS TELL EVERYONE UP
AND DOWN OUR SUPPLY CHAIN THAT
WE DO NOT WANT P. FILES TO BE
USED. BUT LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
ABOUT WHO HOW AND WHERE P.
FOSTER INTENTIONALLY ADDED AS
PROCESSING MANUFACTURING AIDS.
MAKES IT VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE
FOR INDEPENDENT BEAUTY PART OF
CONFIDENCE THAT THE PRODUCT THEY
MAY. SELL DO NOT CONTAIN THE
TOXIC CHEMICAL. THIS IS EXACTLY
WHY THIS BELT SO THE CLEANING.
WE DO NOT WANT ANY P. FAST THAT
CAN POSSIBLY BE AVOIDED AND ANY
OF OUR PRODUCTS. RESHAPED
ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S FRIEDMAN PLAN
TO WORK WITH THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO FLUSH OUT THE
DEFINITION OF INTENTIONALLY
ADDED P. FOSTER AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN ONE IT'S CLEAR AS TO WHAT
IS. AND WHAT IS NOT CONTENT ARE
CONSIDERED INTENSELY ADDED A
STRONG DEFINITION OF
INTENTIONALLY ADDED P. FAST WILL
HELP OSMETIC MANUFACTURERS
RETAILERS LIKE CREDO AND HOLD
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN ACCOUNTABLE.
BEAUTY INDUSTRY IN CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO MAKE THEIR P. FOSS ARE
NOT WELCOME HERE AND AB TWO
SEVEN SEVEN ONCE A CRITICAL STEP
IN THIS FIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PLEASE COME
FORWARD YEAH THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON A GERMAN WOULD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MANDY LEE I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
COUNCIL WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON AB TWO SEVEN
SEVEN ONE A BILL TO BAN P. FOSS
IN COSMETICS. IN CONCEPT WE
SUPPORT THE PHASE OUT OF BOSTON
COSMETICS AND CARE PRODUCTS IN
FACT WE AGREE WITH 90% OF THE
BILL HOWEVER THE BILL CONTINUES
TO LACK CLARITY AND THEN THE
GUARDRAILS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE BEING INTENTIONALLY
ADDED P. FOSSE'S. AVOID TRACE
CONTEMPT. QUITE PLEASE IN AS IT
ANALYSIS NOTES- VIRTUALLY
EVERYWHERE THE TRIP UP
COMPLIANCE WITH THE BILL FOR
INSTANCE THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
DEFINED WOULD CAPTURE FLUORIDES
LIKE TFA WHICH ARE ALREADY FOUND
IN THE WATER SUPPLY SOILS CLAYS
COMPANIES USED WATER WHICH IS
ONE OF THE SINGLE MOST COMMON
INGREDIENTS IN COSMETICS THERE
MAY BE TECHNICALLY UNDERWENT A
TRAIT LEVEL IT AND THAT GET INTO
PRODUCTS. THIS BILL MUSKER
BIGELOW P. FIVE REYES LEVELS AND
ENSURE THAT WE ARE BANNING
INTENTIONALLY ADDED P. FAST IN
GROUP AND AT RATHER THAN
INGREDIENTS WITH TRACES. THIS
PRINCIPLE WAS ADOPTED IN TWENTY
TWENTY. AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
MURATSUCHI WHICH BANNED SEVERAL
INTENTIONALLY ADDED INGREDIENTS
AND CONTAIN LANGUAGE THAT WAS
CLEAR THAT TECHNICALLY
UNAVOIDABLE TRACE CONTAMINANTS
WERE NOT IN SCOPE. PC PC IN A
WIDER GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS
STRONGLY SUPPORTED THIS EFFORT-
THIS WAS APPROVED BY THIS BODY
THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED INTO
LAW BY THE GOVERNOR. WE HAVE HAD
SEVERAL PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING CAN
CONTINUE CONTINUING TO DO SO USE
ME. BUT UNTIL OUR OUR CONCERNS
ARE WORK THROUGH WE I
RESPECTFULLY REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMEND. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- CHRISTOPHER
FEDERALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS TO ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT TOLD CONSUMER PRODUCTS
AND BUSINESSES ACROSS THE SUPPLY
CHAIN INCLUDING AEROSOLS IN
ADDITION TO THE CONCERNS OF THE
MEMBERS LAID OUT BY MANUALLY I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD THAT BROWN.
FINISHED FOST. WHEN WE REMOVE
WHAT ARE CALLED HFO IS FROM THE
COSMETICS MARKET IF YOUR PHOTOS
ARE USED AS AEROSOL PROPELLANTS.
H. OPPOSE HAVE EMERGED AS THE
NEXT GENERATION AEROSOL
PROPELLANT AT THE U. S. EPA HAS
DEEMED ACCEPTABLE AS IT RELATES
TO HUMAN HEALTH. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. H. YOUR FOES HAVE A
VERY LOW GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL AND REDUCE GROUND
LEVEL OZONE FORMATION. GIVING
THEM AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
REACHING CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS. HFO AEROSOL
PROPELLANTS ARE VITAL FOR
MANUFACTURERS TO HAVE IT
AVAILABLE FOR COMPLIANCE COMING
LOWER V. THIS IS. CARP WHEN WE
TO ABOUT FOREVER WE TALK ABOUT
HOW THEY ARE PERSISTENT BIO
ACCUMULATIVE- AND FOR THE
PURPOSES OF THIS BILL IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE TALK BIG WE'LL TALK
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
TOXIC HFO THERE NONE OF THOSE
THE CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH HAZARD
ASSESSMENT REVIEWED HFO ONE TWO
THREE FOUR ZERO P. AND DEEMED IT
SAFE HUMAN HEALTH. AND THE
ENVIRONMENT ALLOWING CARP THE
LISTED AS AN EXEMPT BOC. THE .
S. IS WORKING DEFINITION FOR
THEIR P. FOSS REPORTING RULE
ESTABLISHED IN THE BY
DEMONSTRATION. DOES NOT INCLUDE
H. OF FOES IN THE EPA'S MASTER
LIST OF NINE THOUSAND P. FIVE
SUBSTANCES DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
HFO ONE TWO THREE FOUR. Z. E.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AMENDMENT
TO ALLOW THE USE OF H. OF FOLKS
THEY WILL PLAY AN IMPORTANT ROLE
IN ACHIEVING CALIFORNIA'S
OVERALL CLIMATE AMBITIONS. AND
PROVIDING SAFE PRODUCTS TO
CONSUMERS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSORS IN THE
COMMITTEE IN HOPES OF ADDRESSING
THESE CONCERNS- HOWEVER WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THIS TIME
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME- POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE PLEASE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROXANNE GOLD WITH A VOICE FOR
CHOICE ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
ELAINE ORTIZ ON BEHALF OF CLEAN
WATER ACTION CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL ACTION
FUND AND CALPERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HELLO KAYLA ROBINSON
REGISTERING SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES
ADVOCATING FOR CHEMICALS AND
TOXIC SAFETY SPROUT SAN
FRANCISCO AND BREAST CANCER OVER
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PERSONAL COULD ALSO E HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND THE NATIONAL ACTION
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SUSAN LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP
ANOTHER CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON ROSIE THOMPSON WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. RIGHT SPENCER
WITH AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
IS DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. PRESTIA FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CURRENTLY POSING WITH SOME AND-
THANK YOU. TIM JESTING WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
CURRENTLY OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. DEAN TALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION RESPECTIVOS LESS MAD
THANK YOU THANK YOU. RADHA PATEL
WITH CALPERS STUDENTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THE ONE ELSE THE
KNOWN BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THE ART.
THERE'S NO MOTION YET. MOTIONS
OKAY SECOND ANY. I WILL SECOND
THE BILL- FEEDBACK IT DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THAT'S
DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS- WHICH I
CLOSE MISTREATED I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH INDUSTRY ON THE
DEFINITION OF INTENTIONAL- BUT
IT REALLY SAYS SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN'T EVEN FIND WATER THAT'S NOT
CONTAMINATED WITH THE SUBSTANCE
WAS ATTEMPTING BECAUSE IT SHOWS
IMPORT OF THIS WHAT. ANOTHER
LEGISLATION LIKE IT AND I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT IT'S SUPPOSE THAT
WAS REFERENCED BY THE GENTLEMAN.
I'M EVEN THOUGH THEY THEMSELVES
MAY HAVE BEEN DETERMINED TO BE
SAFE BY SOME OF THESE THEY TURN
INTO A DIFFERENT CHEMICAL CALLED
TFA WHICH DOES HAVE HAVE HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS.
THESE ARE NOT WIDELY USED RIGHT
NOW IN COSMETICS AND I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL
GIVEN THE HISTORY THAT WE HAVE
OF INTRODUCING THESE CHEMICALS
INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
PARTICULARLY IN SOMETHING THAT
YOUR SPRING. ID THAT LATER ON
TURNED OUT TO. BE SO DEVASTATING
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT AND I ALSO
HAVE TO SAY THAT I ALWAYS
WONDERED WHETHER IT WAS ONE OF
THESE KINDS OF CHEMICALS THAT
CAUSED MY CANCER AND MY SISTER'S
CANCER. THAT I. VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MAN SECTOR
IS CALDERON. WOOD I WOULD I
WALDRON. AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
BIGELOW YOU. LAURA LAURA NO
MAIENSCHEIN. MAYES MAYES NOT
VOTING MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO. GARCIA GOOD ONE. OKAY
WELL HE'S OR SHE'S ALREADY GOT
WELL THAT WAS QUICK OKAY ANYWAY
I WILL LEAVE THE BILL HANCOCK.
THIS BONTA YOU ARE UP. IF TWO
BILLS BEFORE. AB. TWENTY NINETY
ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR TIME
AND WORKING ON THIS BILL IN THE
PAST YEAR MULTIPLE STATES HAVE
RAMPED UP THEIR ANTI ABORTION
EFFORTS AND PASSED LAWS
TARGETING OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO ABORTION LAST YEAR
ALONE A HUNDRED AND EIGHT
ABORTION RESTRICTIONS WERE
ENACTED IN NINETEEN. THIS
INCLUDES TAXES WHERE THE MOST
RECENT ANTI ABORTION LAW
ENCOURAGES PRIVATE CITIZENS. TO
ACT AS BOUNTY HUNTERS TO SEEK
OUT AND SUE THOSE PROVIDE ANY
FORM OF SUPPORT TO. TO PEOPLE
SEEKING AN ABORTION INCLUDING
THEIR DOCTOR THEIR NURSE A
FRIEND TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT
WHETHER TO GET THE ABORTION EVEN
THAT WEBER DRIVER. WITH THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
LATER OVERTURNED THE PROTECTIONS
GRANTED. UNDER ROE V. WADE IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE HAVE IMPROVED
ABORTION ACCESS AND STRENGTHEN
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS FOR THOSE
SEEKING. INSTEAD OF SERVICES
PEOPLE ALREADY ARE WELL ARE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO COME TO
CALIFORNIA FREE ACT OF HEALTH
CARE. HOWEVER WE WORRY THAT ARE
OUT OF STATE PRIVATE CITIZENS
AND ACTORS WILL DEMAND THE
MEDICAL RECORDS OF THOSE WHO SEE
CARE HERE. TO PUNISH THEM FOR
EXERCISING THEIR FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. NO ONE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MINUTES MINUTE
CALIFORNIA'S LEGAL TEAM TO GET
WHICH PEOPLE WHO SEEK AND REFUGE
HERE. MY BILL A NEW NINETY ONE
WILL ENSURE OUT OF STATE
SUBPOENA. WHICH SEEK INFORMATION
RELATED TO A PATIENT WHO
RECEIVED GROUP REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE NOT GRANTED BY DOING THIS
CALIFORNIA WILL PROTECT THE
MEDICAL PRIVACY OF THOSE
PATIENTS WHO MAY BE TARGETED BY
HOSTILE LAWS IN OTHER STATES. AB
TWENTY NINETY ONE ALSO ENSURES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
CAN ENFORCE VIOLATIONS. OF THE
RELEASE OF MEDICAL RECORDS
RELATED TO SENSITIVE SERVICES.
AB TWENTY NINE CAN. BE NINETY
ONE CAN. LEGISLATORS WORK OF
PROTECTING PRIVACY AND
CONFIDENTIALITY OF LGBTQ PLUS
PEOPLE AND THEIR MEDICAL
INFORMATION THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY IS DIRECTLY IMPACTED
BY LAWS. THAT UNDERMINE ABORTION
CARE WHICH COMPOUNDS
LONGSTANDING BARRIERS INCLUDES
CARE. EXACERBATES NEGATIVE
HEALTH DISPARITIES. CALIFORNIA
MUST PROACTIVELY PROTECTING THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF MEDICAL
RECORDS OF EVERYONE. AS WE
STATES AROUND THE COUNTRY PAVING
THE WAY TO USE THOSE WRECKED
ENFORCE THEIR OWN STATES. ANTI
ABORTION. THANK YOU AND IS
WITNESS TODAY I HAVE SOME OF. MY
SPUR WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA A CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH DOCTOR
WERE A MEMBERS OF THE- I'M LISA
MATSUBARA ON BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
SEVEN AFFILIATES IN THE STATE
OPERATING OVER A HUNDRED HEALTH
CENTER. HE CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTIONS UNDER ROE V. WADE
ARE NO LONGER ENSURING ACCESS TO
ABORTION ACROSS THE NATION. EVEN
AS THE US SUPREME COURT
CONSIDERS A DIRECT CHALLENGE TO
ROE THE COURT HAS ALREADY UPHELD
TEXAS SENATE BILL EIGHT. IN ITS
DELIBERATE LEGAL SCHEME TO
CIRCUMVENT JUDICIAL REVIEW OF AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL LAW. ALLOWING
TEXAS TO RELY ON PRIVATE
CITIZENS CIVIL LAWSUITS TO TAKE
PEOPLE'S CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
THE TEXAS ABORTION BAN HAS BEEN
IN EFFECT FOR THE PAST EIGHT
MONTHS. AT THE SAME TIME ANTI
ABORTION LAWMAKERS HAVE
INTRODUCED OVER FIVE HUNDRED
RESTRICTIONS IN FORTY TWO STATES
SO FAR THIS YEAR. WITH ABORTION
BANS BEING RECENTLY ENACTED IN
ARIZONA. IDAHO WYOMING FLORIDA
KENTUCKY AND OKLAHOMA. THESE
BANDS CREATE A CULTURE OF FEAR
AND AIM TO MAKE PATIENTS CARE TO
SEE CARE OR CLINICIANS TO
PROVIDE THE CARE. THE RECENT LY
ENACTED BILL IN OKLAHOMA WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE THE PROVISION OF
ABORTION A FELONY. IN OTHER
STATES LIKE MISSOURI LAWMAKERS
ARE ATTEMPTING TO BAN RESIDENTS
FROM LEAVING THE STATE TO OBTAIN
AN ABORTION. IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS OVER
THIRTY SIX MILLION PEOPLE FOLKS
IN OVER HOW STATES WILL LOSE
ACCESS TO ABORTION IN OUR HOME
STATE. THESE BANDS DENY PEOPLE
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE HARM
PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY FACING
SYSTEM. THE HEALTH SYSTEM AND
PEOPLE TO FLEE THEIR HOMES
STATES TO GET THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED AND DESERVE. WE'RE PROUD OF
THE WORK THAT THIS STATE AND
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS DONE AND IS
DOING TO ENSURE ABORTION ACCESS
IN CALIFORNIA. MUST BE MORE. FOR
PLANNED PARENTHOOD PROTECTING
PATIENT CONFIDENTIALITY IS AT
THE CORE OF THE SERVICES
PROVIDED BY OUR AFFILIATES. A
PATIENT'S MEDICAL RECORDS SHOULD
NEVER BE USED TO PUNISH SOMEONE
FOR OBTAINING AN ABORTION. A
RIGHT THAT IS EXPLICITLY
PROTECTED UNDER OUR STATE LAWS.
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE ESTABLISHES
SAFEGUARDS IN THE LAW TO PROTECT
THE MEDICAL RECORDS OF ABORTION
PATIENTS. THAT THIS INFORMATION
IS NOT USED AS EVIDENCE IN AND
OUT OF STATE CASE TO PENALIZE
THE PATIENT WHO SEEKS CARE IN
OUR STATE. AND WOULD SIMILARLY
PROTECT THOSE WHO PROVIDE
ABORTIONS OR ASSIST. TO SEE
KAREN CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT CALIFORNIA CAN BE A SAFE
HAVEN FOR THOSE WHO SEEK THE
ABORTION CARE IN OUR STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON THERESA BRENNAN
PRESIDENT OF THE RIGHT TO LIFE
LEAGUE. THIS BILL IS A COMPANION
PIECE TO AB ONE SIX SIX SIX LIKE
THAT BILL AB TWENTY NINETY ONE
IMPERMISSIBLY DECLARES ANOTHER
STATE SUBPOENA AND JUDICIAL
ORDERS NULL AND VOID. AB TWO
ZERO NINE ONE VIOLATES THE FULL
FAITH AND CREDIT CLAUSE OF THE
U. S. CONSTITUTION WHICH STATES
FULL FAITH AND CREDIT SHALL BE
GIVEN IN EACH STATE TO THE
PUBLIC ACTS RECORDS AND JUDICIAL
PROCEEDINGS OF EVERY OTHER
STATE. WHETHER THIS BILL WILL
FALL UNDER THE PUBLIC POLICY
EXCEPTION OR WHETHER IT WILL BE
FOUND UNCONSTITUTIONAL REMAINS
TO BE SEEN IT WILL BE DECIDED IN
THE COURTS. EITHER WAY AB TWO
ZERO NINE ONE IS DANGEROUS
BECAUSE IT DECLARES ANOTHER
STATE'S COURT ORDERS TO HAVE NO
EFFECT WITH WARNING ENFORCEMENT
OF FOREIGN LAWS. FOR THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSE AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONES. MR NAME POSITION ON
THE BILL AN ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE PLEASE. ISABEL ARE
QUITE ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA IN THE
CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GENESIS GONZALEZ ON BEHALF
OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LENNY
CLOCK IS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRENT SPENCER MERRITT COLLEGE
OBGYN IS TO CHECK NINE SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY ROBSON WITH
PEAPACK OBVIOUSLY IN SUPPORT
ALSO ASKED TO ISSUE US SUPPORT
FOR THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
KATHY MUSBURGER CENTER ACCESS
HEALTH IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FROM I ASKED HER ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE BUT I'M THE
ONLY ONE HERE AND I DON'T HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS. AND THAT'S A
PROBLEM BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY TO MAKE A MOTION EITHER. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE IN THE
IN THE MEANTIME. AT AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE IS A NECESSARY BILL
NEEDED TO COMBAT THE WAVE OF
ABORTION RESTRICTIONS BEING
ENACTED ACROSS THE COUNTRY THIS
BILL PROTECTS EVERY PERSON'S
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO MAKE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH DECISIONS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE BILL DOES ENJOY THE PAST
RECORD ATION THE MOTION WILL BE
DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS WE'RE
GONNA WAIT FOR A MINUTE TO HAVE
SOME MEMBERS COME BACK SO. THANK
YOU. PLEASE DON'T LEAVE. YOU CAN
PRESENT A RATHER BUILD UP AND
GIVE.
THIS VOTE MOVING AB TWENTY
NINETY ONE- SECOND BY ME. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON AB TWENTY NINETY ONE TO PASS
THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WHAT I WHAT I
WALDRON AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BIGELOW CARILLO. I FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO GARCIA. ZERO YOU HAVE
TO VOTES WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE MISSING OBVIOUSLY SO THEY
CAN GET YOUR- OUR NEXT YOUR NEXT
BILL AB TWENTY NINE OH FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. I WOUL LIKE TO
START BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS REDUCING THE SEVEN
YEAR EXTENSION DOWN TO TWO
YEARS. AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. AS
A MATTER. TWENTY NINE OF. THE
BILL PROVIDING A TWO YEAR
EXTENSION TO ALAMEDA HOSPITAL
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE'S
TWENTY THIRTY SEISMIC STATE
SAFETY STANDARDS. AND WOULD
PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY FOR A
SPECIFIC WING OF THE HOSPITAL.
ALAMEDA HOSPITAL IS THE ONLY
ACUTE CARE FACILITY ON THE
ISLAND OF ALAMEDA. AND THE
HOSPITAL FACES UNIQUE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES IN MEETING THE TWENTY
THIRTY SEISMIC SAFETY STANDARDS.
A LIMITING TAX ON PATIENTS THERE
IS AN ONGOING OPERATIONS. MOST
RECENTLY ALAMEDA HOSPITAL
COMPLETED A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR. RENOVATION TO BRING THE
HOSPITAL INTO FULL COMPLIANCE
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY. SEISMIC
SAFETY STANDARDS HOWEVER ALAMEDA
HOSPITAL PROJECTS AT TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS IS TAG. ASSOCIATED WITH
EVEN THE STATE'S TWENTY THIRTY.
SEISMIC SAFETY STANDARDS WHICH
WOULD BE NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO BE
UNDER THE ANTI TIME. FINANCE
STRUCTURE POSSIBLE. THE PASS.
TWO YEARS ALAMEDA IT'LL AS BEEN
EXPLORING PLANNING HOW TO COMPLY
WITH THE TWENTY THIRTY SEISMIC
SAFETY DEADLINES INCLUDING
EVALUATING REPLACING BUILDINGS
AND PASSING A LOCAL BOND MEASURE
BUT HAS CONCLUDED THAT NO MATTER
HOW THEY CAN COME INTO
COMPLIANCE. THEY NEED MORE TIME.
THIS IS ONLY A SAFETY NET
HOSPITAL THIS IS THE ONLY SAFETY
NET HOSPITAL ON THE ISLAND WITH
OVER SEVENTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS
AND IT IS A CRITICAL LIFELINE
FOR ALAMEDA IS HEALTH AND WELL
BEING. THANK YOU AT WITNESSES ME
TOO EIGHT I HAVE MIKE WILLIAMS
PRESIDENT OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT BOARD AND
DEBBIE STEPHENS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ALAMEDA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. Q. GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON. SURE WOULD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I MIKE
WILLIAMS I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
CITY OUT OF ALAMEDA HEALTH CARE
DISTRICT ELECTED BOARD MEMBER
AND ALSO A DIVISION CHIEF FOR
THE CITY OF ALAMEDA FIRE
DEPARTMENT. ALAMEDA IS A
COMMITTEE OF SEVENTY THOUSAND
LOCATED ON THE ISLAND. ON
IRELAND CONNECTED TO A OAKLAND
BY THE POSEY AND WEBSTER TWO AND
THREE DID BRIDGES. THE CAPTAINS
WERE ALL CONSTRUCTED IN THE
EARLY TO MID NINETEEN HUNDREDS
MAKING THE RISK OF BEING
ISOLATED FROM OTHER EAST BAY
COMMUNITIES AFTER A MAJOR
SEISMIC EVENT OR OTHER EMERGENCY
. ALAMEDA IS ALSO A GROWING
RESIDENTIAL COMMUNITY HELLO
CALIFORNIA- AND GROWING
BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY IN LIFE
SCIENCE IN LIGHT INDUSTRIAL
INDUSTRIES. THESE BUSINESSES OF
ADDED THOUSANDS OF NEW EMPLOYEES
WHO WORK ON THE ISLAND OF
ALAMEDA. IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS
IT'S PROJECTED THAT FIVE
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL RESIDENTIAL
UNITS WILL BE DEVELOPED. AND
WILL BE OCCUPIED BY AN
ADDITIONAL TEN THOUSAND
RESIDENTS. ALAMEDA IS A
CURRENTLY A CURRENTLY LICENSED
FOR SIX ONLY HOSPITALS CURRENTLY
LICENSED FOR SIXTY SIX ACUTE
BEDS A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE
SKILLED NURSING SUBACUTE BEDS.
THE LONG TERM BEDS ARE ALMOST
ALWAYS AT 95% CAPACITY THERE'S A
VITAL RESOURCE FOR POST ACUTE
CARE. FOR THE ENTIRE EAST BAY.
THE HOSPITAL ALSO OPERATES YOU
SEE DEPARTMENT AND A CERTIFIED
STROKE PROGRAM. ALAMEDA HOSPITAL
ALSO IS A LARGE THE THIRD
LARGEST EMPLOYER IN THE CITY OF
ALAMEDA EMPLOYING OVER SIX
HUNDRED PEOPLE IN LIVING WAGE
CAREERS. IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
SALOMON'S IT OUT THE RESIDENTS%
OF ALAMEDA APPROVED THE
CONVERSION OF ALAMEDA HOSPITAL
FROM A FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE
CORPORATION TO DISTRICT HOSPITAL
AND APPROVED A TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT DOLLAR PER
HOUSEHOLD PARCEL TAX. WHICH
CONTINUES IN PERPETUITY AS LONG
AS THE EMERGENCY ROOM AND THE
QUEUE CARE SERVICES CONTINUE AT
ALAMEDA HOSPITAL. THE DISTRICT
IS COVERED BY FIVE- ELECTED
BOARD MEMBERS AND THE PARCEL TAX
PROVIDES CLOSE TO SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL REVENUE
HOSPITAL OPERATIONS IS SMALL BUT
VITAL PART OF THE TOTAL HOSPITAL
REVENUE. IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THE DISTRICT ENTERED
INTO A JOINT POWERS AGREEMENT
WITH ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEMS.
UNDER THE AGREEMENT ALAMEDA
HEALTH ALAMEDA HEALTH SYSTEMS
TOOK OVER THE LICENSE AND
OPERATION OF A HOME IN A
HOSPITAL. AND IN TURN THE
DISTRICT NOW RETAINS THE ROLE
COLLECTING THE PARCEL TAX IN
ENSURING IT IS DISTRIBUTED TELL
ME HEALTH SYSTEMS FOR THE SOLE
BENEFIT OF ALAMEDA HOSPITAL. AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE JOINT
POWERS AGREEMENT. IS THE
COMMITMENT BY ELEMENT HEALTH
SYSTEMS TO COMPLETE THE TWENTY
TWENTY SEISMIC RETROFIT. THIS IS
NOW COMPLETE AT A COST OF OVER
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AGREEMENT ALSO CALLS FOR THE
DISTRICT AND ALAMEDA HEALTH
SYSTEMS TO COLLABORATE ON
PLANNING FOR THE TWENTY THIRTY
SEISMIC STANDARDS. THE PLAN HE
HAS BEGUN HAS BEEN UNDER WAY FOR
OVER TWO YEARS. I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE ENTIRE DISTRICT
BOARD TO REQUEST THAT THE HEALTH
COMMITTEES SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE OH FOUR.
WITHOUT THE EXTENSION OF THE
TWENTY THIRTY DEADLINE. AND
MINOR OF FLEXIBILITY IN THE
TWENTY THIRTY REQUIREMENTS
ALAMEDA HOSPITAL FACES LOSING.
ALL OF ITS ACUTE. THAT THE QUEUE
CARE LICENSE AND A LARGE NUMBER
OF ITS DISTINCT CARE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY BEDS. AND MANY
IF NOT ALL OF THE WELL PAYING
JOBS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
HOSPITAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BECAUSE VERY MUCH. SIX WITNESS
GOOD EVENING. DR WOOD AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M DEBBIE
STEBBINS I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CITY OF HEALTH
AT THE CITY OF ALAMEDA HEALTH
CARE DISTRICT. ALSO SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY NINE OH
FOUR. I WAS CEO OF THE ALAMEDA
HOSPITAL FOR SEVEN YEARS PRIOR
TO ITS AFFILIATION IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WITH ALAMEDA
HEALTH SYSTEM. I REJOINED THE
DISTRICT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AS EXACT- AND TODAY MY
- AS- A LARGE PART. ASSURING THE
COORDINATION WITH H. S. OF
MEETING THE TWENTY TWENTY AND
THE TWENTY THIRTY. SEISMIC
STANDARDS WE'VE DISTRIBUTED SOME
HARD COPIES TO YOU TWO ITEMS ONE
OF THE SITE MAP OF ALAMEDA
HOSPITAL SO AS I REFERENCE SOME
OF THE BUILDINGS IT'LL BE EASIER
TO PICTURE THAT AND THE SECOND
IS A PROJECTED. TIME LINE FOR
OUR CURRENT PLANNING- TO MEET
THE TWENTY THIRTY STANDARDS. AS
MR WILLIAMS MENTIONED HOSPITAL
RECENTLY ACHIEVED TOTAL
COMPLIANCE WITH THE TWENTY
TWENTY SEISMIC RETROFIT
REQUIREMENTS- AT A COST OF ABOUT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
THOSE STANDARDS THE TWENTY
TWENTY STANDARDS WERE DESIGNED
TO PREVENT TOTAL COLLAPSE OF
HOSPITAL STRUCTURES. AS A PART
OF THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT THERE IS A
COMPLICATED SEQUENCING OF MOVING
DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE HOSPITAL-
WE ALSO DECOMMISSIONED REGIONAL
HOSPITAL WHICH I DIAGRAM IS
CALLED THE ADMINISTRATION
BUILDING. AND IT IS NO LONGER
USED OR WILL BE USED FOR ANY
ACUTE CARE SERVICES. A BRIDGE
WHICH CONNECTED THE
ADMINISTRATION BUILDING TO THE
STEVENS WEARING- WAS DEMOLISHED
SO ALL ACUTE CARE FUNCTIONS ARE
SEPARATED FROM ANY BUILDING
THAT'S NOT COMPLIANT WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY STANDARDS- WE ALSO
RELOCATED THE BIGGEST PORTION OF
THE EXPENSE OF THE PROJECT WAS
RELOCATING THE KITCHEN TO THE
STEVENS WING WHICH WILL BE A
TWENTY TWENTY COMPLIANT
BUILDING- THAT WAS PROBABLY A
COST OF ABOUT TWENTY MILLION OUT
OF THE TWENTY FIVE MILLION THE
STEVENS WING WAS UPGRADED- TO-
A. S. B. C. TO BUILDING AND
THEREFORE MEETS THE TWENTY
TWENTY STANDARDS. OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS- WE HAVE WORKED WITH
ARCHITECTS TO TRY TO DEVELOP A
PLAN TO COMPLY WITH THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY STANDARDS
BY TWENTY THIRTY UNFORTUNATELY
THAT SCENARIO- TURNED OUT TO BE
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE AT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND ALSO
WOULD HAVE BEEN SO COMPLEX AND
DISRUPTIVE THAT IT PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE NECESSITATED THE
HOSPITAL CLOSING FOR A PERIOD OF
YEARS. IN NINETEEN TWENTY TWO WE
B. WE WENT IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WE WENT BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD AND TRY TO LOOK AT WHAT IT
WOULD TAKE TO BRING ALL THE
BUILDINGS UP TO COMPLIANCE. BUT
AT S. P. C. FOUR D. UP BY TWENTY
THIRTY- AND THE INTENT TO MEET
ALL OF THE IN PC- REQUIREMENTS
AND ALL OF OUR BUILDINGS THE
ONLY EXCEPTION WOULD BE THE
BUILDING IN WHICH THE KITCHEN
HAS BEEN RELOCATED WHICH WE DO
NOT BELIEVE. CAN BE. RESURRECTED
TO- A. L. TWENTY THIRTY
STANDARD. I'M I'M JUST GOING TO
SAY THAT WE HAVE A VERY
COMPLICATED PLANNING PROCESS
BEFORE US THAT'S LAID OUT IN THE
TIMELINE WE PRESENTED- IT IS.
ONE THAT WE THINK. NEEDS TO BE
CAREFULLY THOUGHT THROUGH A BIG
FAN. THE COST OF THE- IN BIG
FACTOR I THINK WE'LL BE PLANNING
FOR HELD PROJECT IN HIS WILL BE
FINANCED THEREFORE- I JOIN- AND
THANK YOU DOCTOR THINKING OF
ASSEMBLY WOMAN BONTA THAT- IN
SPONSORING THIS IMPORTANT BILL
WHICH I THINK PRESERVES THE
HEALTH AND HEALTH RESOURCES FOR
THE COMMUNITY OF ALAMEDA AND
GREATER EAST BAY COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. YOU
KNOW ONE WILL GO TO WITNESSES-
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER IN
SUPPORT. OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION ON THE BILL AND
ORGANIZATIONS WHO REPRESENT ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MEMBERS GIVE ME ROSANNA
CARADJA LEN HERE BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE. IN ORDER TO BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR. THE
MOTION AND A SECOND MOTION BY
MISS CARILLO SECOND BY MISS
GARCIA MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS. THE FUND
WHICH LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A SAFE FINANCIALLY
VIABLE AND QUALITY HEALTHCARE
FACILITY FOR THE COMMUNITY OF
ALAMEDA ENSURES THAT WE'RE
TAKING CARE OF OUR WORKERS. IN
OUR PATIENTS AND HAVE THE BEST
FISHING CARE AND I KNOW THAT
ALAMEDA HEALTHCARE DISTRICT
BOARD WILL WORK TIRELESSLY TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN AS THEY HAVE
FOR DECADES WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ARRIVAL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON. BIGGER
ARAMBULA BIGELOW REAL REAL AYE
FLORA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO GARCIA GARCIA I RESERVE
RESERVE THANK YOU. WILL BE THE
BILL ON TOP. WHERE WE HAD MANY
WE NOW HAVE NONE SO- OR ANY
AUTHORS WHO WOULD LIKE TO COME
FORWARD I'VE PRESENTED. AND. I
CAN DO THAT YEAH I CAN I WILL
PRESENT A BILL. MISTER GIVE
MISTER GET WELL HOURS JUST. LIKE
THE WIND KAMADA MATH. YEAH
PLEASE ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU OF
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
THIS IS ANOTHER SEQUEL- PRESENT
THIS BILL LAST WEEK AND HAPPY
PRESENTED AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL A TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THAT IF AN ADULT
PATIENT LACK THE ABILITY TO MAKE
HEALTH DECISIONS THAT THE
FOLOWING HEALTH CARE DECISIONS
MAKERS MAY MAKE THE DECISIONS ON
THEIR BEHALF AND THEY ARE
LISTED. BELOW ONE. THE SPOUSE OF
A DOMESTIC PARTNER. OF THE
PATIENT. ADULT CHILD OF THE
PATIENT A PARENT OF THE PATIENT
AN ADULT SIBLING OTHER PATIENT
AN ADULT GRAND CHILD OF THE
PATIENT. AND UNAVAILABLE ADULT
RELATIVE WITH THE CLOSEST DEGREE
OF KINSHIP FOR THE PATIENT. ANY
WHO ARE LISTED ABOVE WHOM LIVES
WITH THE PATIENTS ARE GIVEN THAT
PARTICULAR PRIDE PRIORITY. FIRST
OF ALL LET ME ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AT A CLOSE
FRIEND TO THE BILL. ENSURING
THAT A CIRCUIT SELECTED KNOWN.
WHO KNOWS THE BEST WISHES OF THE
PATIENT. THANK YOU FOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND IS CONSIDERED A
CONSULTANT FOR HELPING
STRENGTHENING AND MAKING THIS
BILL BETTER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT. ADS CLEAR
FOR CLEAR CUT CLICK ASIAN TO A
CURRENT LAW IN SECTION OF THE
CURRENT CONFUSING PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AS RELATES TO END OF
LIFE CARE FOR EXAMPLE A STORY. I
SIXTY FIVE YEAR OLD WOMAN WHO
LIVES ALONE. FALLS DOWN AND HIT
HER HEAD. HER CARE GIVER WHO
DOES A WELLNESS CHECK NOW HONOR
ANIMALS BUT ALSO. ON THE SENIOR
AS WELL FIND HER LYING ON THE
FLOOR UNRESPONSIVE. TAKES HER TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM OUR NURSE AND
HER CARE TEAM HAVE IDENTIFIED
THAT THERE IS NO ADVANCE
DIRECTIVE. AT THIS TIME IT IS UP
TO THE DOCTORS OR CARE TEAM TO
DETERMINE THE BEST COURSE OF
ACTION FOR HER ONLY ONE IN EVERY
THREE ADULTS IN THE UNITED
STATES COMPLETES AN ADVANCE
DIRECTIVE FOR END OF LIFE HEALTH
CARE. CURRENT LAW SHOULD MAKE
SURE THAT PERSONS OR PERSONS
MAKING CRITICAL HEALTH DECISIONS
WHEN THERE IS NO ADVANCE
DIRECTIVES HAS THEIR BEST WISHES
IN MIND. AS WELL AS AS A NEXT OF
KIN OUR NEXT OF KIN SOMETIME IS
NOT A BLOOD RELATIVE. IN SOME
CASES IS A FRIEND OR CAREGIVER
OR DOMESTIC PARTNER. MAKE UP THE
NEXT OF KIN THAT KNOWS THAT
PATIENTS WISHES. ONE THING THAT
WE MUST LEARN AND WE MUST KNOW.
THAT ONE SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL
AND OUR NEXT OF KIN MAY NOT BE A
BLOOD RELATIVE DOESN'T COME IN
ONE SIZE OR ONE FLAVOR. WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE PERSON.
WHO IS CLOSEST TO THAT
INDIVIDUAL CARRY OUT THEIR
WISHES AND ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE. OF THIRTY EIGHT IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT ALLOWS
FAMILIES TO DO WHAT WORKS FOR
THEM. PUBLIC HEALTH HAS SHOWN US
THAT PEOPLE ON CENTER CARE IS
THE BEST WAY TO RESPECT A
PATIENT'S WISHES DURING CRITICAL
TIMES. MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT-
ASSEMBLY BILL I'M TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT I HAD WITNESSES
LAST WEEK WHO TESTIFIED WE'VE
SUBMITTED THOUGH THEY'RE WRITTEN
TESTIMONIES AND CERTAINLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER GIBSON OR IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS
CAME IN TO MEET YOU ON BEHALF OF
A CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AT
THIS POINT WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE. THE MEMBERS IN THE- IN
FAVOR. S. C. KNOWN BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OCEAN FROM SOMEONE. ANYONE THANK
YOU THINK SO MOTION BY MISTER
CARILLO SECOND BY THE CHAIR-
BUSH'S TO PASS AS AMENDED WHICH
I TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AGAIN THIS
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
SENIOR LEGISLATURE OF APPRECIATE
THEIR ACTIVISM BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THEY HAVE THEIR HAND ON
THE POLLS AND AGAIN AN ADVANCE
DIRECTIVE- AGAIN- THE NEXT OF
KIN MAY NOT BE A BLOOD RELATIVE
AND MAYBE SOME OF THOSE CLOSE TO
YOU THAT CAN CARRY OUT YOUR
WISHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM SECRETARY WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND- THESE CALL THE
ROLL WHAT I'VE WHAT I WALDRON.
HI. FIGURE CURRY ARAMBULA
BIGELOW CARILLO RIO I THINK
LAURA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RIVAS THANK YOU
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO GARCIA.
GARCIA I THANK YOU READERS ARE
ALL THESE- WE GOT A BUNCH
MEMBERS THAT ARE OUT I KNOW THE
FACT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
GIBSON THANK YOU. MR LACKEY. I
WANT UP SIR.
TWO EXCITING SEAT TRIPLED IN
SIZE. THERE'S. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY AT TO
MISOGYNY BABCOCK BUT THE
COMMITTEE FOR HER ASSISTANCE AND
STRICTLY THIS PROPOSAL. AB
TWENTY TWO ANYONE PRIORITIZE
INVESTMENTS IN YOUNG CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH. THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT WOULD ENABLE THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OR OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. THE
FUND GRANTS FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
THE QUALITY OF CARE. FOR THE
ZERO FIVE POPULATION THEIR
PARENTS FAMILIES AND CAREGIVERS
. EARLY INTERVENTION ADDRESSING
TO THE MILD TO MODERATE NEEDS OF
THESE YOUTH IS ESSENTIAL FOR
JUST MEANT. UNENCUMBERED BY
ANXIETY AND TOXIC STRESS CAUSED
BY WHAT HAS BEEN TERMED ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES KNOWN AS
ACES. IF LEFT UNTREATED THESE
ACES MANIFESTS AS BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS THIS BILL WOULD
ALLEVIATE EXACERBATIONS OF OUR
SHARED SYSTEM BY DECREASING THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT SERIOUS DISEASES
DEVELOP LATER IN LIFE.
CALIFORNIA'S EMBARKED ON A
SIGNIFICANT JOURNEY DISTRICT ARE
SUPPORT OF CHILDREN FAMILIES AND
ADULT CARE GIVERS. AND
APPRECIATION FOR THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS AS VITAL AS WE
OVERCOME. I'M SORRY AS OUT AS WE
COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC WE NEED
TO REMEMBER THAT THERE IS AN
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
WHICH WAS INFLAMED BY THE
LOCKDOWNS ASSOCIATED WITH
COLBERT. WE ALL NEED HELP
ADJUSTING TO RAPIDLY CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES IN DEALING WITH
THE TRAUMA. THESE GRANTS WILL
PRODUCE AN UNDERSTANDING OF
WHICH EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
ARE BEST FOR TREATING THE NEEDS
OF YOUNG CHILDREN WILL SPUR
INNOVATION FOR HOW BEST WE CAN
SUPPORT THESE CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. I BELIEVE THIS
INVESTMENT IS ESSENTIAL FOR
SUPPORTING VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN ADDRESSING HEALTH
DISPARITIES WITH EARLY
INTERVENTION. I HAVE TOBY EWING
WITH THE EXECUTIVE I'M SORRY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION WITH
ME TODAY. YOU IN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AGAIN
TOTALING WITH MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IS
LEADING WITH THIS LEGISLATION.
FIND A DENOUNCES THE COMMISSION
IS THRILLED THAT THIS BILL IS IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY MOVING
FORWARD I HOPE I EXUBERANCE WAS
APPROPRIATE IN TERMS OF THE
LETTER NOT JUST SUPPORT BUT
THRILLED. IN OUR SUPPORT- YEAH
CALIFORNIA'S MADE GREAT PROGRESS
IN. PROVIDING FUNDING INCENTIVE
GRANTS TO STRENGTHEN OUR
STRATEGIES AROUND OUR K. TWELVE
SYSTEM. YOUNG CHILDREN ALSO-
EXPERIENCE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
THAT OFTEN GO UNADDRESSED- MANY
OF YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH A
COMMON REFRAIN THAT FAMILIES ARE
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGED TO WAIT
UNTIL THEIR YOUNG CHILDREN ENTER
SCHOOL TO SECURE AN IEP OR OTHER
STRATEGY. IT CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR PARENTS AND
FAMILIES TO KNOW WHAT TO DO WHEN
THEY'RE VERY YOUNG CHILDREN. ARE
EXPRESSING THEIR NEEDS TO THEIR
BEHAVIOR AND IN FACT MY FAMILY
HAS EXPERIENCED THIS. AS A
RESULT WE SEE THESE DEVASTATING
DELAYS IN ACCESS TO CARE AND
TREATMENT. AB TWO TWO EIGHT ONE
WORST LET'S JUST THE G. CRAIG
SIMMONS FIND STRENGTH AND ENDING
IN A AND E'S TO PUT IN PLACE
STRATEGIES TO REALLY IMPROVE. WE
HAVE A SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
RESPONDING TO NEEDS OF VERY
YOUNG CHILDREN WITH THAT WOULD
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE HAVE ATTENTION
TO QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M SITTING. OF IN NEED THERE
ARE ENOUGH. I'M AWARE. JAMES
CARRAGHER. SPEAKING BROUGH JUST
IN ORDER MISSION IF YOU
REPRESENT GOOD EVENING AND HER
AGAIN EASTMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NICOLE WATERMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO ONE
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. THE MOTION BY MISS
CARILLO SECOND BY MISS- MISS
WALDRON MOTION DO PASSES TO
APPROPRIATIONS ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR. THOSE WHO NEED THIS
HELP THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WHAT I WALDRON. WALDRON
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA
BIGELOW. REAL I FLORA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO GARCIA RCI.
BY ZERO OF FIVE FORGETTING THEIR
VERY MUCH VERY MUCH MR LACKEY
MUCH APPRECIATED THIS IRWIN.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY ALL RIGHT
SAID GOOD EVENING AND- I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
WORK I WILL KEEP THIS SHORT AND
TO THE POINT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR RECENTLY RELEASED
A REPORT THAT DEMONSTRATED LARGE
SCALE. FRAUD WITHIN OUR HOSPICE
INDUSTRY EIGHT SIX SEVEN THREE
WILL IMPLEMENT THE RECOMMENDED
MADE BY THE AUDITOR. THE DRESSES
EGREGIOUS BEHAVIOR AND BUILDS ON
OUR WORK THAT WE DID LAST YEAR
ON- AB TWELVE EIGHTY WITH ME IS
PETER CALLOUS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
PETER CALLOUSED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE ASSOCIATION.
WHICH PRIMARILY RIGHT WHICH DOES
REPRESENT THE HOSPICE PROVIDERS
IN CALIFORNIA- THEY READ THE
AUDITOR GENERAL'S REPORT THEY
CAN FIND NOTHING TO CRITICIZE IN
IT. THEY ARE WELL AWARE- THE-
EXAMPLES OF INADEQUATE
FRAUDULENT OR NEGLIGENT CARE
PROVIDED. BY HOT SOME HOSPICE
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT- THIS
LEGISLATION WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR YOUR STAFF AND MR WHEN
STAFF IN WORKING WITH US
COLLABORATIVELY. THERE IS NO
PLACE IN THE PROVISION OF CARE
TO THE TERMINALLY ILL THE
VULNERABLE WHEN THEIR LOVED ONES
FOR THOSE WHO WOULD PROVIDE
NEGLIGENT FRAUDULENT OR CARE
THAT IS FOR THE SAKE OF ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY. AND NO OTHER REASON
FOR THIS REASON WERE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE DISCUSSIONS AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. KNOW
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. OUR BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND TO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THIS FOR WHICH I
CLOSE SPECS WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THE
DOOR DOESN'T DO I DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MA'AM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHEN I.
WOULD I WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BIGELOW.
MARIA COREA I FLORA MAIENSCHEIN
MAYES MCCARTY THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
SANTIAGO. GARCIA GARCIA HI. BY
ZERO BY ZERO LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL. THANK YOU. THIS IS THERE
ANY LIKE TO PRESENT MR LEVINE'S
BILL ON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE WOULD REQUIRE A HEALTH
SERVICE PLAN TO APPROVE AND
SCHEDULE INITIAL OUTPATIENT
APPOINTMENT FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES WITHIN FORTY EIGHT
HOURS OF A PERSON'S RELEASE FROM
SEVENTY TWO HOUR INVOLUNTARY
HOSPITALIZATION CURRENT LAW
AUTHORIZES THE TEMPORARY
INVOLUNTARY HOSPITALIZATION OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO DUE TO MENTAL
ILLNESS POSE A DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS. OR WHO ARE
GRAVELY DISABLED MEANING THEY
ARE UNABLE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
BASIC NEEDS OF FOOD CLOTHING OR
SHELTER AFTER SEVENTY TWO HOUR
INVOLUNTARY HOSPITALIZATION THE
PROCESS OF OBTAINING FOLLOW UP
CARE ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS CAN BE
FRUSTRATING AND COMPLICATED FOR
THE DISCHARGED INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
OFTEN STILL EXPERIENCING
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL ANGUISH AND
IS ILL EQUIPPED TO TAKE
NECESSARY STEPS TO OBTAIN FOLLOW
UP CARE AND TREATMENT. THERE IS
A CLEAR NEED TO EXPEDITE AND
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
FOLLOW UP MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT ACCORDING TO A STUDY
PUBLISHED IN A GEMMA PSYCHIATRY.
IN THE NINETY DAYS FOLLOWING
THEIR DISCHARGED PERSONS WITH
ANY MENTAL DISORDER OR SEVERELY
AT RISK FOR SUICIDE AND R.
TWELVE. AND A HALF TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT SUICIDE THAN
THE GENERAL POPULATION. A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL HELP
IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES
AND ENSURE TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE
BY REQUIRING THAT A PATIENT
RELEASED FROM INVOLUNTARY MENTAL
HEALTH HOSPITALIZATION RECEIVED
AUTHORIZATION FOR CARE WITHIN
FORTY EIGHT HOURS OF THEIR
RELEASE- THE AUTHOR MR LEVINE IS
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
COMMITTEE. ON QUESTIONS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE ANALYSIS. AND
THE ON HIS BEHALF I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. YOUR SHOW
NOW. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JOHN VAN OVER AND I'M
THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR DVSA
CALIFORNIA THE BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
ON IMPORTANT BILL. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ARE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR I
AM ALSO APPEAR AND LIVE WITH A
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS. I HAVE
BIPOLAR ONE. AND IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN I HAD MY FIRST MANIC
EPISODE. I AM LUCKY ENOUGH TO
HAVE WONDERFUL FAMILY SUPPORT
AND THOUGH WE WERE ALL CAUGHT
OFF GUARD MY AUNT EVENTUALLY
REALIZED I NEEDED PROFESSIONAL
HELP AND TOOK ME TO THE ER WHERE
WAS PLACED ON A SEVENTY TWO HOUR
HOLD. DESPITE THAT MY MOTHER HAD
GONE TO THE FACILITY. UPON THE
COMPLETION OF THE HOLD I WAS
PLACED IN A VAN WITH THREE OTHER
MEN AND WE WERE ALL DROPPED OFF
AT UNION STATION IN DOWNTOWN LA
. CONFUSED BY NOT ONLY MY
BEHAVIOR BUT ALSO THE BEHAVIOR
OF THE SYSTEM MY LOVED ONES WERE
AT A LOSS YET MY TROUBLES WERE
JUST BEGINNING. MY MANIA QUICKLY
WORSENED AND EVENTUALLY LEAD TO
A PSYCHOTIC BREAK. WITHIN THE
NEXT TWO MONTHS I WAS ARRESTED
THREE TIMES FOR MISDEMEANOR
OFFENSES. THE FIRST OF MY LIFE
WITH THE FINAL ONE BEING A
VERBAL ASSAULT OF THE MAILMAN
THE PUT ME IN THE COUNTY JAIL
FOR THIRTEEN HORRIFIC DAYS.
STILL INCREDIBLY SICK. SO IN
ADDITION TO MY SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS I KNOW ALSO HAVE PTSD.
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE IS A
COMMONSENSE PARITY DRIVEN STEP
THE COULD HAVE EASILY CHANGED MY
LIFE FOR THE BETTER. OUR STATE
DOESN'T DO A VERY GOOD JOB OF
EDUCATING THE PUBLIC AND DE
STIGMATIZING WHAT A MANIC
EPISODE REALLY IS. THE WARNING
SIGNS OF MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID
OR WHAT TREATMENT IS AVAILABLE.
AS A RESULT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR LOVED ONES
TO KNOW WHERE TO GO OR WHAT TO
DO. EVEN THOUGH THEY DESPERATELY
WANT TO HELP. AS INVOLUNTARY
HOLDS AMPLIFY THE TRAUMA
SOMEONE'S EXPERIENCING IN THAT
STATE. IT IS CRITICAL TO GET
THEM INFORMATION AND CONNECTION
TO VOLUNTARY CARE OPTIONS
IMMEDIATELY UPON RELEASE. IF ALL
RIGHT AS AN UP. WHITE MALE.
GRADUATE DEGREE CAREER HOME THAT
I OWNED INSURANCE AND EXCELLENT
FAMILY SUPPORT. DON'T KNOW WHERE
TO GO FOR CARE IN THE MOST
POPULOUS CITY IN THE STATE. THEN
WHAT CHANCE TO ANY OF US HAVE.
DUE TO A LACK OF RESEARCH IN THE
FIELD AND INDIVIDUAL STILL
CANNOT BE PROPERLY DIAGNOSED
WITH BIPOLAR ONE AND THEREFORE
TREATED UNTIL THEY HAVE A TRUE
MANIC EPISODE. THE MANIA AND
WE DON'T JUST HAVE A BAD MORNING
THEN BECOME PSYCHOTIC. THERE ARE
MANY OPPORTUNITIES FOR EARLY
INTERVENTION AND TREATMENT THE
PROGRAM SIMPLY AREN'T AVAILABLE.
TRAGICALLY THE LAWS THAT ADDRESS
OF YOUR MENTAL ILLNESS AS WELL
AS THE MEDICATION I CURRENTLY
TAKE OVER HALF A CENTURY OLD.
AND PUBLIC OPINION ABOUT US IS
EQUALLY ARCHAIC. IN ADDITION TO
THE PASSAGE OF AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY
NINE OR ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO QUICKLY TAKE UP LEGISLATION
IN THE NEXT SESSION THE WOULD
PROVIDE IDENTICAL PROTECTIONS TO
THE UNINSURED. AND SINCE PRO
CHOICE. THING THE PROBLEM FOR
GETS WORSE THE CAN ONLY IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR THE PUBLIC AND THE
STATE. BEFORE WE REIMAGINE
OPPORTUNITIES TO WAIT TILL
PEOPLE ARE SEVERELY ILL AND THEN
REMOVE THEIR RIGHTS CRIMINALIZE
THEM AND FORCE THEM INTO
TREATMENT. I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO PUT RESOURCES
AND ALL THE OTHER WAYS WE COULD
SOLVE THE SYSTEM THAT EVERYONE
AGREES IS BROKEN. PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT DRUGS AND TREATMENT
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION. AND ACCESS TO
VOLUNTARY TREATMENT OPTIONS THE
SAME HALLMARKS WE RELIED ON FOR
FISCAL HEALTH FOR GENERATIONS.
SHOULD BE EMBRACED AND FUNDED
RATHER THAN A DORK. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB
FIFTY NINE. THANK EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN I THINK THREE TIMES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WHAT AN
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF- FOR ON. AB. FIFTEEN FIFTY
NINE MY NAME IS ADAM HORN. SHARE
MY- IS IDENTIFYING A FULL FULL
AND TIME WE HAVE REGULAR-
DELAYED MY OWN UP CARE FROM
HEALTH HOLD. NEARLY FOUR YEARS
AGO ON ADVICE FROM A CLOSE
FRIEND- HERE WHO WORKS IN THE
CAPITOL. I MADE A VISIT TO MY
GENERAL PRACTITIONER. AND HAT AS
I HAD BEEN EXPERT SEVERE
DEPRESSION AND A CONSTANT
BARRAGE OF THOUGHTS THAT LEAD ON
MORE THAN ONE OCCASION. TO
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE. WHILE THERE
THE NURSES SOFFIT TO PLACE ME
INTO A MENTAL HEALTH HOLD THE
REQUESTED PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICERS. TO TRANSFER ME TO AN
EMERGENCY ROOM. AFTER SEVEN
EIGHT HOURS SITTING ON A GURNEY
IN THE HALLWAY OF THE YARD. I
WITHOUT BEING SEEN BY AN ON DUTY
PSYCHIATRIST. AND WOULD BRIEF
AND FREQUENT AT CHECK INS BY A
SOCIAL WORKER I WAS RELEASED TO
THE CARE OF ANOTHER CLOSE
FRIEND. IN A WEEK. AND THE
FOLLOWING WEEK I WAS ABLE TO
SCHEDULE AN INITIAL FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENT. WITH THE SPECIALIST
HOWEVER THE SOONEST. I COULD
OBTAIN WAS SIX WEEKS AFTER
MICHAEL. AT THE HOURS DAYS AND
WEEKS PASSED I KEPT WONDERING
WHY WAS TAKING SO LONG. FOR ME
TO SEE A SPECIALIST- WHY
COULDN'T GET THE CAR NEEDED
WHILE I CONTINUE TO SUFFER.
ALTHOUGH THE PROVIDER ASSIGNED A
CASE WORKER WHO CONTINUE TO CALL
AND CHECK IN. ON MY STATE. THE
CONVERSATIONS WERE DIFFICULT TO
COMPREHEND. I FELT LIKE I WAS
BEING STRUNG ALONG. I EXPRESS MY
FRUSTRATION TO THE CASE WORKER
AND ASK WHY I COULDN'T HAVE MY-
DINNER. THE RESPONSE. REALIZE
THE FOOTBALL IN THE TIME WE
ACCESS REGULATIONS. THAT UNLESS
THE PATIENT EXPLICITLY ASKED FOR
CARE- AND MAKE THE REQUEST. THE
TIME REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT
TRIGGERED. THERE FOR TREATMENT
AND FURTHER DELAY IN. IN LIGHT
OF MY FRUSTRATION THE CASE
WORKER MOVED UP MY APPOINTMENT
BUT ONLY BY TWO WEEKS. BROUGHT
THE MONTH AFTER MY HOLD I
THOUGHT RELIEF FOR THE PAIN
THROUGH EXCESSIVE USE OF
INTOXICANTS. CONTEST FOR
INTENSIFYING THE DEPRESSION AND
SUICIDAL IDEATION. MY FIRST LIKE
I. THANK YOU EFFORT APPOINTMENT
WAS THE TURNING POINT I NEEDED
AND I WISH I HAD IT SOONER. OVER
TIME THE MEDICATION AND
TREATMENT SIGNIFICANTLY HELPED.
I BEGAN TO ENJOY LIFE AGAIN. AND
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE DIMINISH
DRAMATICALLY. MY EXPERIENCE
SHOWED ME THAT WHEN A PATIENT IS
IN A MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT'S THEIR
FIRST. THEY CAN NOT A PROPERLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT STEPS NEED TO BE
TAKEN TO GET PROPER CARE. THE
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT NEED TO
INSURE THE PROPER CARE. I
PROVIDE IS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND WAITING A MONTH TO SEE A
DOCTOR IS UNACCEPTABLE. AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE- EX.
EXPEDITE DESPERATELY NEEDED
CARE. THANK YOU AND I URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I THEIR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I DON'T BELIEVE THERE
MIGHT BE OKAY NEVER MIND PLEASE
COME FORWARD MY APOLOGIES.
MOTION BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY
MISS GARCIA. PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEFF HAMPTON HERE
AT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS I REGRETTABLY WE DO
HAVE A POST POSITION ON AB
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE I WISH
REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS TO SCHEDULE
AN APPOINTMENT FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DETAINED FOR SEVENTY TWO
HOUR- TREATMENT AND EVALUATION
UNDER THE LANUS PETR SHORT AFTER
WITHIN FORTY EIGHT HOURS OF THE
PERSON'S RELEASE. I WE CERTAINLY
AGAIN APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF
THIS BILL AS A MEMBER PLANS ARE
STRONGLY COMMITTED TO ENSURING
THAT OUR ENROLLEES RECEIVE HIGH
QUALITY MENTAL HEALTHCARE
SERVICES A PERSONALIZED
COMPASSIONATE MANNER. HOWEVER A
EXISTING LAWS AND REGULATIONS
ALREADY ESTABLISHED TIMELY
ACCESS TO CARE FOR THESE
SERVICES. EXISTING LAW AND
REGULATIONS STATUS TIME FRAME
FORTY EIGHT TO NINETY SIX HOURS
FOR ENSURING URGENT FOLLOW UP
APPOINTMENTS ADD ON THE
INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCES.
WORSHIPED THEIR CONCERNED THAT
AB TWO FIFTY NINE- ARBITRARILY
MANDATE HEALTH PLANS. FALL
PLACEMENT UPON DISCHARGE FROM
THE TRADING FACILITY WITHIN
FORTY EIGHT HOURS REGARDLESS OF
THE INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCE-
UNFORTUNATELY THE BILL MAKES
SEVERAL ASSUMPTIONS DO NOT
PRACTICALLY TRANSLATE. REAL
WORLD A REAL WORLD SCENARIOS
WHICH WE THINK WOULD MAKE THIS
BILL VERY CHALLENGING TO
IMPLEMENT- FOR INSTANCE THE
OFTENTIMES IT TAKES UP TO FORTY
EIGHT HOURS TO DETERMINE IF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS ON A VOLUNTARY
OR INVOLUNTARY HOLDS HE'S ME I
HAS BEEN RELEASED FROM THEIR
HOSPITALIZATION ADDITIONALLY THE
BILL SOON THAT INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
ON AN INVOLUNTARY HOLDS HAS THE
PICTURES INFORMATION AVAILABLE
AND IS A POSITION TO RELAY THAT
INFORMATION TO THEIR HEALTH
PLAN. IF THE IN REALLY DOES NOT
HAVE THAT INFORMATION READILY
AVAILABLE HOW WOULD THEY OR
THEIR SHE PROVIDER KNOW HOW TO
CONTACT THE HEALTH PLAN
REGARDING FOLLOWED SERVICES IN
FORTY EIGHT HOURS. FURTHERMORE
THE BILL ASSUMES THAT HEALTH
PLAN SCHEDULE APPOINTMENTS ON
BEHALF OF THEIR ENROLLEES
GENERALLY SPEAKING THIS IS NOT
THE CASE. I PROVIDERS ESPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROVIDERS. TYPICALLY
WANT TO HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THE
INDIVIDUAL BEFORE SCHEDULING AN
APPOINTMENT. I LASTLY IN THE
BILL MANDATES THAT HEALTH PLANS
ENSURE THAT THE LOCATION OF
FACILITIES PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES BE WITHIN A
REASONABLE PROXIMITY TO THE
RELEASE- HOME OR WORK LOCATION.
HELLO WE UNDERSTAND THE NETWORK
NETWORK ADEQUACY STANDARDS ARE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURING THAT
SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL- YOU KNOW
MANY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
HAVE EXCLUSIVELY TRANSITIONED TO
VIRTUAL PLATFORMS TO DELIVER THE
SERVICES. SO- WE'RE NOT BEEN A
SUPER CLEAR IF THE BILL IS
INTENDED TO EXCLUDE TELEHEALTH
FROM CONSIDERATION TO MEET THE
STANDARDS BUT IT WOULD BE VERY
CHALLENGING FOR HEALTH PLANS TO.
GO TO MEET THE OBLIGATIONS OF
THE BILL- IF TELEHEALTH WERE
EXCLUDED. AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AT THIS TIME BUT DO
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR MOVING FORWARD ON THIS
MATTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN
PERSEPHONE WALKEN'S ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WILL- ECHO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES COMMENTS. WE DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THE NEED FOR
SERVICES AND CARE AFTER
DISCHARGE WE JUST THINK THAT
IT'S MORE APPROPRIATELY A PART
OF THAT JUST CHARGE PROCESS.
CERTAINLY VISUALS TRANSITIONING
OUT OF THE HOUSEHOLD I'M IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO THAT
COMMUNICATION I THINK WE HEARD
IN SOME OF THE TESTIMONY THAT
THERE WAS A LACK OF INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT THE NEXT STEPS COULD
BE. UNFORTUNATE PART FOR- PLANS
IT. PLEASES EARLY NAY. PERSONS
THAN JUST CHARGE FROM A SEVENTY
TWO HOUR HOLD. SO AFTER THE FACT
WHEN THE INDIVIDUALS LEFT THE
FACILITY FOR US TO THEN. BE
INFORMED CONTACT THEM DIRECT AND
SET UP AN APPOINTMENT THAT THERE
NOW FINANCIALLY OBLIGATED- TO
PAY FOR. WITHOUT THEIR INTERFACE
OR INTERACTION IS A CONCERN FOR
US. SO THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
TODAY WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS TO
SEE IF THERE'S A WAY TO SORT OF
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES AND
CERTAINLY WORK WITH THE
DISCHARGE PROCESS. TO SEE IF
THERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN THE
CHAMBER CHAMBER OF THE HEARING
ROOM- IN SUPPORT OR UP IN
OPPOSITION- JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
MR MEMBERS TO MADDENREPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER THE BROKEN CALLS
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND SPORT
GIVE. GOOD EVENING TARGET BY
EASEMENT WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. JANE CAN- WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. L. A. R.
K. ADLER WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT OF AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
. IN KNOWN OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF THE BILL DOES
HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
HELLO I'M SORRY I'M SORRY MISS
WALDRON MY APOLOGIES. NO I JUST
WANTED TO SAY QUICKLY I AGREE
HE- THERE'S DEFINITELY A NEED
HERE. TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO
THIS AND I ALSO AGREE WITH WHAT
THE HEALTH PLANS ARE SAYING
THAT. MAY NOT BE THE EXACT WAY
TO DO IT- BUT I'D LIKE TO SEE
THIS MOVE FORWARD AND SEE WHAT
HAPPENS SO. MAKE IT WORKABLE
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO DO-
CONVEYED TO THE AUTHOR. VERY
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY- MISS RIO
SECOND BY MISS GARCIA A MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
DOZEN JOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTERS
ERIN. I ON BEHALF OF MR LEVINE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
THANK YOU A MAN SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WOOD I WOULD I
WALDRON WALDRON AYE.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA BIGELOW
BIGELOW NO CARILLO. LARA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY THIS
AREA HI NAZARIAN I RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO GARCIA GARCIA
I. ORDER ONE ORDER ONE WILL BE
THE BILL ON TOP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOU HAVE A COUPLE OF BILLS
AS WELL. I DO WHICH ONE WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO START LET'S START
WITH TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THIS BILL AND FOR THE
SUPPORT THE STAFF IS GIVEN TO
OUR OFFICE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY THREE WOULD INCREASE THE
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
REGISTERING AS A SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER COUNSELOR OF
CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL WOULD EXPAND THE SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER COUNSELOR
CERTIFICATION CURRICULUM AND
INCREASE THE CERTIFICATION OUR
REQUIREMENTS SO THEY ARE NO
LOWER. THEN THE OUR REQUIREMENTS
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR
CERTIFIED PEER SUPPORT
SPECIALISTS WHICH IS EIGHTY
HOURS. RIGHT NOW THE OUR
REQUIREMENT FOR REGISTERING AS A
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER COUNSELOR
IS ONLY NINE HOURS WITH A
LIMITED CURRICULUM. THIS MINIMUM
STANDARD IS INADEQUATE TO
EFFECTIVELY PREPARE INDIVIDUALS
TO ENTER A PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM AND WORK WITH A
DIVERSE HIGH NED POPULATION
FREQUENTLY WITH COMPLEX
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONDITIONS AND
LIFE EXPERIENCES. THE PANDEMIC
HAS ONLY HEIGHTENED THE NEED TO
RE CERTIFICATION STANDARDS AS
ALCOHOL AND DRUG RELATED DEATHS
HAVE INCREASED AT AN ALARMING
RATE TO ENSURE THAT WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES AREN'T AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE. WE WORKED WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ON A SET OF
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD PROVIDE A
GRANDFATHER CLAUSE FOR ALREADY
CERTIFIED COUNSELORS AND A SIX
MONTH GRACE PERIOD FOR THOSE
BEGINNING THEIR CERTIFICATION
PROCESS. WITH ME OUR DOCTOR GARY
TÀI DIRECTOR OF L. A. COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH'S
DIVISION OF SUBSTANCE USE%
PREVENTION AND CONTROL AS WELL
AS A TILER. RANDY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG OF PROGRAM
EXECUTIVE. EXECUTIVES THIS
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
EVENING I'M DOCTOR GARY SIDE
RECTOR OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
DIVISION OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE FOR
INSTINCTUAL THANK YOU CHAIR
WOULD- AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY SPEAK ABOUT AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. BOARD OF SUPERVISORS-
WHO SPONSORED AT THIS BILL- IT
FUNDAMENTALLY IT ADDRESSES THE
LONG STANDING ISSUES RELATED TO
ENACT ADEQUATE TRAINING
STANDARDS FOR SUBSTANCE USE
COUNSELORS ARM AS WAS STATED IN
CALIFORNIA THE CURRENT MINIMUM
STANDARD FOR COUNCIL TO BECOME
REGISTERED AND PROVIDE MEDICARE
REIMBURSABLE SERVICES IS NINE
HOURS I WHICH IS THE LOWEST
NEARLY OF ANY HEALTH PROFESSION
IN DISCUSSIONS WITH STAKEHOLDERS
FROM ACROSS THE STATE- THERE IS
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT AND AGREEMENT
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE. ARE AN
INCREASE IN D. WORK FOR
STANDARDS FOR REGISTERED
COUNSELLORS IN THE FIELD AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE DOES
THIS IN TWO WAYS THAT INCREASES
THE REQUIREMENT FOR THE NUMBER
OF HOURS- AN STD COUNSELOR WOULD
BE REQUIRED IN ORDER TO BECOME
REGISTERED- SETS IT AT LEAST AT
THE LEVEL OF THE NEW ENTERED BY
SB EIGHT THREE FOUR A PEER
SPECIALISTS WHICH IS EIGHT
HOURS. IT ALSO ENSURES THAT THE
CORE COMPETENCY COURSE.
REQUIREMENTS FOR REGISTER AND
CERTIFIED COUNSELORS IS
CONSISTENT WITH NATIONAL
STANDARDS. FOR SUBSTANCE USE
ASSESSMENTS DIAGNOSES. COVERS
TOPICS SUCH AS MEDICATIONS FOR
ADDICTION TREATMENT- AND ALSO
COVERS- SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WITH
CO OCCURRING MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE CONDITIONS. OUR
ACHIEVING THE OBJECTIVES. SET
FORTH ARE CRITICAL IN ORDER FOR
US TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE-
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES
CONFRONTING OUR STATE TERMS OF
THE ONGOING OVERDOSE EPIDEMIC
HOMELESSNESS- JUSTICE REFORM AS
WELL AS AMBITIOUS CARE
INTEGRATION GOALS- FROM THE
STATE'S TRANSFORMATION OF MEDIC
CALENDAR CALENDAR. OUT WE CANNOT
BE EFFECTIVE ON ANY OF THESE
FRONTS WITHOUT A WELL TRAINED
AND ROBUST SUBSTANCE USE WORK
FORCE- AND SUBSTANCE USE
COUNSELORS ARE THE PRIMARY
SUBSTANCE USE WORK FORCE- FOR
ADDICTION ACROSS THE STATE A TO
ENSURE QUALITY SERVICE IS ALSO
IMPERATIVE THAT WE- NOT HAVE
PEER. SPECIALIST STANDARDS THAT
ARE HIGHER THAN SUBSTANCE USE
CANCERS PARTICULARLY GIVEN THAT
SUBSTANCE USE COUNSELORS I
PERFORM A BROADER RANGE OF
CLINICAL SERVICES I'VE BEEN MANY
PEER SPECIALISTS- THIS BILL
BALANCES STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS OF
ONGOING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES WITH THE
NEED FOR- THESE HIGHER STANDARDS
AS WELL AS QUALITY. LASTLY THIS
BILL ALSO DOES NOT ADD ANY
ADDITIONAL COSTS GIVEN THE MOST
COUNCILLORS ARE YOU TAKE COURSE
WORK ON THEIR PATH
PERMISSIVENESS STRAIGHT IN.
VENTURA CERTIFICATION AND- JUST
WANT TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR GUIDANCE ON THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE MENTIONED-
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE CONCERNS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR WHAT IN MEMBERS HI
RANDY I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES CAPPY REPRESENTS
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND THE PUBLIC SYSTEM.
AND WE EMPLOY THE LARGEST NUMBER
OUT OF SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER%
TREATMENT COUNSELORS ACROSS THE
STATE- AND PROVIDE SERVICES AT
OVER THREE HUNDRED SITES. WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR SPONSOR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US ON OR PLEASED TO BE IN
SUPPORT TODAY. I'M AB TWENTY
NINETY THREE OF THE MEASURE.
THAT WILL INCREASE THE LEVEL OF
EDUCATION AND TRAINING OF OUR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
COUNSELORS WHICH MAKE UP THE 70%
OF OUR SUBSTANCE USE WORK FORCE.
WHILE ALSO PRESERVING AND
MINIMIZING IMPACTS TO HIRING AND
RETAINING WORKFORCE RESPECTFULLY
PRESSURED OF THE GRANDFATHERING
CLAUSE AS WELL AS THE SIX MONTH
GRACE PERIOD- WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CORE COMPETENCIES ADDRESSED
IN THE- EDUCATIONS FOR THE NEXT
. CURRENT MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE CONDITIONS ULTRA
COMPETENT UNDERSTANDING OF
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE TREATMENT CRITERIA ARE
CRITICAL TO A HIGHLY TRAINED
AFFECTIVE SUBSTANCE USE
WORKFORCE ESPECIALLY IF THE
STATE PUSHES TOWARDS INTEGRATION
WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND PHYSICAL
HEALTH CARE- DEATHS BY OVERDOSE-
ALCOHOL RELATED DEATHS HAVE
SKYROCKETED DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND THE NEED FOR SERVICES HAS
INCREASED THE NOT DECREASED WE
BELIEVE. IS AT A I'M AFFECTED
TOOL TO A WELL TRAINED WORKFORCE
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS IN
ADDITION TO HARM REDUCTION AND
MANY OTHER THINGS THAT WE TALKED
TO THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
PREVIOUSLY ON BEHALF OF CAT B.
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THERE ANYWAY ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE ANY-
WHEN IN THE HEARING ROOM WAS
JUST- EXPRESS SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD. YOUR NAME.
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. THANK YOU L. A. R. K. ADLER
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SOFT DRAWING SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE. YOU KNOW
ONE OF BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS COMMENTS
A MOTION. ALL OF THE ABOVE. THE
MOVE. I WOULD SECOND THE MOTION-
PROJECT CLOSE MISTER NAZARIAN
AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH US AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING WORKING
MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE BILL
DOESN'T I DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
EMOTION WOULD BE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON WALDRON HIGH.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA. BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO. LARA
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MCCARTY
NAZARIAN AYE NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO GARCIA GARCIA
HI. FIVE ZERO FIVE VOTES- WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND NEXT
BILL AB DE TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX
MISTERS ERIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THE ANALYSIS REFLECTS
AMENDMENTS YOU WOULD LIKE ME TO
TAKE SO THAT THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD SO I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THESE AMENDMENTS AND OF
FURTHERMORE COMMITTEE TO WORKING
CONTINUING WORKING WITH YOU-
BEFORE APPROPRIATIONS RELATING
TO THE WORKING GROUP ADDED TO
THIS BILL- THIS BILL IS STILL
REFERRED AND WAS HEARD AN AGING
COMMITTEE LAST WEEK AND RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. BILL CREATES
THE RESIDENT DESIGNATED SUPPORT
PERSONS ACT THIS MEASURE IS A
PRODUCT OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- THE BILL INSURERS ALL
RESIDENTS IN NURSING HOMES. OR
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES THE
RIGHT TO IN PERSON ON SITE AND
ON SCHEDULED VISITATION FROM A
MINIMUM OF TWO RESIDENT
DESIGNATED SUPPORT PERSONS
DURING ANY PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY IN WHICH A RESIDENTS
FORMAL VISITATION RIGHTS ARE
CURTAILED. SUPPORT PERSONS
PROVIDE A CRITICAL AND OFTEN
LIFESAVING ROLE IN THE LIVES OF
RESIDENTS IN CARE SETTINGS
INCLUDING AMONG OTHER THINGS
COMPANIONSHIP COGNITIVE
STIMULATION. EDUCATION AND
DECISION MAKING ASSISTANCE
OFTENTIMES THEY PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE WITH DAILY LIVING
TASKS SUCH AS EATING DRESSING
AND HYGIENE. THE PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL CONNECTION
TRANSPORTATION AND PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY THE FULL EXTENT OF THE
SUPPORT WAS POORLY UNDER BUT BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF YOURS. WHO
AUTHORIZED VISITATION LOCKOUTS.
IN THE PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS OR
OTHER EMERGENCY SITUATION LONG
TERM CARE RESIDENTS ARE
INCREASINGLY VULNERABLE.
OVERSIGHT BODIES MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO PERFORM THEIR ORDINARY
SUPERVISOR SUPERVISORY FUNCTIONS
IN THE CURRENT PANDEMIC SUPPORT
PERSONS HAVE OFTEN BEEN BARRED
FROM VISITING AT A TIME WHEN
RESIDENTS NEEDED THEM THE MOST.
DURING THE PANDEMIC THERE WERE A
STAGGERING NUMBER OF ALL
FACILITY LETTERS PUT OUT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THE
MAJORITY IMPACTING CARE IN
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. THE
S. S. PUT OUT PROVIDER
INFORMATION NOTICES AN
EXPONENTIALLY GREATER NUMBERS AS
WELL. CARE FACILITIES WERE
DEALING WITH COVERT NINETEEN
OUTBREAKS INCREASED INFECTION
PROTOCOLS STAFFING SHORTAGES AND
MORE. AS NURSING HOMES AND
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES WERE
ATTEMPTING TO FOLLOW GUIDELINES
SET FORTH BY DPH AND THE SS. THE
IMPORTNCE OF IN PERSON
VISITATION WAS COMPLETELY
FORGOTEN. THE MORBIDITY
ASSOCIATED WITH COVERT NINETEEN
ISOLATION IS STILL DATA THAT
ROOM YET REMAINS ELUSIVE. AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX AUTHORIZES
A FACILITY TO REQUIRED
DESIGNATED SUPPORT PERSONS TO
GREATER INFECTION CONTROL
PROTOCOLS REQUIRED OF CARE STAFF
DURING A PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
AND ALL INFECTION CONTROL
PROTOCOLS MUST BE COMMUNICATED.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX OUR
TONY CHICKEN TELL REPRESENTING
KENNER AND DENISE SPOKE ON
REPRESENTING THE ESSENTIAL
CHARACTER FOR COALITION. PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
MY NAME'S TONY TICKET TELL EM
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY FOR
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES FOR NURSING
HOME REFORM. AB TWO FIVE FOUR
SIX IS ABOUT CORRECTING A
MISTAKE A HORRIBLE MISTAKE.
MISTAKE THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS CONTINUE TO CLING TO.
A MISTAKE IS ASSUMING THAT
DESIGNATED SUPPORT PEOPLE ARE NO
MORE VALUABLE ARE ARE ARE LESS
VALUABLE. THAN THE FACILITIES
STAFF. PUBLIC HEALTH OF THIS
COULD NOT BE MORE WRONG ABOUT
THIS SUPPORT PERSON VISITORS
PERFORM MANY OF THE SAME
SERVICES. THAT THE SAID THAT
FACILITIES STAFF PROVIDED TO
KEEP RESIDENTS SAFE AND ALIVE
AND THEY BRING THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING FOR RESIDENT
WELL BEING LOVE. PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS WHO NEVER CONSULT WITH
ACTUAL RESIDENTS OR THEIR
FAMILIES AND CRAFTING THEIR
MISGUIDED SUPPORT PERSON
LOCKOUTS. SIMPLY HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT FAMILY MEMBERS BRING. A
LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
RESIDENTS. IS OFFICIALS ARE
COMPLETELY IN CURIOUS ABOUT REAL
RESIDENT EXPERIENCES AND HAVE
FAILED TO GRASP. THAT SUPPORT
PERSON HELP IS NOT A LUXURY IT%
IS ESSENTIAL. PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS HAVE NOT ACCOUNTED FOR
THE AWFUL HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
FOR ISOLATING LONG TERM CARE
RESIDENTS FROM THE PEOPLE WHO
CARE ABOUT THE MOST. I'VE NOT
SEEN IT WILL STATE OR LOCAL
HEALTH ORDER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN- TALKED ABOUT THE AFL'S
IN THE PENS. THAT ACTUALLY STUCK
TO A STUDY A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OR ANY QUANTITATIVE
ANALYSIS. THE ORDERS ARE NOT
BASED ON EVIDENCE AND DATA THERE
BASED ON HUNCHES AND HOPELESSLY
NARROW VIEW OF WHAT SUPPORT
PERSONS DO. THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IS WRONG THIS BILL DOES
NOT PROHIBIT LOCKDOWNS IN A
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. THE
BILL DOES NOT PREVENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AUTHORITIES FROM IMPOSING
ANY INFECTION CONTROL MEASURES
THAT THEY FEEL ARE NECESSARY.
WHAT AB TWO FIVE FOUR SIX DOES
IS REQUIRE MEASURES AFFECTING
DESIGNATED SUPPORT PERSON ACCESS
THE APPLIED EQUALLY TO
FACILITIES STAFF. AB TWO FIVE
FOUR SIX IS NOT ABOUT LIMITING
PUBLIC HEALTH IT'S ABOUT EQUAL
TREATMENT FOR SUPPORT PERSON
VISITORS. RECOGNIZING THAT
SUPPORT PERSONS ARE JUST AS
IMPORTANT OF THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF THE RESIDENTS AS THE
FACILITIES STAFF. THAT THEY
BEGIN THE SAME ACCESS AND IT TO
BE POTENTIALLY HELD TO THE SAME
RESTRICTIONS ON THEIR
INTERACTIONS. GIVING A SUPPORT
PERSON THE SAME ACCESS IS A
RIGHTEOUS CONCEPT STATES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY ARE
ADOPTING DESIGNATED SUPPORT
PERSON BILLS. IN TEXAS THE 88%
OF THE VOTERS AMENDED THEIR
CONSTITUTION TO ALLOW FOR
SUPPORT PERSON ACCESS. THE
COMMITTEE IS PROPOSING A
WORKGROUP THAT KICKS THE CAN
DOWN THE ROAD FOR ANOTHER YEAR
WHILE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS LIVE WITH THE IN
SECURITY. THAT THEIR ABILITY TO
RECEIVE LIFE SUSTAINING CARE
LOVE MAY BE TAKEN AWAY ON THE
WHIMS OF PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS.
WHO HAVE NEVER SET FOOT NOT ONCE
IN A LONG TERM CARE FACILITY IN
PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY. THE
LEGISLATURE IS A WORKGROUP THE
LEGISLATURE IS THE CHECK ON
ARBITRARY RULES HANDED DOWN BY
THE BUREAUCRATS. IT'S SAD THAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S ROLE IS BEING
DELEGATED. AND THAT WILL HAVE TO
WAIT ANOTHER YEAR WHERE FAMILY
MEMBERS ARE LOCKED OUT AND HAVE
TO LOOK WATCH THEIR LOVED ONES
DIE. OVER FACETIME. I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY DESERT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MISSOURIAN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND FOR
HIS STEADFAST COMMITMENT THAT
SUPPORT PERSON SHOULD BE TREATED
EQUALLY AS FACILITIES STAFF
THANK YOU. GERMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM DENISE BOGAN FROM
RIVERSIDE AND I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SIX. IT'S A HUMAN RIGHT TO BE
WITH OUR LOVED ONES. LIKE
THOUSANDS OF OTHERS MY MAMA
GABBY LEWIS AND MY YOUNG NIECE
KELLY SMITH HAD THIS RIGHT TAKEN
AWAY. THOUGH THE DETAILS. MAKE
THEIR STORY THE HORRORS OF
ISOLATION ARE COMMON DINNERS
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. MOM'S DEMENTIA KEPT
HER IN. IN A NURSING HOME PRIOR
TO LOCK DOWN HER DAUGHTER'S
PARTNERED EVERY DAY WITH THEIR
CNA'S TO ASSIST WITH DAILY
NEEDS. NURSES GAVE MEDICATIONS
BUT WE CLOSELY OBSERVED HER FOR
SIDE EFFECTS. MOM ATE VERY
LITTLE UNLESS WE WERE THERE TO
ENCOURAGE EVERY BITE. ANXIOUS IN
THE WE REASSURED HER WITH
FAVORITE SONGS AND FAMILY
STORIES WE TUCKER IN WITH HER
YELLOW AFGHAN AND PLACED HER
ROSARY BEADS IN HER HANDS WE
WERE HER COMFORT AND HER JOY WE
WERE NOT JUST VISITORS ALL OF
THIS STOPPED WHEN THE LOCKDOWN
WAS IMPOSED ON MARCH THIRTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY SEVERING MOM FROM
HER DAUGHTERS WAS DEVASTATING WE
WITNESSED MOM'S DAILY SUFFERING
THROUGH A FACEBOOK PORTAL. WE
WATCHED HELPLESSLY AS MOM
DECLINED SHE USE WORDS THAT WE
NEVER HEARD CROSSED HER LIPS
BEFORE LIKE I'M MISERABLE LOT
I'M LONELY IT'S ANOTHER NO
NOTHING DAYS SHE WOULD SAY MOM
WOULD CRY AND SOMETIMES
COMPLETELY WITHDRAW TO SATTAR
CONFUSED VIDEO CHAT. THE
LOCKDOWN KEPT US OUT BUT NOT
CORONAVIRUS STAFF EXPOSED MAMA
SHE SUFFERED ALL THAT YOU MIGHT
IMAGINE AND ON JANUARY SEVENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SHE TOOK HER
LAST BREATH WHILE HER SIX ADULT
CHILDREN WATCHED THROUGH
FACEBOOK PORTAL MAMA DIED
COMPLETELY ALONE. NO ONE
DESERVES THAT. FIVE MONTHS AFTER
MOM'S DEATH ANOTHER TRAGEDY MY
YOUNG NIECE KELLY SMITH SUFFERED
A BRAIN INJURY SHE IS NOW
PARALYZED FULLY RELIANT ON LIFE
SUPPORT AND RESIDES IN A NURSING
HOME. SHE WAS THOUGHT TO BE
MENTALLY INCOMPETENT AND
UNCOMMUNICATIVE BY DOCTORS AND
STAFF THAT IS UNTIL HER LOVED
ONES WERE ALLOWED TO BE WITH HER
. WE NOTICED KELLY WAS FULLY
AWARE OF EVERYTHING GOING ON WE
CURRENTLY WORK WITH HEARD DAY IN
AND DAY AND NIGHT DILIGENTLY.
KELLY NEEDS US SHE COMMUNICATES
TO THE WORLD THROUGH US. REALLY
IS BEEN HOSPITALIZED SEVERAL
TIMES DURING HER NURSING HOME
STAY DUE TO COMPLICATIONS. IT IS
HER LOVED ONES THAT I'VE NOTICED
CHANGES IN KELLY AND HAVE
BROUGHT IT TO THE MEDICAL STAFF
EVERY TIME ONCE AGAIN WE'RE NOT
JUST VISITORS WERE ESSENTIAL
CARE GIVERS. KELLY LIKE MY MOM
HAS ALSO BEEN DENIED ACCESS TO
US EVERY CHANGING INFECTION
CONTROL PROTOCOLS HAVE KEPT US
AT BAY WE HAD TO PURCHASE OUR
OWN COLBY TESTS AT TIMES. THE
INEQUITIES ITS ACT OF
EXPECTATIONS BETWEEN US AND
STAFF WERE GLARING AT TIMES
REQUIRED TO WEAR FULL PP WE
OFTEN SAW REPAIR MEN GO IN AND
OUT OF THE BUILDING WITHOUT
ANYTHING. WEARING GLOVES TO HOLD
KELLY'S HAND I OFTEN WATCH STAFF
TOO BUSY AND TOO WEARY TO PUT
THEIR GLOVES ON. EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE FORTY SIX- THAT BOULDER AND
TERM CARE ALWAYS MAINTAIN THEIR
HUMAN RIGHT TO BE CARED FOR BY
FAMILY. AS A CENTRAL CARE GIVERS
OUR GOAL IS TO IMPROVE THE
SAFETY AND HEALTH OF OUR LOVED
ONES AS IS THE GOAL OF PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS. ARE SUPPORT
SHOULD BE WELCOMED WE POSED LESS
INFECTION RISK THEN THEN STAFF
BECAUSE WE TAKE THE SAME
PRECAUTIONS BUT ONLY SPEND TIME
WITH ONE RESIDENT. IN HONOR OF
MY MOM GABBY LEWIS AND MY NIECE
KELLY SMITH PLEASE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX SO MUCH
SUFFERING AND DEATH CAN BE
AVOIDED. TO THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBERS SUPPORT-
CHAMBER HEARING ROOM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION- JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON PLUG SIT ON
YES IT'S ON THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON BLANCA CASTRO WITH THE
STATE LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
IN STRONG SUPPORT AS IT WAS
WRITTEN AT. THANK YOU IT. THE
AUTHOR HAS ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS THE BILLS BEFORE US
SO. RICHARD SU SAN FRANCISCO
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN SAYS
HOUSTON STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
. GOOD EVENING NATALIE WEISSMAN-
FOR ON BEHALF OF ESSENTIAL
CAREGIVERS COALITION CO SPONSOR
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
ONE REPRESENTING HEALTH OFFICE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WHAT WE
INITIALLY HAD A OPPOSE UNLESS A
MAN BUT WITH THE AMENDMENTS WE
WERE MOVING OPPOSITION THANK YOU. KELLY BROKE SOME F. OF THE
ACT- COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
WANT TO TAKE THAT THE AUTHOR THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS. WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS JACK WILL BE REMOVING
THEIR OPPOSITION THANK YOU. YOUR
ANYONE ELSE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
NONE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
. LEADING MOTION BY MISS WALDRON
A SECOND BY MR ROD REGUS MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH I CLOSED
MISTER. YEAH MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS FOR. WANTING TO
SUPPORT THE BILL MOVE FORWARD I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
WORKING WITH YOU. I JUST I KNOW
IT'S A LONG COMMITTEE HEARING
BUT I JUST WOULD LIKE TO ALSO.
AND BY SAYING THAT- WE NOTE HERE
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS.
AND IT WAS PROVEN VERY WELL TO
US OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST
TWO YEARS. LOT OF GOVERNANCE
TIMES ALSO INCLUDES TRIAL AND
ERROR. AND SO WE TRIED SOME
THINGS AND IT DIDN'T WORK. SO
WE'RE THE BETTER FOR IT AT THIS
POINT. SO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THIS IS ERIN- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WOOD I AND I WALDRON WALDRON I.
ARAMBULA BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
CAREER. LARA MAIENSCHEIN MAYES
MAYES AYE MCCARTY. NAZARIAN HI
NAZARIAN I REQUEST I GUESS
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO. GARCIA.
SIX ZERO SIX THOSE WHO LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. MISTER MURATSUCHI I SEE YOUR
BACK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB TWO TWO
TWO ZERO TO ESTABLISH A HOMELESS
COURTS PILOT PROGRAM A GRANT
PILOT PROGRAM TO BE ADMINISTERED
BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL FOR
KARANA KLAY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
INVOLVED WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. V. COMMITTEE
SAYS POINTS OUT THAT THERE ARE
FOR OVER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
ALMOST COURTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF HAVING ONE OF THEM. ARE THEY
CITY OF REDONDO BEACH HAS SIX A
LAUNCHED A SUCCESSFUL HOMELESS
COURT PROGRAM WHERE THEY PROVIDE
WRAPAROUND SERVICES INCLUDING
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. FOR A
CRIMINAL DEFENDANTS THAT- HAVE.
BEEN CHARGED WITH- WITH MINOR OF
QUALITY OF LIFE- IT TYPE CRIMES-
BUT- WE KNOW THAT- THIS IS NOT A
NEW PROGRAM WE KNOW THAT TO AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY THERE IS A
ALSO A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
HOMELESS COURT PROGRAM. A SAN
DIEGO WAS ONE OF THE FIRST IN
THE STATE TO ESTABLISH THIS. AND
SO- BUT WITH THIS TRACK RECORD
THE CHIEF JUSTICE IS WORKING
GROUP ON HOMELESSNESS AS
RECOMMENDED IN FACT THIS
HOMELESS COURT A PILOT PROGRAM
TO BE FUNDED. A WITH ME- HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS A MICHAEL WEBB CITY
ATTORNEY OF THE CITY OF REDONDO
BEACH WHO HAS SPEARHEADED THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IN REDONDO
BEACH. AND ALSO TIFFANY SIGN ON
THE SUPER OF THE SUPERVISING
ATTORNEY WITH THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE.
PROSECUTOR AND PUBLIC DEFENDER
SIDE BY SIDE IN SUPPORT OF THE
HOMELESS COURT PROGRAM. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WEDDING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TIFFANY SENATE I AM A PUBLIC
DEFENDER FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS.
MAY SUPERVISE SOME OF OUR PUBLIC
DEFENDER PROGRAMS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. AN
INTERSECTION EXISTS BETWEEN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
HOMELESSNESS AND TWENTY NINETEEN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE FOUND. THAT
50% OF OUR MISDEMEANOR CLIENTS
WERE UN HOUSED A SECONDARY STUDY
IN TWENTY NINETEEN FOUND THAT
FIFTY PERCENT. OF A MISDEMEANOR
MENTAL HEALTH DIVERT. FUNDS WERE
ALSO AND HOUSED IN 99% LIVED IN
QUALIFIED OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
RECOGNIZING THIS INTERSECTION IN
A NEED TO LINK OUR CLIENTS WHO
SUPPORTED SERVICES. WE DEVELOPED
A PRE TRIAL SUPPORT PROGRAM WITH
OLIVER JUSTICE PARTNERS SOCIAL
SERVICE AGENCIES SUPERIOR COURT
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. OVER THE PAST
YEAR WE HAVE USE LAW STUDENTS TO
GO INTO CUSTODY AND ASSESS OVER
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED PEOPLE USING
AND FOR EVIDENCE BASED TOOLS TO
IDENTIFY THEIR NEEDS WHAT WE
FOUND WAS THIS. 51% OF THE
PEOPLE IN CUSTODY NEEDED MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT 43% NEEDED
SUBSTANCE USE SUPPORT 46% NEEDED
HOUSING SUPPORT IN 83% NEEDED
FOLLOW UP WITH THE SOCIAL WORKER
. ONCE WE IDENTIFY THESE NEEDS
BILLION CLIENTS TO OUR PUBLIC
DEFENDERS SOCIAL WORKER TEAM.
WITH TO POSTAL WORKERS A HANDFUL
OF SOCIAL WORKER AND LAW STUDENT
INTERNS AN IMMENSE COLLABORATION
FORMER SUPERIOR COURT JUSTICE
PARTNERS AND SOCIAL SERVICE
AGENCIES TOGETHER WE LINK TO
FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
INDIVIDUALS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT. WE LINKED TWO HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE TO SUBSTANCE USE
SUPPORT. AND WE FOUND TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO PEOPLE
HOUSING. THIS YEAR WE HAVE ALSO
RECALLED WARRANTS AND OVER THREE
HUNDRED INFRACTIONS CHANGING
FINES AND FEES TO COMMUNITY
SERVICE ROB MOBILE LEGAL
HOMELESS CLINIC. WE'VE SUPPORTED
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND HOUSE
CLIENTS WITH RECORD MODIFICATION
SO THAT WE CAN REMOVE THE
BARRIERS THESE CONVICTIONS GREAT
FOR EMPLOYMENT SERVICES AND
HOUSING. ADDITIONALLY WE OPEN UP
A ONE STOP SHOP WITH PARTNERS SO
THAT SERVICES CAN BE FOUND ONE
RULE FOR A MISDEMEANOR MENTAL
HEALTH POPULATION. WHAT WE HAVE
LEARNED THROUGH ALL OF THIS IS
THAT THERE IS AN INTERSECTION
BETWEEN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AND
HOMELESSNESS. BUT WITH HOLISTIC
MULTI PRONGED MULTI SYSTEMIC
APPROACH WE CAN CHANGE LIVES WE
CAN IMPROVE PUBLIC SAFETY AND WE
CAN HELP SUPPORT THIS STATE AND
ARE HOMELESS CRISIS. THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANKS THANK YOU
CHAIR WOULD IN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MIKE WELL BEHIND THE
CITY ATTORNEY FOR THE CITY OF
REDONDO BEACH. IN MY THIRTY FIVE
YEARS OF WORKING IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM I HAVE NOT SEEN
ANYTHING WHERE THE INTEREST OF
EVERYONE IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM ALIGN DEFENDANT'S DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS PROSECUTORS IN THE
COMMUNITY. MEMBERS ARE ALL-
SEEKING THE SAME GOAL WHICH IS
TO REMOVE AS MANY OF THE
OBSTACLES PREVENTING THE ON
HOUSE FROM. PEENING HOUSING. IN
THE DIFFICULTY IN CALIFORNIA IS
THERE ARE SO MANY PROGRAMS THAT
WORK IN SILENCE IT BECOMES VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ANNOUNCED
INDIVIDUAL NOT ONLY IS ON HOUSE
BUT WE MAY BE SUFFERING FROM OF
ONE OR MORE ISSUES WHETHER IT BE
MENTAL HEALTH FOR DRUG ADDICTION
TO BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE THROUGH-
THROUGH THE SYSTEM. ARE- THE
APPROACH TO ALMOST COURT IS WE
MOVED OUTDOORS AND WE ORIGINALLY
DID IT BECAUSE THE PANDEMIC BUT
WHAT WE QUICKLY LEARNED WAS THAT
BY BRINGING THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
INTO THE COMMUNITY NEAR WHERE
THEY ON HOUSE ALREADY WERE WE
HAD BETTER RESULTS IT WAS AA
IT'S A COURT BUT IT'S A COURT IN
A PARKING LOT IN ITS AGREE AND
IT'S A SITUATION WHERE. IT'S-
LESS THREATENING AND WE BRING
ALL THE ADDITIONAL SERVICES AND
WE'RE ADDING MORE EVERY DAY. TO
MAKE THE PERSON NOT GIVE FIVE
REFERENCES OF YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
COULD DO THIS EVERYTHING'S RIGHT
THERE ADDITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELLING DRUG ADDICTION
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH-
THAT JOB PLACEMENT FOR THE
PEOPLE AS THEY PROGRESS THROUGH
SO WE'RE- TRYING TO SET THEM UP
FOR SUCCESS. AND THAT'S WHY YOU
THINK BY ELIMINATING THE SILOS
WHY IT WORKS SO WELL AND WHY
EVERYBODY IS SO. SUPPORTIVE OF
IT- WE'RE A SMALLER CITY BUT
WE'RE FULL SERVICE WE HAVE OUR
OWN PROSECUTION POLICE FIRE
HOUSING AUTHORITY SO WE'RE GOOD-
SMALLER MODEL TO PILOT IT'S NOW
BEING TESTED IN A TORRANCE OUR
LARGEST NEIGHBOUR IN LONG BEACH
THE SECOND LARGEST CITY. IN LA I
THINK THIS I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THAT WOULD ENABLE THAT SORT
OF PUBLIC PROJECT HE BE ADOPTED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE FOUND
THAT OURS IS PRE PLEA BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO ENTER A GUILTY
PLEA AND WE FOUND THAT. OVER 71%
OF THE PEOPLE REFERRED SHOW UP
AND ACCEPT SERVICES. AND IN A
STUNNING STATISTIC THE AMOUNT OF
DEFENDANTS WHO ARE ENCOUNTERED
THAT SHOW UP. IS AT A LOW OF
EIGHTY PERCENT. SOMETIMES IS A
100% WHICH YOU JUST DON'T SEE IN
ANY SORT OF COURT PROCEEDINGS
SO- WE'RE SETTING THEM UP FOR
SUCCESS IT WOULD BE A GREAT
MODEL TO TRY AND BRING ALL THE
SERVICES. IN ONE PLACE AND I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THERE ANY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. SEE ANY
OF OTHERS WHO WERE REFLECTED
SOME EITHER EXPRESS SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION MR NAME ONLY. NAME
POSITION. ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT ONE. HI L. A. R. K.
IDOL WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT YOU. ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO
ONE WE WILL- BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
. REYES I JUST WANT IS WONDERFUL
BILL- AND IF YOU'D BE INCLINED
ALLOWED TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR. THANK YOU. CAN I TAKE
THAT AS A MOTION. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE. OKAY MISTER
NAZARIAN THANK YOU MISTER-
MISTER RICH DIVERSITY THE MET
AND WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND JOY TO DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU OUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AS CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE I JUST I SEE THE
REPUBLICAN CONSULTING WITH
SPRING I KNOW THAT ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE'RE PLANNING TO
ADDRESS- IS TO REMOVE A FELONY.
CRIMES FROM- THIS HOMELESS
CORPORATE PROPOSAL SO- HOPEFULLY
THAT WOULD ADD TO THE SUPPORT
BUT- WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FIVE THANK YOU FOR RESURGENT
MADAM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT
I WOULD AYE WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO YOU LARA MAIENSCHEIN
MAY FORCE HERE I'M SORRY LARA.
LAURA HI. MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY THIS AREA NAZARIAN I.
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO GARCIA. AB ONE BY ONE WILL LEAVE THE
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH. RAMOS WHICH LIKE TO
PROVIDE A REAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- HERE TODAY.
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN I WANT TO START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE YOUR
STAFF'S EXCELLENT WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS- ADDITIONALLY I WANT TO
COMMIT TO ADDRESSING THE
COMMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS BY
COMMITTEE AND WILL ADDRESS
THOSE- POLICY QUESTIONS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IN THE PROCESS. IN
KENTUCKY. IT CONTINUED- AND WORK
WITH THE MINISTRATION- TO BETTER
BUILD A BETTER BILL. AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTEEN WOULD ESTABLISH
A LICENSING PATH AND ENSURE MUCH
NEEDED FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
CHILDREN CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS. CURRENTLY AN ESTIMATED
THREE OUT OF EVERY FOUR CHILDREN
IN THE U. S. WHO NEED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES DO NOT RECEIVE
THEM. SUICIDE IS NOW THE SECOND
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
ADOLESCENTS. FORTY SEVEN OUT OF
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES HAVE NO
CHILD PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL
INPATIENT BEDS FOR CHILDREN
UNDER TWELVE. ON THE HEELS OF
THE US SURGEON GENERAL'S DIRE
WARNING ABOUT THE GROWING MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AMONG YOU. WHICH
HAS WORSENED DUE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. CRUCIAL
MENTAL HEALTH REFORM IS NEEDED.
IT IS NOW MORE VITAL THAN EVER
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER. AT CARE AND THE NEED
FOR CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH
RESIDENTIAL INTERVENTIONS WHICH
COULD NOT BE MORE URGENT THAN
WHAT WE'RE SEEING TODAY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN WHAT AT THE
PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM AS A LICENSING
OPTION FOR CHILDREN'S PRICES
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS. WITH THE
APPROPRIATE LICENSING CATEGORIES
ESTABLISHED THE STATE AND
COUNTIES WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS CRITICAL COMPONENT OF THE
CONTINUUM OF MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS SERVICES UNDER MEDICARE
OUT EARLY AND PERIODIC SCREENING
DIAGNOSIS ENTRY. WHICH IS A
FEDERAL AND A FEDERAL
ENTITLEMENT. I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH SECRETARY GOLLY AS WE
HAD A CONVERSATION ON THURSDAY
OF LAST WEEK TO CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS- IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND- TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A BILL THAT THAT REALLY-
SUFFICES IN AND- MEETS THE NEEDS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JOINING ME TODAY IS ADRIAN
SHELTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHAAT CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND AB BLOMBERG
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL. THANK YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD GOOD EVENING ADRIAN
SHELTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES. WE REPRESENT ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE.
THAT ARE SERVING CHILDREN AND
YOUTH AND FAMILIES IN PUBLIC
HUMAN SERVICES SYSTEMS. OUR
MEMBERS ARE SERVING SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN OUR MEDICAL PROGRAM.
AND THEY'RE SEEING HIGHER ACUITY
AND MORE INTENSE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS THAN EVER BEFORE
WHERE THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN. THIS BILL WOULD ADD A
NEW LICENSURE CATEGORY CALLED
THE PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITY OR THE P. R.
T. F. SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING
CHILDREN'S CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS. THESE PROGRAMS ARE
CRITICALLY NEEDED TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY HOSPITALIZATIONS
ENABLE CHILDREN AND YOUTH TO
ACCESS MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES IN
A TIMELY MANNER. ESTABLISHING A
NEW LICENSURE CATEGORY IS
NECESSARY FOR COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES. TO
DEVELOP THE SHORT TERM CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS THE NEED
EXISTED WELL BEFORE THE COVERT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND CONTINUES
TO BE EVEN MORE NEEDED NOW. IN A
STUDY OF CRISIS SERVICES PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
HIGHLIGHTED THAT FORTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN WERE BEING HOSPITALIZED
EVERY YEAR. AND THE SAME STUDY
IDENTIFIED JUST SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR BEDS AVAILABLE FOR
CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
STATEWIDE- AS MISTER RAMOS
STATED WE- SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEE CHAI AND THE STAFF-
TO FURTHER STRENGTHEN THIS BILL
AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH. A BROAD ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS PUTTING THOSE THAT
RAISE CONCERNS. ADDRESS THOSE AS
WE MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD.
BERMAN THAT'S- THREE MUCH PLEASE
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING MISTER TURN
MEMBERS AMY BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA RUNS HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION CCHA REPRESENTS THE
EIGHT PRIVATE NONPROFIT
FREESTANDING CHILDREN'S
HOSPITALS IN THE STATE'S
APPROXIMATELY 62% OF OUR
PATIENTS ARE ON MEDICAID. AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTEEN RECENTLY
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS HAVE SEEN A
DRAMATIC INCREASE AND PEDIATRIC
PATIENTS IN PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS
FOR EXAMPLE FROM 202-120-2220
TWENTY ONE AT CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL OF ORANGE COUNTY OR
CHALK. THERE WAS A 27% INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF KIDS PRESENTING
TO THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND
JUST THE FIRST SEVEN MONTHS OF
THIS FISCAL YEAR THERE'S BEEN
ANOTHER 24% INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF PEDIATRIC PATIENTS IN
CRISIS PRESENTING AT THE E. D.
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN BEING
HOSPITALISED FOR EATING
DISORDERS IS ALSO VERY ALARMING.
FROM TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT SHOCKED THERE WAS
A HUNDRED AND 8% INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN BEING
HOSPITALISED FOR EATING
DISORDERS. AND THIS YEAR'S CASES
ARE KEEPING PACE FOR ANOTHER
100% INCREASE FROM LAST YEAR.
OVERALL IN THE PAST FIFTEEN
YEARS CHOCK HAS SEEN A FOUR
HUNDRED AND 50% INCREASE OF
CHILDREN BEING HOSPITALISED FOR
EATING DISORDERS. THERE ARE MANY
POSSIBLE SOLUTIONS OF HOW TO
ADDRESS THE SURGE AND- DEATRICH
PSYCHIATRIC NEEDS AND CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL SERVICES ARE A
RESOURCE THAT CAN HELP. MANY OF
THE CHILDREN ARRIVING IN THE E.
R. COULD BE TREATED MORE
EFFECTIVELY IN A RESIDENTIAL
SETTING PROVIDING QUALITY AND
SAFE CARE AND ALSO RESERVING THE
LIMITED INPATIENT PSYCHIATRIC
BEDS FOR THE KIDS THAT NEED IT
MOST. ACCESS TO CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL BEDS IF AN EFFECTIVE
DISCHARGE ACTION FOR PATIENTS
THAT REQUIRED INPATIENT
HOSPITALIZATION RIGHT NOW MANY
COMMERCIAL INJURED PATIENTS HAVE
THIS AS AN OPTION THAT IS USE
REGULARLY WHEN STEPPING DOWN TO
ONCE A WEEK OR ONCE A MONTH
THERAPY IS TOO BIG OF A DROP.
UNFORTUNATELY ACCESS RESIDENTS
THIS IS BEDS IS NOT COVERED FOR
MEDICAL PATIENTS FOR THESE KIDS
THE MAIN OPTION IS GOING TO FROM
TWENTY FOUR HOUR SUPERVISION AND
A LOCKED IN PATIENT UNITS BEING
A THERAPIST EVERY FEW WEEKS AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE THIS IS NOT
SUCCESSFUL FOR MANY PATIENTS
AND- RETURNING TO THE ER OR
IMPATIENCE THANK YOU TRICK UNIT.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN WHAT
ADVIL PORTENT TOOL TO ASSIST
PEDIATRIC PATIENTS IN CRISIS FOR
THESE REASONS CCHA SUPPORTS AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE.
VERY MUCH- I DON'T SEE I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- ANYONE IN THE
CHAMBER CARE TO ADD. TESTIMONY
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME. POSITION ON THE BILL AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. MANAUS GOOD ATHLETIC
CONFERENCE ON SUPPORT THANK YOU
. L. A. K. I. BILL WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TONIGHT
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. JANE DINNER WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. KELLY
BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. TYLER READY
WITH THAT CALIFORNIA ASOCIATION
OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NICOLE WATERMAN ON
BEHALF OF SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. TARA
GAMBLE EASTMAN WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE SEE
ANYBODY WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER MAYES BUT WE'LL
TAKE THAT AS A SECOND WAS
RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU. WYCHECK
CLOSE THANK ASKRI RIVAL. I WAS
QUICK YEAH ALL RIGHT WELL ALL
RIGHT OKAY MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL OF MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SO I WAS IN TOO
QUICK TO. WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW I
CARILLO. LAURA LAURA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY THIS AREA. NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO GARCIA. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO YOU'RE CLOSER THAN A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE BEEN AND I'M
SORRY OKAY THANK YOU TO THE MOST
ALONG CHAU THANK YOU COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU. AFTER REGULAR
WOULD YOU LIKE 2%
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HE
PREFERS I START WITH AB NINETEEN
THIRTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AB
NINETEEN THIRTY INSURERS EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS A HEALTHY START
TO LIFE BY EXTENDING COVERAGE OF
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL SERVICES
PROGRAM C. P. S. P. TO A ONE
YEAR POSTPARTUM. PERINATAL CARE
IS HEALTHCARE FOR PREGNANT
PERSONS FROM PRENATAL TO POST
PARTUM. IT ALLOWS PRACTITIONERS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DETECT MONITOR
AND TO ADDRESS HEALTH CONDITIONS
AND BEHAVIORS THAT CAN IMPACT
PREGNANCY MATERNAL HEALTH AND
NEWBORN AND INFANT HEALTH
OUTCOMES. CALIFORNIA'S
COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL SERVICES
PROGRAM OR C. P. S. P. IS A
BENEFIT FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES WHO BECOME
PREGNANT. C. P. S. P.
PARTICIPANTS ARE PROVIDED
WRAPAROUND PERINATAL SERVICES.
AND SERVICES ARE AVAILABLE FROM
THE DATE OF CONCEPTION THROUGH
SIXTY DAYS FOLLOWING THE END OF
THEIR PREGNANCY. AB NINETEEN
THIRTY WOULD EXTEND COVERAGE FOR
C. P. S. P. SERVICES FROM SIXTY
DAYS TO ONE YEAR POSTPARTUM.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB.
NINETEEN THIRTY ARE LUCY KWASI
MELA OF MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS AND SHANNON SHARPE
PACE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HER
HEALTH FIRST. IS PUSH THE BUTTON
THERE THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR ARAMBULA OF MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LUCY QUINTANILLA ON
BEHALF OF MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS BY PROVIDING
MEDICARE L. C. P. S. P. BENEFIT
NOT JUST FOR THE FIRST SIXTY
DAYS POSTPARTUM. AT WHOLE FIRST
YEAR INCLUDING WITH IN HOME AND
COMMUNITY SERVICES THIS IS THE
WAY FOR THE STATE TO MAKE GOOD
ON ITS PROMISE FOR TWELVE MONTH
POSTPARTUM COVERAGE AS DR
ARAMBULA MENTION CPS P. IS A
REIMBURSABLE MEDICAL BENEFIT. IT
PROVIDES PSYCHOSOCIAL AND OTHER
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES NON MEDICAL
SUPPORT AND NONMEDICAL SUPPORTS
THAT WRAPAROUND OBSTETRICAL
ANOTHER CARE CPS P. IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ADDRESSING SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH WHICH
HAVE AN OUTSIZED IMPACT ON
PHYSICAL HEALTH THINGS LIKE FOOD
AND SECURITY HOUSING AND
SECURITY ESCAPING FROM VIOLENCE.
OF PARENTS WHO ARE WORKING TWO
AND THREE JOBS AND HAVE TROUBLE
WHICH PERTAIN GETTING TO MEDICAL
CARE THESE ARE ESSENTIAL CPS P.
IS ALSO THE PRIMARY WAY THAT
MEDICARE REIMBURSES FOR
BREASTFEEDING AND LACTATION
SUPPORT WHICH OF COURSE MANY
CITIES DEMONSTRATE IS ESSENTIAL
TO BOTH MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH AND SAVES ON HEALTHCARE
SERVICES IN THE LONG TERM. C. P.
S. P.'S CASE COORDINATION
BENEFIT ALSO HELPS WITH THINGS
LIKE GETTING PEOPLE TO SPECIALTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WHEN THEY
NEED THEM. NON CLINT SO TEAM
UNDER CPS P. INCLUDES
COMPREHENSIVE PERINATAL SERVICES
WORKERS THIS ALLOWS THE DOCTORS
NURSES PSYCHIATRISTS TO WORK AT
THE TOP OF THEIR LICENSES
KNOWING THAT THEIR PATIENTS CAN
GET THE PSYCHOSOCIAL SUPPORTS
THEY NEED. THE NATIONALLY
ACCLAIMED CALIFORNIA MATERNAL
QUALITY CARE COLLABORATIVE AND
THE FEDERAL AGENCY THAT OVERSEES
META CALCIUM MASS HAVE BEEN
ENCOURAGING STATES TO ADOPT
PROGRAMS LIKE C. P. S. P. FOR
THE TWELVE MONTH POST PREGNANCY
COVERAGE. OVER ONE HALF OF
MATERNAL DEATHS OCCUR. BETWEEN
THE FIRST DAY AND UP THROUGH THE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIFTH DAY
DURING POST THE POST PARTUM
PERIOD AND BLACK MOTHERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE NOW DYING AT A
RATE OF ALMOST SIX TIMES THAT OF
OTHER GROUPS. MENTAL HEALTH IS A
PARTICULAR CONCERN DURING THAT
FIRST YEAR 83% OF THE MATERNAL
SUICIDES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN
FAR BEYOND THE FIRST SIXTY DAYS
MOST OF THEM ARE OCCURRING IN
THE FORTY THREE TO THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAY PERIOD WELL
BEYOND WHAT CPS P. IS CURRENTLY
CAPPED AT. AN END 85% OF THESE
MATERNAL SUICIDES PSYCHOSOCIAL
STRESSORS WERE INVOLVED
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP VIOLENCE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE AND I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER NOW TO- SHANNON
SHAW PAYS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF HER HEALTH FIRST OF WHICH
BLACK MOTHERS UNITED IS A
PROJECT. THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING
MY NAME IS SHANNON SHARPE PACE
AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF HER HEALTH FIRST SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON DECREASING
DISPROPORTIONATE AFRICAN
AMERICAN MATERNAL AND INFANT
MORTALITY RATES. ARE PROGRAM
BLACK MOTHERS UNITED FUNDED FOR
OVER EIGHT YEARS BY FIRST FIVE
SACRAMENTO IS MODELED ON C. P.
S. P. AND RELIES ON THE SERVICES
OF PREGNANCY COACHES TO ASSIST
CLIENTS DURING PREGNANCY THREE
FOUR MONTHS POSTPARTUM IN THEIR
HOMES AND COMMUNITY. OUR ABILITY
TO MEET CLIENT'S WHERE THEY'RE
OUT OUTSIDE OF THE CLIP ALLOWS
OUR TEAM TO BUILD XIN SHIPS
BASED ON TRUST AND EMPOWERMENT
LEVERAGING C. P. S. B. TOOLS
LIKE THE INITIAL ASSESSMENT WE
HAVE DEVELOPED A ROBUST DATABASE
AND THROUGH INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION THE FOLLOWING ARE
JUST A COUPLE OF THE
STATISTICALLY SIGNIFICANT
OUTCOMES THAT WE ARE SEEING. ONE
REPORTED NUTRITIONAL
DEFICIENCIES DECREASED FROM 20%
AT PROGRAM INTAKE 26% AT FOLLOW
UP. AND MATERNAL DEPRESSION AS
INDICATED BY THE PH Q. NINE
ASSESSMENT WAS RATED MODERATE OR
HIGH IN 30% OF MOTHERS BEFORE
ENTERING THE PROGRAM. AND AFTER
PROGRAM COMPLETION ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS POSTPARTUM
VERSUS SIXTY DAYS POSTPARTUM BSE
PSP. THIS PERCENTAGE HAS
DECREASED 211% SIXTY DAYS
POSTPARTUM IS SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH
WE KNOW THAT POST PARTUM MOOD
AND ANXIETY DISORDERS DO NOT
OFTEN DISPLAY IMMEDIATELY AFTER
BIRTH AND CAN ADVERSELY AFFECT
INDIVIDUALS THROUGH ONE YEAR
POSTPARTUM WITH NO OPPORTUNITY
FOR SCREENINGS OR SUPPORT.
ADDITIONALLY THIS EXPANSION
WOULD ALLOW PROVIDERS
REIMBURSEMENT FOR ONGOING
LACTATION SUPPORT ASSISTING
PARENTS IN BREASTFEEDING LONGER
IMPROVING PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR BIRTHING
PEOPLE AND DEVELOPMENTAL
OUTCOMES FOR THE BABY.
ADDITIONALLY IT WOULD PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY SUPPORTS TO ENSURE
THAT THE INFANT IS CONNECTED TO
THEIR PEDIATRICIAN RECEIVING
REGULAR WELL CHILD CHECKS
VACCINATIONS AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS IF NOT FOR GRANT
RELIANT PROGRAMS LIKE BLACK
MOTHERS UNITED WHERE ELSE WOULD
OUR FAMILIES GO TO RECEIVE THE
SUPPORTS IT SHOULD BE A PART OF
MEDIC CAL. GIVEN THE OUTCOMES
THAT WE ARE SEEING WITHIN OUR
PROGRAM IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THE C. P. S. P. BENEFIT BE
EXPANDED AT A MINIMUM TO FOUR
MONTHS POSTPARTUM HOWEVER
CONSIDER THE POTENTIAL IMPACT WE
WOULD SEE IF THE BENEFIT WAS
EXPANDED TO SUPPORT. OUR FAMILY
THEN BABIES THROUGHOUT THE FIRST
YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
ANY OPPOSITION RESEARCH THERE'S
NO RESEARCH OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL SO- OTHERS IN SUPPORT. OR
OPPOSITION- JUST YOUR NAME.
LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. ISABEL ARE QUITE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. CITY
HILLARY CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. ANDREA RIVERA SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. KELLY BROOKS WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NICOLE
WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP ALSO A CO
SPONSOR YOUR- CUT THE MUSTARD
FIRST FIVE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT YOUR-
SEVERAL BY THEM A PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. JANE CAN- WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
YOUR. DEMAND REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE SEE AND NO ONE WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OF THE
AUTHOR. YOU'RE A MOTION BY
MISSION IS ARIANNA SECOND BY MR
RODRIGUEZ MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS SUBJECT CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THAT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD AYE WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA ALL RIGHT
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO
CARILLO. LARA LARA I MAIENSCHEIN
. MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. GARCIA
GARCIA I. SEVEN TWO ONE SEVEN
WORK STILL TEETERING ON THE EDGE
HERE OF THINGS SO- ANYWAY THANK
YOU- DOCTOR REGULAR HOW ABOUT-
A. B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY PLEASE
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SIX. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY WILL HELP REDUCE RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN FUTURE RECOVERY
RESPONSE AND REPAIR EFFORTS
FOLLOWING STATE AND LOCAL
EMERGENCIES. COBIT NINETEEN
REVEALED THE CRACKS IN OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THEIR DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS
ON DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
OUR LACK OF A COMPREHENSIVE AND
COLLABORATIVE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
SYSTEM OF CARE EXACERBATED THE
INEQUITIES AND DISPROPORTIONATE
ALITY THAT HISTORICALLY
DISINVEST DID COMMUNITIES FACED.
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY WILL
PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK FOR THE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF
EMERGENCY FUNDS MOVING FORWARD.
BY EVALUATING WHERE CALIFORNIA
EXCELLED AND WHERE IT FELL SHORT
IN SUPPORTING DISADVANTAGED DIS
INVESTED COMMUNITIES THE
RECOMMENDATIONS DEVELOPED BY THE
WORKING GROUP THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES WILL DRAFT A MORE
EQUITABLE RESPONSE TO FUTURE
EMERGENCIES. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
ARE THE PUBLIC HEALTH ADVOCATES
AND ALLOW THEM TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS A SOME
APPLIED THEN THE DIRECTOR OF
STATE POLICY A PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES. TOGETHER WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DR ARAMBULA WE'RE
PROUD TO SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SIXTY WHICH WILL
PROVIDE A STRATEGY TO PLAN
ALLOCATE AND EXECUTE THE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF FUTURE
EMERGENCY FUNDING. TWO YEARS
INTO THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
DATA REVEALS THE PANDEMIC HAS
DONE IMMENSE HARM AND HAS IT HAD
AN UNEQUAL IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. LIKE THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC RESPONSE AND RECOVERY
EFFORTS ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
ALSO BEEN ON EQUAL. WE KNEW
GOING INTO THE PANDEMIC WHO
WOULD BEIMPACTED BECAUSE WE
WERE AWARE OF THE EXISTING
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC DISPARITIES
. UNFORTUNATELY OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SYSTEMS WERE NOT
PREPARED TO RESPOND TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT KOBE NINETEEN
PRODUCED THE PANDEMIC
HIGHLIGHTED THE IMPORTANCE OF
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
RESPONSE. THE PANDEMIC ALSO
REVEALED SIGNIFICANT CRACKS IN
THIS CRITICAL SYSTEM. THESE
LESSONS LEARNED OVER THE PAST
TWO YEARS HAVE TAUGHT US THAT WE
NEED TO PREPARE NOW. FOR THE
NEXT EMERGENCY. OUR GOAL GOAL
THROUGH A B. TWENTY THREE SIXTY
IS TO BRING TOGETHER KEY STATE
AND LOCAL PARTNERS TO DEVELOP
TOOLS AND PROTOCOLS FOR THE
ALLOCATION OF FUTURE EMERGENCY
FUNDING. TO REDUCE RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN RECOVERY RESPONSE
AND REPAIR EFFORTS. THE WORK
GROUP CREATED BY AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY WILL CREATE A PLAN FOR
ALLOCATING FUNDING DURING
EMERGENCIES THAT WILL COME BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR APPROVAL.
THE PLAN WILL CREATE THE
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE BY
PREPARING NOW FOR FUTURE CRISES
WITH THE RACE CONSCIOUS LANDS
AND COMMUNITY DRIVEN APPROACHES.
TO PUT OUR MOST HISTORICALLY
DISINVEST THE COMMUNITIES FIRST.
BUILDING RESILIENT COMMUNITIES
BY MAKING SMART AND SUSTAINABLE
INVESTMENTS BASED ON THE
EXISTING NEEDS OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
ESTABLISHING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
KEY BY PARK LEAD AND SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS BEFORE EMERGENCIES
HAPPEN. FINALLY I KNOW THAT
PEOPLE DID THE BEST THAT THEY
COULD TO RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC. THIS WAS AN
OVERWHELMING TASK FOR ALL OF US
AND ALL OF OUR STATE AND LOCAL
SYSTEMS HOWEVER. WE HAVE LEARNED
LESSONS FROM OUR SUCCESSES AND
OUR FAILURES WE MUST USE THESE
LESSONS TO CREATE AN EMERGENCY
FUNDING STRATEGY THAT BETTER
SERVES OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA. IF WE
FAIL TO DO SO EACH FUTURE
EMERGENCY WILL CREATE DEEPER
DISPARITIES THAT WILL BE EVEN
HARDER TO ADDRESS. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY AND
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
DON'T BELIEVE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- OTHERS
IN THE HEARING ROOM WHO MIGHT
WISH THIS EXPRESSIVE PORTER
OPPOSITION- PLEASE COME FORWARD
YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION
POSITION ON THE BILL. ANDREA
RIVERA WITH THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE BRANDON MARCH
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FREE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MR RODRIGUEZ.
YES I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. FOR TEST TODAY OFFICE YOU
YOU TALK ABOUT THE WITH THE
PANDEMIC IS DONE I THINK WE NEED
AS ROOM MOVE FORWARD IN
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES OF
DISASTER RESPONSE PREPAREDNESS.
I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT IN
WORST CASE SCENARIO RESPONDING
TO TWO MAJOR DISASTERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RIGHT
BECAUSE WE HAVE. THE FIRES
FLOODS AND WE ALWAYS HAVE THAT
EARTHQUAKE THAT'S LOOMING
ANYTIME THAT I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORT NOW LIKE TO BE OUT OF
THE COST OF POSSIBLE SO THANK
YOU LOOK FOR DISCORDANT THANKS.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE WE TAKE
AS A MOTION MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
OKAY THE SECOND BY MR MAYES.
ANYONE ELSE. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER RODRIGUEZ A SECOND BY MR
MAYES MOTION TO PASS THROUGH
CORPORATIONS WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
AFTER REGULAR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU- AS
OUR TRIP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHEN I WHEN I WALDRON WALDRON
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA AYE
BRAMBILLA AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW
NOT VOTING CARILLO. LARA LARA I
MAIENSCHEIN. MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY NAZARIAN. RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
GARCIA S. CI. SEVEN VOTES STILL
ON THE EDGE THERE- BUT ALSO OF
JUST TO MAKE A QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR DOCTOR IN THE
PLANET- PROCESSES LAST BILL-
PLEASE MEMBERS PLEASE COME DOWN
TO THE- OF COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOM SO WE CAN CONCLUDE OUR
BUSINESS ONE OF BILLS OF
PRESENTATIONS OF GENERAL GETTING
CLOSE TO THE END PLEASE COME ON
DOWN THANK YOU AND PLEASE GO
AHEAD DOCTOR ARAMBULA. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY WILL ADVANCE HEALTH
EQUITY BY CONNECTING
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED
CALIFORNIANS WITH TRUSTED
COMMUNITY MESSENGERS IN ORDER TO
HELP IN ROLE RETAIN AND
ENCOURAGE THE UTILIZATION OF
MEDICAL BENEFITS IN THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
CALIFORNIA IS LEADING THE WAY IN
EXPANDING ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE.
AS WE IMPLEMENT THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICAL INCLUDING THE MOST
RECENT HEALTH FOR ALL OLDER
ADULT EXPANSION. WE NEED TO
UTILIZE OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS
TO ENSURE THAT WE REACH EVERYONE
WHILE SERVING THE NEEDS OF THE
LINGUISTICALLY AND CULTURALLY
DIVERSE COMMUNITIES. AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY WILL ESTABLISH THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM TO EMPOWER COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OR CBO'S.
CBO'S ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED
TRAINED AND EXPERIENCED IN THE
COMMUNITY TO INCREASE OUR REACH
AND IMPACT TO HISTORICALLY
EXCLUDED COMMUNITIES. AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY WILL ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIANS BY CONDUCTING
TARGETED OUTREACH ENROLLMENT
RETENTION UTILIZATION AND ACCESS
ACTIVITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICAL. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY ARE
ANDREA RIVERA WHO IS THE SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR C. PAN
AND YERRY SEAN WHO IS THE CHIEF
OF PROGRAM INTEGRATION AND
COMMUNITY IMPACT AT THE KOREAN
COMMUNITY CENTER OF THE EAST BAY
. PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ANDREA RIVERA AND I'M THE SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK THE PLAN IS THE PROUD
SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
WHICH WILL ESTABLISH THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM THE PROGRAM WILL ENSURE
THAT EVERY DAY CALIFORNIANS WILL
HAVE ACCESS TO NAVIGATORS THAT
CAN HELP THE CAN HELP
INDIVIDUALS NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE MEDIC HEALTH
SYSTEM. AND SUPPORT WITH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE
TROUBLESHOOTING APPLICATIONS AND
ROLL MEANT RETENTION AND
UTILIZATION OF MEDICAL SERVICES
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AB
SEVENTY FOUR ESTABLISHED THE
MEDIC HOW HEALTH NAVIGATOR
PROGRAM UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THIS PILOT
PROGRAM WORKED WITH COUNTIES AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE OUTREACH EDUCATION
RETENTION AND UTILIZATION
SUPPORT TO SENIORS LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT. IMMIGRANTS
ON HOUSES AND OTHER KEY
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES HOWEVER
THE PILOT PROGRAM IS SET TO
EXPIRE ON JUNE THIRTIETH OF THIS
YEAR. AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY WILL
ESTABLISH A PERMANENT NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM UNDER DH CS THAT CAN
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THESE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES YOUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
MEDICAL SERVICE THE MAJORITY OF
THE STATE'S LOW INCOME LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENT. IMMIGRANTS
BLACK INDIGENOUS COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR AND THESE GROUPS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SEEK APPLICATION
SUPPORT FROM CBO'S WHERE THEY
CAN RECEIVE IN LANGUAGE
ASSISTANCE OR WORK WITH SOMEONE
WHO IS LIKELY TO COME FROM A
SIMILAR BACKGROUND. AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY WOULD REQUIRE DH CS
TO OVERSEE THE NAVIGATOR PROGRAM
AND WORK WITH THE FOUNDATION TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO ELIGIBLE
CBO'S. THE CBO'S WILL THEN BE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE TRAINING AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE SO THAT
THEY CAN WORK WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO COMPLETE MEDICAL
APPLICATIONS. OF CALIFORNIA
PREPARES TO WELCOME THOUSANDS OF
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS INTO
MEDIC HOW IT IS ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURE OUR STATE HAVE THE LONG
TERM INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT THE OUTCOMES WE WISH TO
SEE. AND PART OF THAT PLAN
SHOULD INCLUDE COMMUNITY HEALTH
NAVIGATORS. LASTLY AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE DH CS
TO PROVIDE SUPPORT. TO PROVIDE A
REPORT ON THE FEASIBILITY OF A
FUTURE SINGLE STREAMLINED
NAVIGATOR PROGRAM THAT IS
COMPRISED OF BOTH COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND DH CS NAVIGATORS.
ULTIMATELY WITH THE GOAL OF
FURTHER ALIGNING THESE TWO
ESSENTIAL NAVIGATOR PROGRAMS AND
FURTHER REDUCING BARRIERS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE ACCESS.
WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO VOTE I
ON AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF THE
SECOND WITNESS DR ABDULLAH. WHAT
WE ARE DOING ANY PHONE.
WITNESSES OKAY ALL RIGHT SO WITH
THAT WE WILL GO TO OF PEOPLE IN
THE HEARING ROOM IT JUST YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL LUCY QUINTANILLA ON
BEHALF OF MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. CINDY HILLARY
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
EVENING LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NICOLE
WATERMAN THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. DURING DINNER WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT IF. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS DAVID AND SALAS A MAP OF
THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. YOUR
SOME OF THE OTHER MALE PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING FAITH
FOR JUST WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH INSURANCE
PROFESSIONALS AND FORMERLY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS HERE WITH A BRIEF
POSITION IN BETWEEN OF SUPPORT
IF AMENDED WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
APPLAUD THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR
AND NAVIGATOR PARTNERS AGENTS
STAND ARM IN ARM DOING THE GOOD
WORK TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
BRINGING THOSE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR COVERAGE. INTO COVERAGE IN
UTILIZING THAT COVERAGE
PRESENTLY AGENTS ARE LEADING
COVERED CALIFORNIA ENROLLMENT
AND WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THOSE
SERVICES AND THAT INCLUDES
ENROLLING INDIVIDUALS WHO WALK
INTO THE DOOR AND A MEDIC CAL
SERVICES WE WOULD LIKE TO ASK
THE AGENT BE INCLUDED AS
POTENTIAL GRANTEES WITH THE
STATE RESOURCES. CONSIDERING
THAT AGENTS ARE PRESENTLY
RECEIVING NO COMPENSATION SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE TREATED FAIRLY
AND DOING THE GOOD WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TO ACHIEVE
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU I DOCTOR EMAIL IN YOUR
SPONSOR AND APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MOTION FROM THE COMMITTEE- WHAT
OF MOTIONS WILL WILL CALL THAT
MR RODRIGUEZ AND I MIGHT HAVE
BEEN MISTER SANTIAGO BUT I'M NOT
SURE BUT- WE'LL TAKE IT- WE HAVE
A WE HAVE A MOTION OF- BY.
EMOTION DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
VERY MUCH A SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL WHAT I WOULD AYE
WALDRON. WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. ARAMBULA HI
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NOT VOTING CARILLO. LARA. OR NOT
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN. MAYES. MAYES
NOT VOTING MCCARTY NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I REQUEST. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE GARCIA GARCIA I. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THIS RIVAS. AB AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. MEMBERS WE HAVE
AFTER THIS WE HAVE ONE BILL LEFT
SO PLEASE COME DOWN TO THE
HEARING ROOM.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MISTER RIVAS. IT CAN YOU PUSH
YOUR PUSH THE MIKE THERE PLEASE
SO. OKAY I THINK THAT'S BETTER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATE THE MOST
THE SECOND AND P THE FIRST ONE
I THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
ALL OF THE WORK THAT WENT INTO
THIS BILL. AND. THE BILL EIGHT
ONE EIGHT EIGHT TWO SIX TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY SO THAT
EMERGENCY RESPONSE AGENCIES
GONNA PROBABLY RIP UP OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR MAJOR SEISMIC
EVENT ON AND ENSURE THE SAFETY
OF OUR AND THE CONTINUITY OF
CRITICAL CARE FOR RESIDENTS.
EXISTING STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT
BY TWENTY THIRTY HOSPITAL
BUILDINGS BE DESIGNED OR
RETROFITTED A CONSTRUCTED TO
REMAIN STANDING AFTER MAJOR.
EARTHQUAKES AND ALSO REMAIN
CAPABLE OF PROVIDING SERVICES
AND CARE TO OUR RESIDENTS.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE HOSPITALS THAT HAVE NOT
YET MET THE TWENTY THIRTY
STANDARDS TO NOTIFY THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCIES AS WELL AS A HOSPITAL
LIBERALIZATION'S OTHER
COMPLIANCE STATUS. AND SUBMIT A
LIST OF SERVICES PROVIDED EACH
BUILDING OF THE HOSPITAL TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
INFORMATION IN ADDITION
HOSPITALS WOULD BE REQUIRED TO
POST NOTICES OTHER SEISMIC
COMPLIANCE STATUS IN PUBLIC
AREAS- AND FOR THE MOST PART WE
ARE VERY FORTUNATE- A VERY
FORTUNATE HAVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CARE WHEN WE NEED IT. I AM
CLEARLY HERE IN AUSTIN
CALIFORNIA WE SOUGHT TO ENSURE
THAT OUR ACCESS TO MEDICAL CARE
WILL BE COMPROMISED. I SHOULDN'T
UNPREDICTABLE DISASTERS SUCH AS
EARTHQUAKES I KNOW THAT THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
TIMELINE TO COMPLY WITH THE
TWENTY THIRTY A SEISMIC SAFETY
STANDARDS. I WOULD BE HERE TO
TESTIFY ARE DUG SUBER'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PRUSSIA FIREFIGHTERS
AND DEVON LOMBARD WITH- IS IT.
THE DIGGING COAL. STRUCTURAL
ENGINEERS ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST OF SERVERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. CALIFORNIA'S FIRE SERVICES
ALL RISK RESPONDING TO A VARIETY
OF INCIDENTS SUCH AS FIRES CALL
FOR MEDICAL AID AND NATURAL
DISASTERS SUCH AS EARTHQUAKES.
WITH THE EARTHQUAKE RESTING RISK
IN MIND IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
HAVE ON GOING TRANSPARENCY AS IT
RELATES TO THE STATUS. OF
SEISMIC SAFETY OF HOSPITALS AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO WILL PROVIDE
THAT TRANSPARENCY BY ENSURING
THAT STATE. LOCAL AGENCIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE ROBUST
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CURRENT
SEISMIC SAFETY STATUS OF THESE
HOBBIES FACILITIES. MORE DATA
WILL IMPROVE SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS FOR FIREFIGHTERS AND
BOOST AMERICANS THE RESPONSE
INSURING OUR HOSPITALS ARE
SEISMICALLY SAFE IS IMPORTANT
MAKE CERTAIN FIREFIGHTERS CAN
TRANSPORT PATIENTS TO. AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT AND
TRANSFER CARE OFFICIALLY IN
ORDER TO RETURN TO THE FIELD TO
HELP THE NEXT COMMUNITY MEMBER
AND NEED FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I'VE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE GO
AHEAD SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M DEVON
NUMBERED PRACTICE INSTRUCTION
AND ENGINEER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
I'M HERE IS POLICY CO CHAIR FOR
THE STRUCTURES OF STATION
CALIFORNIA. WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS BRING FORWARD THIS
LEGISLATION. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRS ARTICULATION OF THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY RURAL
HOSPITALS. IN CALIFORNIA.
EXISTING LAW THE OFFERED E.
ALQUIST HOSPITAL FACILITIES SUCH
HE OFFERED ALQUIST HOSPITAL
FACILITIES SEISMIC SAFETY ACT OF
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE AS WELL AS
SENATE BILL NINETEEN FIFTY THREE
OF NINETEEN NINETY FOUR INTEND
THE GENERAL Q. CARE INPATIENT
HOSPITAL FACILITIES B. AS
FUNCTIONAL AS POSSIBLE.
FOLLOWING A DAMAGING EARTHQUAKE.
EXCELLENT FUNCTIONAL AS
PRACTICAL THE LAUNCHERS
CALIFORNIANS THAT BY TWENTY
THIRTY CALIFORNIA INPATIENT
MEDICARE MEDICAL CARE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE AFTER A
MAJOR EARTHQUAKE A CONDITION
THAT WAS NOT MET WHEN HOSPITALS
CLOSED FOLLOWING EARTHQUAKES IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR. AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO
REQUIRES HOSPITAL OWNERS TO TEST
ANNUALLY TO THEIR AS THEIR
OBLIGATION TO MEET THE TWENTY
THREE DEADLINE. AND TO NOTIFY
PUBLIC OF ANY. COMPLIANCE
FAILURES. IN THIS INTEREST ALL
THE FURTHER QUESTIONS AND IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME ALL THE FOR TO
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THESE
COMPORT. YOU CAN SET UP THEIR P.
LIKE AFTER YOU DID YOU ACCEPT
THE MENU DID NOT ACCEPT THE
MEMBER DID YOU EXPECT THE
MEMBERS OKAY WILL. FORMALLY
ACCEPT THE MENACE THANK YOU. THE
PUSH THE BUTTON ALL RIGHT EVERY
EFFORT START SORRY. GOOD EVENING
CATHERINE SCOTT CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION- AS STATED
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS HAVE
SPENT ABOUT A BILLIONS TO MEET
THE CURRENT REQUIREMENT BY THAT
TWENTY THIRTY REQUIREMENT WHICH
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
HOSPITALS COLLAPSE AFTER A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE. WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE NEXT REQUIREMENT TO TWENTY
THIRTY REQUIREMENTS AND I STAYED
IN A RAM REPORT JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO WAS YEARS BEFORE RECENT
CONSTRUCTION ESCALATION COST WAS
A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS TO
MEET THE TWENTY THIRTY
REQUIREMENT TO ENSURE WERE FULLY
OPERATIONAL. WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND SOME OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS WERE DRESSED WHICH
RELATED TO THE WAY IN WHICH WE
REPORT BUT THE BIGGEST A MOMENT
FOR US IS REALLY ADDRESSING THAT
TWENTY THIRD REQUIREMENT FOR US
IT'S A DIFFICULT TO. REPORT TO
THE LOCAL ENTITIES WHEN MANY OF
OUR HOSPITALS 52% ACTUALLY
ACCORDING TO REACH RECENT
KAUFMAN HALL REPORT ARE IN THE
RED IT WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT
FOR THEM TO IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO
MEET THE REBUILD REQUIREMENTS
HUNDRED PLUS BILLION DOLLARS TO
REBUILD THOSE HOSPITALS SO MANY
IN YOUR BACKYARD. RULE HOSPITALS
URBAN HOSPITALS WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO MEET THIS REQUIREMENT AND WE
HAVE OFFERED AN ALTERNATIVE- AT
LAST YEAR WITH THE MINISTRATION.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY HAVE NOT
REACHED AGREEMENT ON WHICH WOULD
ALLOW US TO FOCUS ON THE
EMERGENCY ROOMS POST DISASTER
THAT THEY ARE FULLY OPERATIONAL.
AND THEN REQUIRE US TO LOOK AT
AGAIN THOSE BUILDINGS THAT MIGHT
HAVE MADE THAT REQUIREMENT
THROUGH A HAS ITS ALTERNATE
OBSERVATIONS SO THIS WOULD.
BRING THAT COST DOWN BUT ALLOW
US TO MAINTAIN THOSE EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN THE EVENT OF AN
EMERGENCY- SO IT FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK YOU OPPOSE THE
BILL MUST AMENDED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL PLEASE JUST COME FORWARD
AND- YOUR NAME POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- JANET SO MY ONLY A
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IT
WE ARE CO SPONSORS OUR SPONSORS
ACTUALLY OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
. YEAH THANK YOU THAT'S NOT UP
TO THIS YEAR'S DAY COUNTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. KEITH
THE MAMODO CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR RETIRED AMERICANS AND SPORT
THANK YOU. KELLY BROOKS- ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
WE HAVE A CONCERNS POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ABOUT HER
CONCERNS POSITION BEFORE SO-
WE'LL HAVE THAT OUR GLOSSARY SO
BUT- BUT TAKEN IT WORKS I THINK
WE GET IT SO- THREE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISTER RODRIGUEZ. THANK
YOU MA'AM SOME REMEMBER REQUEST
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING SOME POOR
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD PROVIDE I
KNOW NOTICE REQUIREMENTS FOR
LOCAL OFFICES OF MERCHANT
SERVICES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND
BERMAN. AND OTHER STATE PARTIES
WHOSE JURISDICTION THE
HOSPITAL'S BELONGS BUILDINGS ARE
LOCATED UNDERSTAND HOSPITALS TO
HAVE SEVEN YEARS TO MEET THE
TWENTY THIRTY SEISMIC STANDARD
DEADLINE BY CALIFORNIA IS DUE
FOR A MAJOR EARTHQUAKE AND I'M
CONCERNED WE NAY WE MAY NOT BE
PREPARED. NOT ONLY WERE THESE
NOTICES YOUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
HOSTILE STAFF AND THE PUBLIC ARE
WHERE THE HOSPITAL'S COMPLIANCE
WITH THE TWENTY THIRTY STANDARDS
BUT I BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL
HELP START THE CONVERSATIONS
WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
REGARDING MARKETING PLANNING AND
RESPONSE PREPARATION FOR WHEN
THAT MAJOR EARTHQUAKE HAPPENS.
FOR THOSE REASONS ARE PROBABLY
JOINING AS A JOINT CO AUTHOR NOW
LOOK FOR SPORTING IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE. WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ A SECOND BY MR
SANTIAGO MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS WHICH
LIKE CLOSENESS REAVIS- REALLY-
APPRECIATE THE OPT IN BEER AND-
BUT THAT'S WHEN I BOUGHT THIS
YEAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WOOD. I WOULD I WALDRON. WALDRON
NOT VOTING AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BRAMBILLA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NO CARILLO. LARA OR NOT VOTING.
MAIENSCHEIN MAYES MAYES NOT
BOATING MCCARTY. NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN I REQUEST. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE GARCIA GARCIA HI. OVER ONE
SEVEN ONE HERE WE GO AGAIN SO-
MEMBERS WHO OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
ARE NOT PRESENT WE ARE ON THE
LAST SEGMENT PRESENTING THE LAST
BILL PLEASE COME DOWN HERE SO WE
CAN CONCLUDE OUR BUSINESS.
MISTER CHAIR. THERE'S BEEN A
SMALL WAGER PLACED ON WHAT TIME
THIS COMMITTEE WAS GOING TO BE
OUT AND- I AM RUNNING
SIGNIFICANTLY SHORT SO I REQUEST
DATA. A SMALL READING OF ERNEST
HEMINGWAY'S OLD MAN TO SEE. THAT
THE APPROPRIATE. WITH THAT THAT
WOULD BE A FILIBUSTER AND WE
DON'T DO THAT.
THE MOTION IS SECOND HERE- I'M
GONNA SLOW DOWN FOR MR MR FLORA
. GOOD EVENING. ADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING AT TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- THREE OF US WHO
IS IT WAS NOT WITH US TODAY I
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS
DESCRIBED ON PAGE SIX AB TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX ESTABLISHES THE
EXTREME HEAT AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE PROGRAM TO COORDINATE
THE ACTIVITIES OF THE STATE IN
INCENTIVIZE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
LOCAL COMPREHENSIVE HEAT ACTION
PLANS TO PROTECT COMMUNITIES
FROM EXTREME HEAT. BILLABLE
ESTABLISHED EXTREME HEAT
HOSPITALIZATION AND DEATH
REPORTING SYSTEM WILL HELP THE
STATE BETTER UNDERSTAND WORK
STREAM HEAT ILLNESSES AND DEATHS
ARE OCCURRING YOU'RE HERE WE
HAVE WITNESSED A RECORD BREAKING
MAKING HEAT WAVES THAT HAVE LED
TO MORE HUMAN SUFFERING
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS AND DEATHS
LAST FALL THE L. A. TIMES
RELEASED A SERIES OF STORIES
RELATED TO EXTREME HEAT AND
CONCLUDED THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONICALLY UNDERCOUNTS HEAT
RELATED ILLNESS AND DEATH WITH
NO WAY OF TRACKING MEASURABLE
AND FOR MEASURING IMPACTS. LA
REPORT RECENTLY RELEASED-
HIGHLIGHTS CLIMATE CHANGE-INDUCED HEALTH IMPACTS THAT
SPECIFICALLY MENTIONS EXTREME
HEAT AS BEING ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT FACTORS IMPACTING
CALIFORNIA. BEING TRANSITION
EXTREME EXTREME SPRING HEAT IS A
GROWING PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
LOADING THE INCOME AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR HUMAN
IMPACT MUST BE EVALUATED AND
PROPERLY UNDERSTOOD
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO NOT HAVE
ACCURATE REAL TIME DATA ON HOW
HUMAN LIVES ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY EXTREME HEAT
CONTINUE TO ENACT ACTION WILL
INCREASE ILLNESSES EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS AND SADLY PREMATURE
AND AVOIDABLE DEATHS AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SEVENTY SIX. IS
NEED TO ENSURE THE STATE HAS A
TRUE UNDERSTANDING OF THE HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT ARE CAUSED BY
EXTREME HEAT. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR- YOUR VOTE
I CAN START WITH. L. TWO CITIES
IF YOU WISH AT THIS POINT OR
WEAKENED. OKAY APPARENTLY NOT
ALL RIGHT. IT WAS THE BEST OF
TIMES IT WAS THE WORST OF. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
SOUNDGARDEN WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES AND SUPPORT. ANY
OPPOSITION. THING NONE WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS DR. I JUST WANNA- WHEN
IT'S APPROPRIATE ASK THE AUTHOR
IF I CAN JOIN AS A CO AUTHOR AS
I BELIEVE THAT EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS AND THE COLLECTION OF
DATA AREVITALLY IMPORTANT FOR
US TO TRACK I'M CERTAINLY OFFER
WITH. WOULD WELCOME THAT THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE TO HAVE A
MOTION DO. WE DO OKAY. A MOTION
AND A SECOND TO PASS. AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CALLS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE WALDRON AYE
WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA RAMBLE
I BIGELOW. RIO LAURA LAURA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY. THIS
AREA THIS AREA I REVERSE.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA GARCIA HI.
LIMON IS ZERO ELEVEN ZERO HOW WE
HAVE A BILL OUT OKAY- WE DO HAVE
A CONSECUTIVE- OKAY A MONTH I
WILL READ THEM THE BILLS ON THE
CONSENT COUNTERTERRORIST WHAT
WHAT IS YOUR OVER UNDER MR FOR.
WHAT. I WAS REALLY PACKAGE. THIS
REALLY BAD. OKAY RIGHT. OKAY ALL
RIGHT- SO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS LIGHT THERE'S NO WAY I CAN
SEE DELAY UNTIL TWELVE FORTY
FIVE AND NO DESIRE TO DO THAT-
THE ITEM NUMBER THE SECOND
pSECOND OR CLUES ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY ONE. ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B. NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
AB TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED UNDER
EIGHTEEN AB TWENTY SIX THIRTY
SIX A NUMBER TWENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY NINE. AM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTEEN. ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
THREE. ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR
AB TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY FIVE. I
REMEMBER THIRTY FIVE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE. ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY SIX AB TWENTY
NINETY SIX ITEM NUMBER FORTY ONE
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX. A
NUMBER FORTY FOUR AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX ITEM NUMBER
FORTY FIVE AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY SIX AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT AND ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTEEN. WE HAD A WE HAD A
MOTION. AND A WE HAVE WE HAD WE
HAD MOTIONS AND WE HAD MODE WE
HAVE MOTION BY DOCTOR AND THE
SECOND BY MR SANTIAGO. PASS A
CONSENT CALENDAR AND SECRETARY
PLEASE. UNLESS MR FLOOR WANTS TO
PULL ALL THESE ITEMS FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. YOU SURE GOING
GOING GONE MEDICAID PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL QUICKLY WOULD I WOULD I
WALDRON WALDRON AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGAR CURRY I ARAMBULA RAMBLE I
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
LARA OR I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY. NAZARIAN LIVE THERE AND
I RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA RCI. ZERO TWELVE ZERO OKAY WE STILL
GOT A COUPLE MEMBERS MISSING SO
IF THEY COULD PLEASE COME DOWN
IT WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL. I
CAN'T ADJOURN THE MEETING UNTIL
TWELVE FORTY FIVE APPARENTLY SO%
I GUESS MAYBE THEY HAVE PLENTY
OF TIME- SO WE'RE GONNA START AT
THE TOP OF THE- TOP THE AGENDA
AND ARE UNER A SPECIAL ORDER
BUSINESS I'M NUMBER ONE. WE
CAN'T DO ONE OR TWO. OR THREE
ONE TWO A CLOSED NEVER MIND SO-
I REMEMBER THREE. AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY TWO BY MR SANTIAGO PLEASE.
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I.
BIGELOW BIGELOW NO RIO.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE GARCIA
GARCIA I. ELEVEN TO ONE ELEVEN
TO ONE THAT BILLS OUT ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY EIGHTY
WOOD PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I. RIO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
I IN THIS AREA. NAZARIAN I RIVAS
. GARCIA RCI. AND THE THREE TEN
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB NINETEEN FORTY-
MISTER SALAS PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WALDRON. WALDRON NOT VOTING.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW
BIGELOW NO CARILLO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I MCCARTY MCCARTY I
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA
GARCIA HI. NINETY TO NINETY TWO
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY ONE
BY MISTER SALAS PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WALDRON WALDRON I. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE
CARILLO. MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I MCCARTY MCCARTY I RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA GARCIA I.
THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN BY DOCTOR WEBER PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO CARILLO
LAURA LAURA NO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I MCCARTY MCCARTY I
IN THIS AREA. MISSOURIAN NOT
VOTING. RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
AYE GARCIA GARCIA I. NINE THE
THREE NINE THREE AND THAT GOES
OUT ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY TWO BY DR WEBBER PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARAMBULA RAMBLE I
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
HELLO LAURA LAURA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES. MAYES NOT
VOTING MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS
AREA THIS AREA AND I RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I GARCIA GARCIA I.
ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FOUR BY DR WEBER PLEASE LET THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CARILLO LARA OR LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA NAZARIAN
AYE RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA
GARCIA HI RIO. RIO I. IN THE
THREE AND A THREE THAT BILLS OUT
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTEEN BY US ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO LARA OR NOT
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA THE VERY
AND I RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
GARCIA. GARCIA I. WELL TO ONE
TWELVE TO ONE THAT BILL IS OUT
EIGHT ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WALDRON WALDRON I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO
. LARA. LARA NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I MAYES. MAYES NOT
VOTING MCCARTY. MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN THE SYRIAN ARMY RIVAS
SANTIAGO MONTERO AYE GARCIA RCI. ELEVEN THE TWO ELEVEN TO TWO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN- AB
NINETEEN THIRTY BY DOCTOR
ARAMBULA PLEASE LIFT THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I RIO
. RIO I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS
AREA. THE SYRIAN ARMY RIVAS
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. THIRTEEN A
ONE THIRTEEN ONE THAT PHYLLIS
OUT ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY BY DR
ARAMBULA PLEASE WITH THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I. RIO
RIO I MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN. THE SYRIAN I REVERSE.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. I'M SORRY
OH NO NO NO. RIGHT YEAH YEAH
YEAH YEAH. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTEEN ZERO SO- ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
BY DOCTOR REGULAR PLEASE LET THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I. RIO
CORREO I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I. MCCARTY MCCARTY I REQUEST.
ELEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
AB TWENTY NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WALDRON WATER NOW. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY I ARAMBULA RAMBLE I
BIGELOW BIGELOW NO. LARA. OR NOT
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO OKAY GO
AYE GARCIA RCI. AND THE TO TEND
TO THAT BILLS OUT ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY ONE AB TWENTY NINETY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WALDRON WALDRON AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA RAMBLE I BIGELOW
BIGELOW I LARA. LARA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
INEZ. NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ NONVOTING
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. THIRTEEN
ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER BRIAN
PLEASED WITH THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING
. MAYES MAYES AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING SANTIAGO
WHATEVER I GARCIA RCI. ELEVEN TO
ONE ELEVEN TO ONE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALDERON PLEASE LET THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO. LARA. LARA NO MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. RIVAS
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I GARCIA
GARCIA I. ELEVEN A THREE LEVEL
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE PLEASE OPEN
THE AB TWENTY TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NO. MAYES AB
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE. MAYES AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY I REQUEST. GARCIA GARCIA
I. WELL TO ONE TWELVE TO ONE
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB TWENTY
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WALDRON. OVER NOT VOTING
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO CARILLO I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES I'M SORRY
I HAVE YOU. NUMBER EIGHT RT
MCCARTY I RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE GARCIA RCI. AND THE TO SEND
IT TO THE BILL WAS OUT ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
NOW LARA OR NOT VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES. WHEN I FORTY EIGHT AM.
OKAY I WAS AND I WITH AN ASSIST
BY MULTIPLE MEMBERS JUST FOR THE
RECORD MCCARTY. MCCARTY I IN
THIS AREA. THE VERY AND I RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. YES TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT. ELEVEN A ONE
ELEVEN THE BILL'S OUT LEVIN A
ONE ITEM NUMBER TWO IS NOT. A
NUMBER TWENTY NINE AB TWENTY SIX
SEVENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW
AYE LAURA LAURA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
OF HERE ARE FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
TWO AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY PLEASE LET
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY ONE BIGELOW
AYE FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES MAYES AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I FOURTEEN ZERO. HOW
MANY WITHOUT SORRY FOR FOURTEEN
ZERO I WAS DISTRACTED THERE'S A
LACK OF IN HOUSE. ARE WE OKAY
NOW. YOU'RE YOU'RE WITH FOR A
WHILE HERE. ALL RIGHT THAT'S
GOOD BECAUSE MR FLOORS HOPING
YOU'LL DELAY FOR ABOUT FOUR
HOURS AND SOMETHING MINUTES. IT
CAN HAPPEN UP. ENOUGH WELL IT'S
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT WAITING SO
ANYWAY ITEM NUMBER THIRTY THREE
AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE BY MR
LEVINE PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I RIO. HI FLORA FLORA
NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING MCCARTY
MCCARTY I RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
I. ELEVEN TO TWO SEVENTY TWO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY TWENTY. TWENTY TWO. AB
TWO TWO TWO ZERO. BY MISTER
MURATSUCHI PLEASE LET THE CALL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I CARILLO. I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ. RODRIGUEZ NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA
RCI. WELL TO ONE OF THE ONE.
THAT BILLS OUT ADAM NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY THREE BY MISTER NAZARIAN
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I CARILLO- I FLORA.
FLORA HIGH MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MAYES. MAYES AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
NINE AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX BY
MISTER NAZARIAN PLEASE LET THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
ARAMBULA RAMBLE I CARILLO RIO
AYE FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I MCCARTY. MCCARTY I
RIVAS SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
GARCIA FIRSTLY I FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO A BILLS OUT ITEM
NUMBER FORTY- AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN BY MISTER RAMOS PLEASE
WITH THE CALLING CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WALDRON. AT TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN. WALDRON I
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
CARILLO RIO I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY
I RIVAS SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
GARCIA. GARCIA HI FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
TWO AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ROBERT RIVAS PLEASE LIFT THE
CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS RIO
. I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
MCCARTY MCCARTY I RIVAS. AND THE
ONE AND A ONE THE BILL IS OUT
ITEM NUMBER FORTY THREE PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BIGELOW. FORTY THREE.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING CARILLO. YOUR
ITEM NUMBER FORTY THREE. I THANK
YOU I MCCARTY MCCARTY I REVERSE
. THIRTEEN ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO
THEN FINALLY ITEM NUMBER FORTY
EIGHT- PLEASE LISTEN AB TWENTY
TWENTY NINE WEEKS PLEASE LIFT
THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOW LARA. OR NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN HI MAYES. MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA
THE VERY AND I RIVAS. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE GARCIA GARCIA I.
THANK YOU IS GARCIA. ELEVEN A
TWO. BUT YES. ABOUT CHANGE. FILE
ITEM TWENTY VOTE CANGE FOR MR
FLOOR FILE ITEM TWENTY. TWENTY
NINETY ONE YES THANK YOU. NOT
VOTING TO NOT VOTING TO KNOW A
NUMBER TWENTY FOR MR LARA ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY AB TWENTY NINETY
ONE. NOT VOTING TO NARROW. LARA
NOT VOTING TO KNOW. THE TICKET
AFTER THE THREE THAT'S TEN TO
THREE OKAY THANK YOU. OKAY WITH
THE BACK END OF HIS CAREER WE'VE
GOT SOME THINGS TO FILL IN FOR
MISS CARILLO AND IT. I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS MCCARTY. DID YOU
OKAY ALL RIGHT SO- NUMBER ONE
AND TWO WERE WERE VOTED OUT WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING WITH THOSE
ANYMORE. ITEM NUMBER. THREE AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY TWO OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AREA. I RIVAS. A ONE FOR ONE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AB
TWENTY EIGHTY. MARIA I. RIVAS.
ELEVEN TO THREE SEVENTY THREE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB NINETEEN
FORTY SALAS PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MARIA I. RIVAS. SENATOR A. B. S. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY ONE MISTER SALAS PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AREA. I REQUEST.
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO A
NUMBER EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
SEVEN BY DOCTOR WEBER PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS AREA. I. RIVAS AND THREE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY TWO BY DR WEBBER PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AREA. I RIVAS. ZERO ZERO
CONSENT CALENDAR- DID YOU I
THINK I THINK. I THINK YOU ARE
THE S. SO- THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AREA. I MCCARTY
MCCARTY I REQUEST. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO AND THEN ITEM
NUMBER TEN A. B. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FOUR BY DR WEBBER PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. I THINK THAT'S WHERE IT
SAYS WERE GOOD. I HAVE EVERYBODY
ON YEAH SO I THINK WE'RE GOOD.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALRIGHT
WITH THAT WE WILL CLOSE THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.